I'm gonna say again I would absolutely
anchor my physiology with morning
sunlight viewing you know what's special
about morning sunlight there's a group
at the University of Washington and
they've discovered that the cells in
your eye the neurons that set your
circadian clock make you alert during
the day and make you sleepy at night and
so on those cells respond best to yellow
blue contrast and orange tones when you
go out in the morning even if it's not
at Sunrise but it's close to Sunrise or
you look at the sun in the evening what
you'll see is yellow blue contrast or
orange yellow that's not the color of
light that you're going to see when the
sun is overhead now this also is really
interesting because artificial lights at
least to my understanding even the
daylight simulators have not picked up
on this it's just about bright light
someone ought to design something that
can mimic this but nature has done this
beautifully for us hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I quit I'm
a business partner I struggled to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Andrew huberman enjoy
viewing low solar angle sunlight in the
morning and in the evening is most
effective because of those yellow blue
contrast now here's the really wild
thing
those circuits that set your levels of
alertness and sleep yes they respond
best to yellow blue contrast but what
that tells us is crazy what that means
is that color vision
was probably not related to color
perception first because all of that is
completely subconscious the pathways
that do this are present in people who
are pattern Vision blind
so what do I mean I mean that color
vision likely evolved from a need to
synchronize your internal state with the
external world and the best stimulus in
the outside world to do that is yellow
blue contrast in other words our ability
to detect color was first and foremost
and we understand this based on
evolutionary genomics and so forth
to extract time of day information not
color of fruit or color of skin or
anything like that that's all secondary
which is wild and crazy and this is yet
another example of the way we think
things work is not the way they work
it's completely 180 degrees opposite and
I'm just going to give you a little
teaser I had a guest on the podcast he
hasn't we haven't aired the episode yet
his name is Eric Jarvis he works on
speech and language he also was admitted
in the Alvin Ailey Dance Company again
who are these people he's a professor at
the Rockefeller anyway
I learned from Eric and you'll learn
when that episode comes out that you
only find elaborate speech and language
in species that also engage in dance and
song and the genomics point to the fact
that song and singing came first and
language came second
and that led me during that episode of
the podcast I wrote down in my notes I
was listening to him talk and I wrote
down in my notebook it's just scrawled
in big letters it says I am so happy
right now
I was just blown away I couldn't and it
makes so much sense when you hear it
that the colors in the sky were what we
our system is trying to extract not a
perception of those colors in the sky
because they're informing us about time
and orienting Us in time that song and
the communication of emotional states
would be simpler and more foundational
than communication about specific
patterns of language
when you hear it suddenly it makes sense
but of course we're human beings and
unless you're Eric Jarvis or Ali Crum or
Anna Lemke you think about all this
stuff backwards one of the reasons why
breathing is such a powerful tool for
shifting one state
is that a it's always available
for voluntary control it's just right
there you can I can decide right now to
do three inhales
or I can just go back to breathing
reflexively I can just do that in any
moment so the the neural architect you
know real estate which is in the brain
stem that controls breathing is in a
unique position because it's at the kind
of boundary between conscious control
and unconscious control I can't do that
for my digestion I can't do that for
most most everything that happens
internally the other thing is that
breathing controls our level of
alertness very dramatically So the
faster you breathe generally the more
alert you are the slower you breathe the
more calm you're going to be the faster
you breathe meaning shorter quick
breaths or either way
so we're just to take a brief
um Adventure through the the
Neuroscience of breathing and how it
relates to brain States and and there's
some fun Tools in here so forgive me for
this tangent but you have two brain
areas that are responsible for breathing
one is called for the aficionados the
pre-butt singer complex it was
discovered by Jack Feldman at UCLA it's
named after a bottle of wine so now you
people won't forget it and it controls
rhythmic breathing so inhale exhale
inhale exhale it's just rhythmic
breathing there's another brain area
that controls breathing which is near
What's called the parafatial nucleus
which involves breathing anytime there
are double inhales or double exhales or
triple inhales you say well why would
you have this second brain area for
breathing Well turns out when you're
speaking or crying or coughing you need
to coordinate your breathing with your
speaking and that means sometimes you
need to take multiple inhales or
multiple exhales and this is all
happening very very fast you don't
notice but there's a very important
discovery that was made a few years ago
by Jack's lab and by a guy named Mark
krasno at Stanford
who discovered there's a set of neurons
in your brain stem mind brainstem
everybody's brain stem and every animal
every mammal's brain stem it's a very
small number of neurons that controls a
specific pattern of breathing which are
called physiological size
so these are not just size where you go
and exhale these are size that involve
doing two inhales and then an extended
exhale we all do this you do this during
sleep anytime carbon dioxide levels in
your bloodstream get too high
in order to get more oxygen into your
system people also do this if they've
been crying or sobbing they'll do this
and then they'll exhale so what's
happening with these physiological sides
and why is this powerful so your lungs
are two big bags of air but they
actually are made up of a ton of little
sacks of air called the alveoli of the
lungs when we are exercising or when we
are sleeping or anytime we're doing
anything these these little sacks of air
eventually start to collapse and what
happens is carbon dioxide builds up on
our system and we experience that as
stress we actually feel the impulse to
breathe because carbon dioxide levels
get too high there are neurons that
sense carbon dioxide and then
without realizing it you do the double
inhale
and then exhale typically the inhales
are done through the nose and the exhale
is done through the mouth so it looks
like
and why the second inhale well if you've
ever tried to blow up a balloon for a
kid a kid's party you're just blowing up
a balloon you sometimes blow into that
empty balloon what do you do you do two
in you do two you go and then it pops
open so these double inhales pop open
the alveoli of the lungs they don't
explode them but they pop them open
which pulls carbon dioxide out of the
bloodstream brings oxygen and then you
offload carbon dioxide so if you watch a
dog right before it takes a nap or
something it often will do these now
what's cool about these physiological
size is from work in our lab and that's
still ongoing I just want to say it's
still ongoing but work in other labs as
well double inhales followed by an
extended exhale are the fastest way that
I'm aware of to bring the mind and the
body into a more relaxed State really
yeah it is the fastest way so if I'm
stressed I'm overwhelmed I'm just doing
three or two two inhales through the
nose
and then exhale slow through the middle
one to three of those repeated will
bring your level of autonomic arousal
down
basically to Baseline there's a much
better way to maintain ongoing action
toward a goal that also involves
visualization but it turns out it's not
about visualizing success it's about
visualizing failure the balcattis lab
and other labs have looked at whether or
not people make progress toward goals of
different types whether or not they are
thinking about the goal they're thinking
about that goal line and what they want
to achieve that long-term goal and all
the wonderful things associated with it
or whether or not they're thinking about
all the ways in which they could fail
and route to that goal right this is not
typically what we are encouraged to do
typically we are told don't imagine
failure push failure out of your mind
only focus on success you know fake it
till you make it or it's a phrase that I
absolutely hate frankly because it's not
even clear what that means and it's
unclear what the ethical form of that is
I think it means continue despite any
anxiety or fear that things won't work
out but if you look at the literature
the scientific literature what the bowel
status lab and other labs have shown is
that there's a near doubling near
doubling in the probability of reaching
one's goal if you focus routinely on
foreshadowing failure you think about
the ways in which things could fail if
you take action a or you take action B
and instead therefore you take action C
you're supposed to think about how
things could fail if you don't get up
and run each morning if your goal is say
a fitness goal so let's use that as an
example because even though I realize
people are in pursuit of many things not
just Fitness fitness goals and physical
goals are a very concrete thing that we
can all get on the same page about
because they're related to actions let's
say somebody that sets a goal of running
five miles four times a week minimum and
as many as seven four times a week
minimum before 8 A.M okay in a previous
podcast on habits I talked about the
benefits of not necessarily setting
specific times that one will do things
but setting time blocks that one will do
things so you say before 8 AM you're
gonna run five miles and that's gonna
happen up to seven days a week okay
one version of this would be okay sit
back in a chair and think about how
great you're going to feel and look if
you're doing this every day how your
health is going to improve how
everything's going to be your blood
markers of lipids Etc are going to
improve okay fine that's the
visualization goal of visualizing the
end point turns out that is far less
effective and maybe even
counterproductive compared to thinking
about what's going to happen if you
don't do this the negative Health
outcomes that are going to occur the
disappointment you're going to have in
yourself the fact that you're going to
wait until 7 30 that's not long enough
for many people to run five miles you go
to put it on your shoes it can be
pouring rain or even hailing or snowing
outside and now you're not going outside
unless you're somebody who's
particularly motivated to do that okay
so foreshadowing failure turns out to be
the best way to motivate toward goal
pursuit in fact as I mentioned before
there's a near doubling in the
likelihood that people will reach goals
of any kind when they're constantly
thinking about how bad it's going to be
if they fail if we think back to the
neural circuit associated with a
assessing value in our goal Pursuits
this makes perfect sense the amygdala
that center of the brain that's involved
in anxiety and fear and worry well the
amygdala is one of the four core
components of our goal setting and goal
Pursuit circuitry and there's no
bypassing that there is no one listening
to this or watching this whose amygdala
is not involved in their goal setting
and goal Pursuit behavior and so while
I'd love to be able to tell you that all
you should think about is rainbows and
puppies and all the wonderful rewarding
things that are going to happen when you
achieve your goals
the truth is you should be thinking
mainly about how bad it's really going
to get if you don't do it how
disappointing yourself you're going to
feel how
it will negatively impact you if not in
the immediate term in the long term if
indeed your goal is to reach your goal
so I want to emphasize that I'm not
interested in encouraging people to
flagellate themselves I'm encouraging
people to
achieve their goals and it turns out the
best way to do that is by foreshadowing
failure and the more specific you can
get by writing down or thinking about or
talking about how bad it will be if you
don't achieve your goals the more likely
you are to achieve those goals also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there if we are in a pretty relaxed
state or if we are happy we generally
feel like we we can do what we want to
do we can maneuver through our
environment we can make choices that are
reasonable but oftentimes we're not in
relaxed and happy States that's just
part of The Human Experience obviously
and there is a fundamental feature to
the nervous system which is this thing
they call the autonomic nervous system
which is just fancy nerd speak for the
components of your nervous system that
raise your levels of alertness or bring
them way down sometimes we hear fight or
flight rest and digest but this system
governs all that but a lot more and
basically what happens is when we are at
the extremes of the autonomic what I
call seesaw of very very alert to the
point of being really stressed or
panicked or concerned or if we are very
close to sleep and we're drowsy and
we're exhausted
at those
points along the autonomic nervous
system
our thoughts become a bit like a runaway
train you know if you're very upset it's
hard to talk yourself out of it if
you're stressed it's hard to think
yourself out of it in fact you can start
doing all sorts of third personing and
rationalization you can call someone you
can text somebody it's very hard to get
yourself out of those states with
thinking alone
but the beauty of the autonomic nervous
system is that it traverses the brain
and the body and it connects to
essentially all the organs of the body
and it's a two-way street such that
certain behaviors even certain patterns
of breathing
Etc allow us to shift where we are on
the autonomic Continuum between very
very alert and stressed and very calm
and thereby give our mind a shift also
in terms of the kinds of thoughts that
we can entertain the sorts of actions
that we can engage in to make this
concrete if you're very very stressed
you're very upset
two things happen one it's very hard to
take your focus off whatever it is
that's upsetting you and if you don't
know what's upsetting you know pure
anxiety but you don't know why it's very
hard to take your mind off of the
feelings of anxiety in those states of
mind
there's another component which is that
for whatever reason and no one really
understands why this is it feels as if
the state that you're in will go on
forever now when we're in happy relaxed
States rarely do we think gosh this is
going to go on forever and yet when we
are in these unfortunate states of mine
we get the idea somehow it sort of
hijacks our perception of time and we
feel like this is never going to stop
if we turn to the body and certain
behaviors let me talk about what those
are we are able to move ourselves along
the autonomic Continuum and at that
point when we've done that successfully
it's actually quite straightforward to
do we are able to think about things
differently we start to get a sense that
the way we feel might not be the way
we're going to feel forever and it's in
those shifts that we start to realize ah
my mind actually is not my best friend
at these extremes but there's a lot more
to it you're only getting the tip of the
iceberg in those States so that's why I
say if you can't control the mind with
the Mind look to the body to control the
mind when you deprive a kid of something
that
is very very dopaminergic that
stimulates the release of a lot of
dopamine
and then they actually have access to
that at a friend's house or something of
that sort it is going to create a
massive increase in pleasure
so I think there's this issue of you
know not eliminating things but
having a controlled relationship to
these
very very powerful stimuli I mean you
know movies are very powerful
um you know this is not the topic that
we're talking about right now but you
know I get a lot of questions these days
about dopamine and about pornography for
instance pornography you know removing
all judgment from this because that's
not what the base of the conversation is
pornography has created an enormous
number of problems for in certain
countries in the last 10 years mostly
because of its immense availability and
the intensity of the images it's also
wired up a lot of young brains to become
aroused watching other people have sex
as opposed to being in the physical act
of sex themselves so there's a lot of
like you can't even call it third
personing they're not you know they're
aroused by imagery that they're not
actually participating in this is and I
hear a lot about I get a lot of
questions about this especially from the
younger audience so
um am I saying all pornography is bad no
not necessarily I you know I don't know
any discussion about uh sex and
sexuality I always say we're of course
framing it in the context of
age-appropriate consensual context
appropriate species appropriate
um so but the point is that you know
anything that stimulates a lot of
dopamine release is a very sharp blade
so if you eliminate it completely great
in the short term
potentially treacherous in in the long
term that kid goes to a friend's house
and sees you know a movie let's let's
just remove pornography from the
conversation cookies yeah it's something
that tastes candy for the first time and
the brain is hardwired to get very very
excited about that so then you now
you're dealing with a kid that
potentially could get even more addicted
to these things so it just has to be
controlled it has to be controlled any
potent stimulus highly processed highly
palatable food
um visual imagery movies
um has to be controlled caffeine is
consumed by basically most all adults
every single day and consumed at very
regular times each day caffeine can
improve mental Performance and Physical
performance this has been demonstrated
in tens of thousands of studies when we
ingest caffeine provided that we don't
have a lot of food in our stomach and
that our blood sugar isn't particularly
High generally we experience an increase
in alertness within about five minutes
and that increase in focus is an
alertness Peaks around 30 minutes after
ingestion of caffeine and persists for
as long as 60 minutes now this is
assuming that one takes caffeine in pill
form or drinks the entire caffeine drink
within a short period of time perhaps
the most robust finding across all of
the studies that I have examined is that
caffeine reduces a reaction time that is
it improves our reaction time it doesn't
make it longer it makes it shorter so
for instance in a laboratory study where
people were asked to hit a lever every
time they hear a tone you can greatly
reduce the time between the tone and the
pressing of the lever if people ingest
caffeine about 30 minutes before they do
that task now that seems like a trivial
task but this is also seen in the domain
of sports performance and even in
cognitive performance where people have
to arrive at a particular answer to a
question and the answer to that question
has to be pulled from their memory banks
within their brain their hippocampus for
instance a brain structure involved in
memory and if you are asking people for
instance to remember the capitals of
different states or cities or to
remember certain historical facts they
will do that at a particular rate but if
they've ingested caffeine within the
hour prior
their ability to recall that information
is much much better they are faster and
it does not appear that accuracy is
reduced in fact in many cases accuracy
is enhanced and that's because caffeine
both works on the reaction time systems
of the brain and body
I'll talk about the mechanisms for that
in a little bit but it also stimulates
certain neurotransmitters and so-called
neuromodulators within the brain and
body that give the neural circuits in
the brain that are associated with
learning and memory
a lower threshold to activation what
does that mean that means that we are
better able to access the brain
circuitry involved in learning in memory
when we have a certain amount of
caffeine circulating in our system so
this makes caffeine an incredible
performance enhancing compound caffeine
is known to have certain neuroprotective
effects and that is because of its
ability to increase
neuromodulators such as dopamine but
also other so-called catecholamines like
norepinephrine if you don't know what
those names mean these are molecules
that increase levels of alertness
motivation and drive and so then
therefore not surprisingly the
large-scale analyzes of the relationship
between depression and caffeine shows
that provided people are not drinking so
much caffeine that it makes them overly
anxious
that regular intake of caffeine is
inversely related to levels of
depression there are a lot of sources of
brain fog the most obvious one would be
a poor night's sleep okay and sleep of
course being the most fundamental layer
of mental and physical health I mean you
don't sleep well for one night you're
probably okay for two nights you start
to fall apart three four nights you're
really a degraded version of yourself in
every aspect emotionality is off ability
to do most anything is off hormones
start suffering so sleep is is
fundamental but assuming that you slept
well
there are a number of things one is your
breathing patterns and we often get into
discussions of breathing but this is a
slightly different one than we've had in
the past you know a lot of people have
sleep apnea they are not getting enough
oxygen during their sleep or they are
mouth breathing during sleep
these days it's become popular in some
circles to take a little bit of medical
tape and tape the mouth shut yeah and to
learn to be a nasal breather and there
is excellent evidence now that being a
nasal breather most of the time as long
as you're not speaking or eating or
exercising hard enough that you would
need to breathe through your mouth
that it's beneficial to be a nasal
breather for a couple of reasons first
of all if you are nasal deliberately
nasal breathing during the day
the tendency is that you will nasal
breathe at night which tends to lead to
less sleep apnea less mouth breathing
during the middle of the night and less
brain fog why brain fog well during
sleep a number of restorative processes
occur but if you're not getting enough
oxygen into the system the brain is
literally becoming hypoxic and a lot of
the cleaning out mechanisms the
lymphatic system Etc as they're called
don't get an opportunity to function as
well as they ought to so you wake up in
the morning you slept your normal six to
eight hours but you're feeling kind of
groggy and out of it and of course there
could be other reasons that you're
experiencing brain fog maybe you know
for people that drink alcohol the night
before maybe they had alcohol for people
that maybe they ate a meal that was too
large before sleep maybe any number of
reasons right gotcha but
um getting adequate oxygenation of the
brain during sleep is key so learn to be
a nasal breather and for those of you
out there that say well I have a
deviated septum a lot of people think
they have deviated septums the problem
is they're not nasal breathing enough
the sinuses actually can learn to dilate
if you nasal breathe exercising while
nasal breathing it will kind of depend
on the sport like if you box oftentimes
there's the need to do a sh or you know
kind of like exhale on impact type thing
so I I don't think anyone should tamper
with their normal breathing patterns as
it relates to sport or singing or some
you know activity but what I'm talking
about is when you're just standing
around when you're walking down the
street any low level activity you're
working at your desk yeah you should be
nasal breathing and breathing regularly
that will reduce brain fog in many cases
so one thing that we've been exploring
in humans is the extent to which people
who can take on adaptive decisions can
take that adaptive behaviors can take
that stress response and kind of move
the Horizon in closer and just focus on
okay I'm in the high stress regime this
is really painful we see this in we work
on people generalized anxiety who are
trying to overcome fear of heights and
just walking across a virtual height
plank can be terrifying for them but if
they can get one step in front of the
other despite high levels of anxiety
they can eventually overcome that and so
we've been looking at everything from
how breathing affects the anxiety
response to heart rate pupil size Etc
I'd be happy to talk about all that in
as much detail as you like but I think
the principle to take away is this that
the growth mindset is not about
suppressing anxiety so that you're able
to move Crews through things with ease
that's just one part of it it's really
about trying to understand that stress
response as key to your growth it's
absolutely key and I think people that
you know lift weights or run long
distance or are involved in competitive
Sports they fundamentally understand
this but even they kind of migrate away
from it over time where we recovery is
super important but you need the
stimulus right and the stimulus for
growth is that stress response and if
you think about it
evolutionarily let's say we were all
living in a little Clan here in the
audit offices and we didn't know
anything about the outside world we
would start to kind of eventually what
drove people to leave was they didn't
have enough of what they needed there's
this sort of the seeking right so if you
had enough everything you had enough
mates enough food enough water be fine
but at some point there was some
deprivation and so we had to do a risk
benefit analysis and so it was really
about taking that anxiety and venturing
out into the unknown to find resources
some people died and some people
succeeded and they were rewarded and
with that reward came the idea that ah
there's something about looking out into
the environment that's useful that can
allow me to have more than I have in the
moment but you can't divorce yourself
from the anxiety of wondering whether or
not things are going to turn out okay
you can't divorce yourself from the
anxiety of of strain and effort there's
just simply no way and in fact you
weren't really designed to do it so to
kind of peel this around to a practical
answer because I often listeners and you
know and people want to know what do I
do with this is you know I think
the field of wellness and biohacking and
high performance is great but it lacks
definition so one thing I'd really like
to see more of in the in these
communities and in the scientific
Community for that matter is more
careful definition like what is
mindfulness like really what are we
really talking about what is stress and
what are stress mitigation processes
that are useful so one thing I think is
really useful is think about real-time
tools versus offline tools I believe
personally that everybody whether or not
their MMA fighter they're in a CrossFit
they're running Ultras where they're a
student in class that doesn't do
anything physical whatever it is has
four tools one tool to get you to
mitigate your stress response in real
time so let's say the stress response
hits you need to keep it you can't let
it go too high or too low you know you
don't want to suppress it but something
to do that you also probably want an
offline tool that allows you to raise
your ceiling on what stress feels like
you know I'm buds with whim and I've
known him for a long time and like you
know I think Wim Hof breathing is in
particular is a use useful tool for kind
of Shifting your perception of what
stressful is that's an offline tool it's
not you can do it in real time but it's
not you're not going to start Wim
hoffing in the middle of your like
rolling Jiu Jitsu because your breathing
has got to be devoted to other things so
you need offline tools and real-time
tools to cope with stress and I think
people need real-time tools and offline
tools to bring themselves into
heightened states of arousal right so
there are times when there's when you're
actually too low on the arousal plane
and the key is to get higher up there
where you can access even better levels
of performance and so I think the the
so-called autonomic nervous system it
it's absolutely under our control it's a
total misnomer it's just that your heart
rate and your breathing are taken care
of on their own you don't need to flip
the on switch you wake up every morning
and you know if everything's going well
you're breathing and your heart rate is
going the way it should but you
absolutely have levers that you can
control and move in order to shift those
and I think that
um there's been a lot of focus on like
okay breathing is a great tool or you
know the ice bath is a great tool but we
really aren't thinking about what
they're best for and as a result of that
I don't think they'll ever evolve past
where they are unless we start thinking
okay like what's the utility of breath
holds no one can tell me like so my lab
is very interested in like in trying to
figure out what the utility of breath
holds is is it better at letting you
deal with adrenaline in your system is
it better at get carbon dioxide
tolerance you know
um for all the the incredible tools that
are out there there isn't a lot of good
information about systematic ways to
approach it and I don't want to peel
everything down to like a really
reductionist approach you know I'm
friends with Brian McKenzie and those
guys and you know Brian's about as
reductionist as you get in the
breathwork community and I love how
quantif you know how he loves to
quantify everything that's one of the
things that initially brought us
together
um as friends and as uh as you know sort
of informal collaborators but I think
that this world of biohacking needs
definition you know it's it's kind of
ironic that in the weightlifting
Community they've really works things
down to a kind of a fine science whereas
in the endurance Community it's kind of
like whoever you're listening to seems
to be the person who knows the most and
I don't claim to know everything or the
most at all I just would like to see
sharper definition on all this stuff
about stress stress mitigation ice baths
breathing and so on so you might be
wondering what exactly is this
meditation the meditation is very simple
and it's one that anyone can perform
what you would want to do is set a timer
for about 13 minutes I don't think it
has to be exactly 13 minutes but since
that's what they included in the study
you would set a timer for 13 minutes you
would sit or lie down close your eyes
and you would simply focus on your
breathing
most people are going to benefit from
only doing that breathing through their
nose but if you have some sort of
obstruction or inability to breathe just
through your nose you could probably
also do it by breathing through your
nose and mouth or just your mouth but
ideally you would do just nasal
breathing for a period of 13 minutes
concentrating on that breathing and
concentrating meaning bringing your
awareness your so-called interceptive
awareness if you wanted to get really
technical about it your interceptive
awareness to a point just about an inch
inside of your forehead now of course
that might sound kind of gory to some of
you you've never actually been inside
your forehead but just about an inch
behind your forehead is where you would
want to place your concentration while
also concentrating on your breathing now
here's the thing about meditation
that all studies of meditation show
which is that unless you are a very
experienced meditator
your concentration your focus will drift
away from your breathing and away from
that location about an inch inside your
head inside your brain about just behind
your forehead
that will happen maybe every 10 seconds
every 20 seconds maybe even every five
seconds but an important part of such a
meditation practice to improve
concentration and focus is that you are
continually refocusing
back to that specific location and
refocusing back on your breath
this is something that again is not
often discussed people think that if you
do a meditation and you're supposed to
concentrate on your breath that if your
mind drifts that somehow you failed in
that meditation but actually that's not
the case a huge component of improving
your ability to focus and concentrate by
way of neural plasticity rewiring of the
circuits for focus and concentration is
the repeated return to a state of focus
from a state of non-focus or diminished
Focus okay so think about it like trying
to drive down the freeway
and staying between the lane lines
excuse me and every once in a while
because there's a bit of drift on the
vehicle maybe the wheels aren't aligned
correctly or there's something else
wrong with the chassis or the steering
device it starts to drift right a little
bit then you hit the rumble strip to go
and then you pull back to the center
that's really what a focused meditation
practice is about as opposed to
expecting yourself to stay between the
mental Lane lines so to speak so if
you're somebody who's going to do a
practice of the sort that I described in
a 13-minute meditation practice every
day you'd want to sit or lie down close
your eyes start to concentrate on your
breath Focus your attention on a
location about an inch behind your
forehead and then fully expect that at
some point you'll be thinking about
something else and that's a cue to focus
back to that location just about an inch
behind your forehead and back to your
breath
by doing that repeatedly over and over
what you're really training up is the
network within your brain that indeed
includes that prefrontal cortex that
you're focusing on as well as some other
structures the infra-temporal cortex
indeed the hippocampus a structure
associated with memory and other
components of the neural circuit that
are involved in directing our mental
focus and concentration again I can't
emphasize the importance of this
practice being one of focusing and
refocusing in fact I would prefer to
call such a practice a refocus focused
meditation or a constantly refocusing or
maybe you all can come up with a better
name for it I'm certainly not that good
at naming things but this sort of
meditation practice has been shown in
the study the Suzuki lab and other
studies
to really improve people's ability to
focus and remain focused so much so that
in the beautiful book Altered States
they describe a number of different
meditation practices some a little bit
longer than the one that I described one
that's 17 minutes another one that's 30
minutes some people meditate as long as
60 minutes a day although that's quite a
long time in my opinion the point here
isn't how long you focus or somehow
trying to achieve Total Focus for the
entire 13 minute or 17 minute or 60
Minute bout of meditation while that
would be wonderful and I think many
people aspire to do that that's a lot of
hard mental work I think for most people
out there including myself a relatively
short meditation practice of about 13
minutes in which you fully expect your
focus and concentration to drift but
that you are continually refocusing is
going to be the most effective yes
indeed the most effective at teaching
yourself to focus and stay concentrated
in fact I invite you to interpret every
time time that you focus off that
location about one inch behind your
forehead as an opportunity to refocus
and think about the refocusing as the
trigger for teaching your neural
circuits how to focus for extended
periods of time so growth mindset and
these dopamine rewards that we
subjectively apply are not about saying
oh you know I had a terrible day I
performed poorly but you know what it's
great I just feel great anyway it's not
about that it's not about attaching your
sense of reward to the ultimate goal
it's about attaching your sense of
reward to the fact that you're making
action steps that are generally in the
right direction the more you can reward
the effort process
the better off you are at building these
kinds of neural circuits and these kind
of Tendencies to be able to lean into
anything challenging over essentially
any duration so how does this work like
how would somebody do this right well
keeping in mind that adrenaline and
epinephrine are all great for getting us
into action this is Mother Nature's Way
of chemically making us feel kind of
agitated remember stress was designed to
agitate us to move us away from things
and toward things now I didn't have the
power of concentration I hadn't read all
the good books that gun high school
students read growing up I had to
learn how to speak properly I learned
how to learn how to think properly and
really learn how to
commit to something that was very linear
and at times was very painful and and I
went to some pretty extreme things I um
you know I actually used to set a timer
and I wouldn't allow myself to get out
of the chair until I was the timer went
off right so and I would experience
extreme agitation but over time I got
pretty good and now I can do long stints
of work without any breaks on a trial by
trial basis we know that when you fail
at an attempt on the next attempt your
forebrain is in a position to to engage
better and this makes total sense right
you feel that frustration
you want to get the next one right well
you're
harboring or I should say funneling more
neural resources your focus that
aperture tightens now you have to be
mindful of that too because when you
have a failure and then you're like
you're gonna hit the Bulls I'm thinking
about a dartboard because I'm terrible
at darts you know sober I'm terrible at
darts
I don't even drink so that next trial
part of the problem is is that Focus can
narrow so much that you can start to
lose access to information that might
help you if you were just to relax a
little bit and dilate that focus a
little bit but in General on a trial by
trial basis focus is the cue that your
nervous system is going to be positioned
to learn better on the next trial now in
terms of Life Experiences
gosh I wish for everyone fewer failures
and more successes but you know failures
keep you humble and I've had a lot of
them I mean if people ever wanted and
they you know I'd be happy to tell you
about I mean I've made a ton of mistakes
in life a ton of mistakes some of those
were mistakes of persistence like dumb
decisions I could like it's going to
change it's going to change and it's
clearly never going to change and then
some were failures of misjudgment about
other people or situations and a lot of
them were just plain failures like the
experiment didn't work or
the thing it just wasn't the right thing
and you're trying to reframe those I do
think that we owe it to ourselves and to
the people that we know to try and
generate some wins here and there and
try and help other people generate wins
um you know in running a lab over the
years and I still do
you realize that you want your students
to publish a paper and feel that success
pretty early so that they can experience
a how much work it is so they pick
problems wisely but B so they can feel
that like I can do this and I think that
um you know this gets into the
psychological as well I think that yes
failures help but success is help and
there I think
you know I function best in a team and I
think that for those of you that are
feel like you're fighting some challenge
alone I do think that there are great
resources to be had in trying to access
other you know other people as sources
of support I I think that that's a great
tool there's this whole literature
scientific literature around social
connection and how that can help us
reframe motivation and goals anyway
maybe that's a topic to expand on
another time but uh failure is important
on a trial trial by basis
people who don't experience enough wins
for a long period of time the brain is a
prediction machine after all and they
start to predict failure so it takes a
bit more work to
wedge oneself out of that for somebody
who's very driven who wants to be the
best who has a milestone I would say two
cautionary Notes One first first of all
that's beautiful and that's wonderful
and that's a lot of what makes life Rich
to
one needs to make sure that along the
way you are registering the wins the
Milestones settings of closer Horizon
Milestones yeah yep and then the third
is that
the schedule of reward that works best
for keeping people in a healthy State of
Mind of pursuit is one of the same one
that the casinos use to extract money
from you which is random intermittent
reward here's what I mean the slot
machine it does it's not every 10 polls
that keeps people playing a win every 10
pulls it's the randomness of it right as
soon as you're ready to walk away you
get a win and then it keeps people going
this we can apply this in our own lives
that in this especially true with kids
it's great to reward your wins but every
once in a while
take that gold medal and just say don't
say it wasn't good enough but just
go right back into living life and
pursuing new new Pursuits what what I've
seen over and over again is that people
that are very driven
become so attached to this dopamine
reward system that they get the the they
reach the Milestone excuse me and then
they feel depressed well why because
dopamine is released by Pursuit
motivation and craving not by reaching
the reward itself so the journey being
the destination is a is a dope again a
dopaminergic as we say phenomenal one
other major finding of the Harvard
longitudinal study on happiness as well
as shorter term studies on happiness is
that much as you've heard perhaps that
no one on their deathbed says they wish
they had worked more
well indeed the total amount of time
that one spends working does not seem to
determine one's happiness
and yet I also want to earmark that
result as one that we need to parse a
bit more carefully because
work last time I checked and certainly
for me is the way typically that people
earn an income and as we just talked
about a moment ago income is often a way
that people have access to or provide
access for their family to things like
Recreation
that opens up the opportunity for more
social connection right so there we have
to be careful with how we interpret
these blanket statements that have
become very popular that you know money
doesn't determine happiness and that the
amount that you work isn't going to
determine happiness
it certainly is the case that if you
earn more money from working more and
that money is devoted to things that
bring more opportunities for social
connection or for buffering stress in
other areas of your life including
health care care for your children care
for yourself Recreation
other things that you enjoy well then I
think it's a little bit naive to assume
that work itself is somehow counter to
happiness which of course it isn't and
it especially isn't if we combine that
feature of work with another important
feature of the human psyche which is
this notion of meaning much of the
psychology of the last century and still
today focuses on this feature of meaning
as a critical one in terms of what makes
us happy and what doesn't make us happy
certainly in the long term and I can
certainly say for myself that learning
and teaching and doing research in my
laboratory brings me tremendous feeling
of meaning and happiness
some people consider their work simply a
way to gain a pay a check
and other people find that they would do
the very work they do regardless of
whether or not they were paid in fact
many people will do volunteer work and
other forms of work for zero money so
this idea that money isn't important or
that work is not as important as we deem
it to be that also needs to be
considered from a number of different
perspectives when I was a kid I had a
little bit of a grunting tick when I was
five or six
um I would feel this buildup of tension
in my throat and I would do this
grunting tick if I get very tired I
start to do it still we actually know
that this is related to these basal
ganglia circuits for go no go you've got
an accelerator and a break basically in
your neural circuitry and um kids with
Tourette's and OCD
um the break doesn't work quite as well
and so one thing that happens is if I
wake up in the morning and especially if
I'm well rested well if I'm not well
rested I do a hypnosis or Yoga Nidra in
order to recover my sleep that works
really well but then once I'm into the
process of preparing the podcast
I've already gone through my notes I
know what I want to say more or less in
a kind of General contour and then I
take a walk and I I try to so no phone
with me and I try to assess
whether or not my energy is too high or
too low for podcasting because when you
podcast as you know you have to punch
out a lot of material but then there's
times when you really need to slow down
and emphasize and articulate and so uh
what I do uh this is I don't I've never
revealed this uh what I do actually is I
will recite the lyrics of songs for
about 10 minutes songs I love while I
walk out loud it calms you and focuses
you what does it do I think it gets my
vocal cords
warmed up and it also do you sing or
speak them I often sing them uh and
unfortunately nobody hears and as I do
this I start to evaluate whether or not
I'm straining to get the words out or
whether or not I'm straining to make
them slow enough so that I can
articulate them
so there are days when I have so much
energy that I trying to speak faster
than I should in order to articulate
properly there are other days when I'm
tired and I can't sort of keep up with
my thoughts and so what I try and do is
assess that and then adjust the
transmission the RPMs so to speak for
instance I can speak very quickly and
then I can slow down so I can change the
Cadence of my voice and when you teach
in the classroom you learn as you know
because you're an excellent teacher I've
watched your lectures in the classroom
as you teach in the classroom when you
want to slow down every teacher knows
you turn to the Whiteboard or chalkboard
and you start writing right it gives you
a break and then you turn around and you
fire back the kind of machine gun fire
of of information and then you slow down
or you underline something when you
podcast
you don't have that opportunity right
there are no visuals in my podcast so
what I try and do is always
get my voice warmed up and make sure
that I'm thinking and speaking at
approximately the same rate
and then I also do this thing as I put
my vision into panoramic Vision when I
walk which is very calming
and then I actually start to remind
myself of the purpose of podcasting this
sounds very mission statement e but you
asked what I do yeah I I remind myself
first and foremost that what I want to
communicate what I want to come through
is the beauty and utility of biology so
there is something called adrenal
insufficiency syndrome which is a real
medical phenomenon where the adrenals
are incapable of making these cortisol
and adrenal hormones but
the the truth is that you have enough
adrenaline and cortisol in your body
you'll last two lifetimes in 25 famines
I mean we were built with a lot of
robustness right this explains you know
that you know the David Goggins of the
world they they you know we have we all
do have that greater capacity that
people talk about the stress is very
misunderstood because people think of
stress as this ancient carryover that's
very unfortunate it kind of gets lumped
with depression like oh this is just a a
flaw in our design or something but
actually stress is wonderful it actually
activates our immune system so anytime
you liberate adrenaline into your
bloodstream you also protect yourself
against infection of bacteria and
viruses because if you think about if we
had to gather food and we didn't have it
and we had to then pack up and you know
migrate long distances you can't afford
to get sick and this is why people who
work work work and then rest they
usually get sick when they finally stop
and rest yeah it's like the post-finals
phenomenon in University or after the
season the game or the caretakers thing
where you're taking care of somebody
who's ill and you're just work work or
taking care of young children and then
you finally stop to rest you go on
vacation and you get slammed with with
why is that because you're being in your
comfort zone now or you're just stress
turned off and adrenaline and so that
these the stress response recruits the
immune organs of the body to release
killer T cells in fact Wim Hof breathing
I know you're familiar with whim of
doing 20 or 30 deep inhales and exhales
and also combined with some breath hold
type work exhale hold inhale hold is
known to stimulate adrenaline release
and the one of the better papers that's
out there scientific peer-reviewed
papers is a study published in the
proceedings in National Academy of
Sciences where they brought in two
groups one group did Wim Hof breathing
the other group did just mindful
meditation both groups were injected
with E coli that's crazy right crazy
it's crazy the meditators got fever
diarrhea and
um and vomiting and the people who did
Wim Hof either didn't get it or got it
to a much lesser sluggish but that's
right they didn't right isn't that this
is non-experiment to do at home isn't
this crazy but it makes perfect sense
because
it incred that breathing simulates a
stress response it stimulates cortisol
and adrenaline which signals to protects
the body right which signals to the
thymus the spleen and the other you know
the the nodes of the immune system to
liberate killer cells and so when that
bacteria comes in the system is ready
for it your body is defending against
viruses that's right disease
when you create a routine of healthy
stress that's right and and we can talk
about we definitely want to you don't
want stress on all the time sleep is
really important Etc but that stress
response combats
infection because it recruits immune
cells the problem with this all dopamine
thing in the context of relationship is
that early on it's incredibly
intoxicating to the point where
oftentimes people don't realize that
they're veering so hard right that that
you know and and this is where the power
of friends
um comes in very handy this is also
where we can honestly say that the power
of complete and total disclosure about
relationship to friend or therapist is
really healthy if you're saying like you
know I've seen this with some of my male
friends
I have female friends too but most of my
friends just happen to be male at this
stage of life that's just kind of my
surroundings and I get the friend that's
super excited about somebody and they'll
tell you this story about how this say
oh you know and there was this crazy
thing she did this crazy thing and they
get kind of wide-eyed and like that
doesn't sound good he's like excited
about it like okay this is this is your
this is his drug right it's uncertainty
it's excitement and I and it follows a
very predictable pattern wherein three
to six months it's
him complaining that she's crazier that
the relationship is a mess or that you
know the original thing you love now you
hate exactly there's chaos so I think
that here's I think the takeaway for
relationships not just at the beginning
not just in the middle
um we can talk about the end in a minute
if there is one but
to have an awareness where if you sense
too much excitement in yourself
or too much anticipation of how great
someone is
I'm not saying don't fall in love but be
very cautious about the extremes of
dopamine be very wary about the thing
that makes you feel incredible and I I
say this with some trepidation because I
myself you know love love right I love
love I love love I love following it
yeah it's the best love falling in love
being in love I mean that's true in
romantic relationships and I also you
know I I loved having a bulldog like I
loved Tim love love love
you know I have so many loves in life
and relationships are always the best of
it right but there is this element where
it is a bit of a drug right it's this
thing because it's always about more and
if you really want the relationship if
you want good Clarity on the
relationship and you want it to last
there has to be a tempering of that and
I don't mean
um playing aloof I don't mean canceling
things last minute I don't mean playing
any kind of games with the dopamine
reward prediction error thing what I
mean is just being aware that that
chemical state
it it really isn't what comes up comes
goes down and it also puts tremendous
Demand on the other person right that I
think the key of any good relationship
is to be able to toggle back and forth
ideally in Para like together through
these more dopaminergic like novelty
excitement and then the more like really
getting joy out of just being together
the more serotonergic stuff like that
that just like wow the sweetness the the
incredible like the Cocoon
um and missing one another is super
healthy also remember
addiction is a progressive narrowing of
the things that bring us pleasure making
sure that we continue to derive
excitement from other things in life
even when we're falling in love you know
the concept of the Muse and the concept
of in a new relationship we feel kind of
indestructible and we can do anything in
life and feeling so inspired you know
you see this joyful excited oh I've seen
this in family members also like working
out again and you're like wow they're
using it but the problem is it's all
anchored it's all Tethered to this
relationship and the relationship goes
and then the rest of stuff goes too if I
could travel back in time as a 15 year
old I would encourage you to cultivate
some sort of mindfulness practice I know
this sounds a little cliche but having
some awareness of how you're thinking
about your thinking is good but I'm
actually not going to say sit down and
meditate for 10 minutes a day or do nsdr
I'm actually not going to tell you that
I think given how plastic your brain is
how much it's changing at 15 I would
encourage you and maybe you would set a
timer for this to actually develop just
a really Keen awareness of what stresses
you out what relaxes you
what Delights you
Etc and just to Simply develop an
awareness of that
because those are your antennae
and I certainly had a meditation
practice as a youth mostly given to me
because I was a little haywire and I
needed it
and it worked pretty well but I think in
retrospect what I wish I had developed
was more of a sense of
you know how I navigated stress or
things and things I enjoyed and things I
didn't enjoy and I would just encourage
you to have a general awareness try and
detect and learn about what raises your
adrenaline what raises your dopamine
what raises your serotonin and then
start thinking about tools but again the
awareness is going to be very valuable
and gosh as a 15 year old you are in
this you know amazing blessed period of
heightened neuroplasticity should we all
be so lucky so enjoy it
when we lack social interaction that we
expect we become pro-social however
if we are chronically socially isolated
meaning we don't have interactions with
people for a long time we become
actually more introverted this is
separate from all of the tacky kind and
stuff that I talked about earlier or
falling into states of chronic stress
but it's well established now that in
humans and in animals
if you don't give them enough social
interaction they actually become
anti-social and so this is actually a
little bit like what one might see with
long-term fasting okay I give the
example of eating every four hours now
let's give the parallel example of
somebody who's been fasting perhaps for
two or three days if they are expecting
to eat and then the meal doesn't arrive
they are not necessarily going to
immediately try and seek out food and
that's a little bit counterintuitive you
would have thought well they haven't
eaten in a very long time they're going
to be very motivated to seek out food
but no they are accustomed to fasting
similarly this social homeostasis
circuit Works in a way such that when we
don't have social interactions for a
very long time we start to lose our
craving for social interactions if you
give people a little bit of an
understanding of the underlying
mechanisms
it creates a system around any tool that
makes it easier to do that practice and
uh
makes it more impactful as well so what
I mean is you know I could do a whole
episode just listing off tools and
protocols for everything from Fat Loss
to focus and attention mental health
depression trauma grief Etc based on the
data but if I start each episode which I
do with a little bit of a of a
description of the mechanism for
instance how cold impacts metabolism
how for instance a particular childhood
attachment pattern to a parent
translates to an adult romantic
attachment pattern then when I go into
some of the description about the tools
My Hope Is that people will have those
mechanisms in mind or even just
subconsciously they're embedded and then
not only are they going to be more
willing to lean into those tools but
those tools will be more impactful and
the last thing I'll say about this is I
have a colleague at Stanford I should
introduce you guys because she'd make a
phenomenal podcast guess her name is Ali
Crum Aaliyah crumb she is a tenure
professor at Stanford she's a trained
clinical psychologist she was a division
one gymnast and she's a martial artist
and she works on beliefs and belief
systems and she has incredible data
showing that
the result of anything you do or what
you eat
is both the consequence of that thing so
like she's done experiments for instance
where they give people milkshakes and
they tell them okay this is a low
calorie milkshake
or they tell people this is a high
calorie nutrient dense and it's a
regular milkshake it's it's a milkshake
people drink that and they measure
subjective reports of how fulfilling
that and how how much satiety how much
satisfaction it provides and for how
long and they measure hormones insulin
ghrelin all the hormones that are the
consequence of eating and what you find
is that if you think what they find is
that if people are told this is a high
calorie nutrient shake it provides much
more satisfaction for much longer than
if they're told that it's a low calorie
nutrient sparse shank and the hormones
that one secretes in response to that
milkshake differ in the two groups even
though the milkshakes are absolutely
identical because it's all about your
beliefs it's in part about your beliefs
because of course if you know uh you
can't tell yourself that the entire
chocolate cake is you know uh just a
bowl of broccoli and it's gonna have the
same effects as a bowl of broccoli so
anything you do whether or not it's
exercise cold bath what you consume is
the consequence of that thing there are
some undeniable non-negotiable realities
about your biology and then there's the
belief system and the other example I'll
give is they've done these beautiful
studies where they tell one group listen
stress is a part of life and it gives
you dementia it makes your thinking
suffer it can kill neurons it can do all
this terrible stuff they tell another
group
all that's true by the way in certain
contexts they tell another group
stress is a part of life but it can
sharpen your thinking it can bring out
your best it can stimulate your immune
system as long as it doesn't last too
long and what they find is that the
biological effects of stress on those
two groups match what those people are
taught about stress wow and so you can't
get around the realities of stress or
calories or things of that sort there's
the laws of physics but in the laws of
biology but belief systems have a
powerful role in how the tools and
practices that we engage in shape us and
so that's the The Logical backbone for
teaching people a bit about the
mechanism because if if I say hey do an
ice bath you know it increases your
metabolism increases your resilience and
can reduce pain and inflammation help
you sleep better at night great but lots
of people are saying that but if I say
listen there's this pathway where when
you get into cold water and it it's
really uncomfortable and you really want
to get out but you stay in for an extra
minute you stimulate this certain
adrenaline related pathway in your brain
and body now when you do it and you hit
that wall you're like I really want to
get out of here you think no I want to
stimulate that pathway way and then your
belief and understanding about that
pathway really does shape the fact that
it works and so teaching mechanism is in
part for me about educating and turning
people on to the beauty of biology but I
realize look not everyone wants to be a
biologist or a researcher but I think
everybody wants better mental health
physical health and performance and so
mechanism has a real impact next I'd
like to talk about some of the research
on and the roles of hormones in OCD
because it turns out to be a very
interesting relationship there but
before I do I want to point out
something that I realize I probably
should have said earlier which is one of
the key things for someone with OCD to
come to understand if they're going to
experience any relief of their symptoms
whether or not they're doing drug
treatments or behavioral treatments or
otherwise
is that thoughts are not as bad as
actions
right thoughts are not as bad as actions
one of the rules that people with OCD
seem to adopt for themselves is that
thoughts are really truly the equivalent
of actions so they'll have an intrusive
thought and we haven't spent too much
time on this today but earlier I touched
on the fact that some of the intrusive
thoughts that people have in OCD are
really disturbing they can be really
gross or at least gross to that person
they can evoke imagery that is you know
toxic or infectious or is
highly sexualized in a way that is
disturbing to them can be very taboo
this is not uncommon when you start
talking to people with OCD and you start
pulling on the thread again this would
be a psychiatrist who was trained to ask
the right questions and gain the comfort
and Trust of a patient they start to
reveal that these these thoughts are
really intrusive and kind of disturbing
which is why they feel so compelled to
try and suppress them with behaviors one
of the powerful elements of treatment
for OCD is to really support the patient
and make them realize that thoughts are
just thoughts and that everyone has
disturbing thoughts and then oftentimes
those disturbing thoughts Arise at the
most inconvenient and sometimes what
seems like the most inappropriate
circumstances and this relates to a
whole larger discussion that we could
have about what our thoughts and why do
they surface and how come when you stand
at the edge of a bridge even if you do
not want to jump off you think about
jumping off and you know this has to do
with the fact that your nervous system
as a prediction machine is oftentimes
testing possibilities and sometimes that
testing goes way off into the
Netherlands of the thought patterns and
emotional patterns that we all have
inside of us the big difference between
a thought and an action is that of
course the nervous system is one case
not translating those patterns of
thinking into motor sequences
that nerdy way of saying thoughts aren't
actions believe it or not can be helpful
for people if they really think about
that and use it as an opportunity to
realize that first of all they're not
crazy
they're not thinking and feeling this
stuff because they're bad or evil and of
course sometimes this can cross over
with other other elements of life where
we place moral judgment on people for
certain behaviors I think that's part of
a healthy Society of course that's why
we have laws and punishments and and
rewards for that matter for certain
types of behaviors but this idea that
thoughts are not as bad as actions and
that thoughts can be tolerated and the
anxiety around thoughts can be tolerated
and over time can diminish that's a very
powerful Hallmark theme of the treatment
of OCD so I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention it
thoughts are not actions actions can
harm us they can harm other people they
can soak up enormous amounts of time
thoughts can soak up enormous amounts of
time they can be very troubling they can
be very detrimental we of course want to
be sensitive to that
but when it really comes down to it
the first step in treatment for OCD is
this realization where the approach to
the realization that thoughts are not as
bad as actions there are behavioral
tools that you can use to enhance Focus
things like staring in a particular
visual Target at the same distance at
which you're going to perform some work
and doing that for 30 to 60 Seconds
narrowing in a very deliberate way your
visual field and then moving into a
focused work bout
that behavioral practice of narrowing
your visual aperture
will increase the amount of
acetylcholine Transmission in particular
neural circuits that will then make it
easier to focus how do we know that well
I covered in that episode some of the
peer-reviewed studies that relate to
protocols that are now actively being
deployed in schools in China and
elsewhere where kids are doing
deliberate visual Focus exercises in
order to increase their mental focus and
while they're not doing micro dialysis
or brain Imaging on those kids in real
time the cognitive effects and indeed
the performance effects in terms of
academic ability and output are pretty
impressive so acetylcholine increases
Focus we talked about some dietary and
some supplementation based ways to
improve acetylcholine or I should say
increase acetylcholine and that does in
fact lead to increases in one's ability
to focus this is why a lot of the
prescription drugs for the treatment of
Alzheimer's age-related cognitive
decline and indeed even some of the
drugs that tap into treatments for ADHD
also involve the acetylcholine system so
there's nothing surprising or heretical
here but it is important to point out
that your behavioral ability to focus is
also related to your ability to access
and deploy acetylcholine so never do we
want
purely pharmacologic treatments to be
the only way that people are increasing
a given neuromodulator I always say
behaviors first then nutrition then
supplementation and then if there's a
need certainly a clinical need then
prescription drugs Etc of course
administered through a physician
nowadays there's a ton of interest in
social media and in video games and it
there have been some measurements of the
amount of dopamine released video games
especially video games that have a very
high update speed where there's novel
territory all the time novelty is a big
stimulus of dopamine those can release
dopamine somewhere between nicotine and
cocaine so very high levels of dopamine
release
social media is an interesting one
because the amount of dopamine that's
released in response to logging onto
social media initially could be quite
high but it seems like likely that
there's a taper in the amount of
dopamine but and yet people still get
addicted so why why is it that we can
get addicted to things that fail to get
to elicit the same massive amount of
pleasure that they initially did
being addicted to something isn't just
about the fact that it feels so good
that you want to do it over and over
again and that's because of this
pleasure pain balance that underlies
motivation so let's look a little bit
closer at the pleasure pain balance
because therein lies the tools for you
to be able to control motivation toward
healthy things and avoid motivated
behaviors towards things that are
destructive for you there are a lot of
reasons why people try novel behaviors
whether or not those are drugs or
whether or not those are Adventure
thrill-seeking things or they seek out
new partners or you know they take a new
class as you'll notice I'm not placing
any judgment or value on these different
behaviors although I think it's fair to
point out that for most people
addictive drugs like cocaine and
amphetamine are very destructive
actually we know that about 15 to 20
percent of people have a genetic bias
towards addiction that you know you
sometimes hear that the first time that
you use a drug you can become addicted
to it that's actually not been shown to
be true for most things in most people
but for some people that actually is
true and we'll talk a little bit later
about why certain people are heavily
biased toward becoming addicts on the
first use of a particular drug it's
actually very interesting it has
everything to do with whether or not
they were formally addicted to something
else
but in any case the way that addiction
works and the way that motivation Works
generally in the non-addictive setting
is that when you anticipate something a
little bit of dopamine is released and
then when you reach that thing you
engage in that thing
the amount of dopamine goes up even
further but as you repeatedly pursue a
behavior and you repeatedly engage with
a particular thing let's say you love
running or you love chocolate as you eat
a piece of chocolate believe it or not
it tastes good and then there's a shift
away from activation of dopamine and
there are other chemicals that are
released that trigger a low-level sense
of pain now you might not feel as
physical pain but the craving that you
feel is both one part dopamine and one
part the mirror image of dopamine which
is the pain or the craving for yet
another piece of chocolate and this is a
very important and subtle feature of the
dopamine system that's not often
discussed people always talk about just
as pleasure you love social media so it
gives you dopamine and so you engage in
that you like chocolate it releases
dopamines you do that but for every bit
of dopamine that's released there's
another circuit in the brain that
creates you can think of it as kind of
like a downward deflection in pleasure
so you engage in something you really
want and there's an increase in pleasure
and then there's a without you doing
anything there's a mirror image of that
which is a downward deflection and
pleasure which we're calling pain so for
every bit of pleasure there is a mirror
image experience of pain and they
overlap in time very closely so it's
sometimes hard to sense this but try it
the next time you eat something really
delicious you'll take a bite it tastes
delicious and part of the experience is
to want more of that thing this is true
for any pleasureful experience
now the Diabolical part about dopamine
is that because it didn't evolve in
order to get you to indulge in more and
more and more of something what happens
is that initially you experience an
increase in pleasure and you also
experience this increase in pain shortly
after or woven in with the pleasure
that makes you want more of that thing
but with each subsequent time that you
encounter that thing that you pursue the
chocolate that you uh you pursue the
lover each time the experience of
dopamine release and pleasure is
diminished a little bit
and the Diabolical thing is that the
pain response is increased a little bit
and this is best observed in the context
of drug-seeking behavior the first time
someone decides to take cocaine or
amphetamine
they may do it out of boredom they may
do it out of peer pressure they may do
it to relieve some internal sense maybe
they're bored or they're just excited
maybe they're high in novelty seeking
there are a lot of reasons why people
might try a drug far too many for us to
you know to get into or parse here
maybe they don't even want to do it but
someone encourages them they will
experience a huge dopamine release and
they will feel likely very good
however the next time they take it it
won't feel quite as good and it won't
feel even as good the third time or the
next time but
the amount of pain the amount of craving
that they experience for the drug will
increase over time so much of our
pursuit of pleasure is simply to reduce
the pain of craving so the next time you
experience something you really like I
don't want to take you out of that
experience but it's really important
that you notice this that if there's
something you really enjoy part of that
enjoyment is about the anticipation and
wanting of more of that thing
and that's the pain system in action
learning to cultivate a a life of focus
and I should say it should be produ the
way to support that is to have
components of your day of wordlessness
and defocus I do want to emphasize that
because it's not about waking up and
from morning till till night being Ultra
focused right I don't I don't I don't do
the make my bed first thing I admit it I
I sometimes like it happens midday okay
all right I wouldn't make it in the
military but we knew that already anyway
so the you know that it's about being
in in recognition of where you're at and
focused and dropping in deeply for
certain portions of the day but I also
have a deliberate decompress time of my
day right I take 30 minutes a day and I
either take a nap or I do a Yoga Nidra
or I just let my mind go but that does
mean not mindless scrolling although I
do some mindless scrolling too I allow
myself that but
having periods of the day where you let
the mind defocus and just kind of drift
in the same way that your mind drifts a
bit during sleep that is what allows you
to focus so it very intensely afterward
or on a consistent basis so it's not
about being a total animal from morning
till night and then just expecting a
switch you know switch off the thinking
and go right to sleep it's about for me
they're really two blocks two 90-minute
blocks one early in the day and one
later in the day where I commit to doing
really focused work twice a day and I
have to fight tooth and nail to create
the space for those and to make sure it
happens and if it and I fail a lot you
know if something gets in the way and I
don't do that I um I just try and get
back on track as quickly as possible I
don't bring my phone I put my phone on
airplane mode when I'm training and
doing any kind of physical work now
because it's just too distracting I
happen to be an omnivore my goal is
always to eat high quality minimally or
non-processed foods and to eat things in
moderation so I do eat some meat from
sustainable sources or from organic
sources I eat some starches and I eat
vegetables and I eat fruits I try not to
eat sugars and I don't really like
highly processed foods at this point in
my life that's me that's what I do but
I'm certainly not dictating what people
should eat I know certain people are
ketogenic and I can say that for people
who achieve ketosis and can get into
ketosis yes indeed there is a mental
state associated with ketosis that will
allow your brain to function and to
think really clearly that many people
find very attractive and keep them going
back over and over again to a ketogenic
diet I'm somebody who for instance has
not been in ketosis many times in my
life at least not deliberately so but I
actually will ingest liquid ketones from
time to time because of the further
cognitive enhancement physical
enhancement that I experience on top of
nutrition that does include some
carbohydrates so there are a lot of
different ways to approach all this
whether or not you're a vegan omnivore
vegetarian carnivore Etc the point is
this
your ability to focus and in fact your
ability of neurons to encode specific
information in your environment that is
to represent what's out there in the
world is actually related to your blood
glucose level now here I'm setting aside
the discussion of ketosis and and
ketogenic diets for the moment but
there's a beautiful study that was
published in neuron not long ago that
showed that the tuning that is the
Precision with which neurons in the
brain to represent things in our
environment is actually much greater
when there is sufficient glucose in the
brain translate into English this means
that when we are fasted or when our
blood glucose is very low we aren't able
to perceive and think about things as
clearly now there's a Twist to this
however many people who practice
intermittent fasting and I should say I
practice a sort of pseudo-interm fasting
I generally eat my meals between the
hours of 11 A.M and 8 PM although
sometimes there's some wiggle around
that occasionally I have an early
breakfast I'm not super rigid about it
but I know there are a number of people
who are doing longer fast so they're
eating in a six hour window we did a 10
our episode about fasting you can again
find that hubermanlab.com we'll likely
have Sachin Panda who's an expert in
intermittent fasting on the podcast
intermittent fasting has a lot of
different potential benefits for some
people it's a convenient way to restrict
their calories for other people it's a
convenient way to avoid eating that is
it's easier to not eat than to eat a
small portion so they opt for
intermittent fasting and so on and so
forth but one of the things that you
hear very often is that some people like
being fasted because they like the
clarity of mind that it provides here's
the situation neurons unless you're in a
ketogenic diet really thrive on glucose
they love glucose and as I mentioned
before your ability to think and
perceive things is actually enhanced by
having sufficient glucose in your
bloodstream so why would it be that some
people experience a heightened state of
mental Clarity when they are fasted I've
certainly experienced that before well I
should say that provided you're well
hydrated enough and you have enough
electrolytes in your system what tends
to happen is that when you ingest food
there's a shift in your nervous system
towards so-called parasympathetic mode
that is the more relaxed you probably
heard it as rest and digest although it
does other things a more relaxed mode
that can indeed make us very sleepy if
we have too many carbohydrates that
actually can make us quite sleepy
however if we have any food if we have
enough of it that is if our gut is full
it diverts blood to our gut and we
become sleepy and we can't focus as well
so a lot of people really like fasting
in the state of being fasted for focus
and concentration because they don't
have as much of that parasympathetic
activation they're just not as sleepy
and in fact under those conditions half
as much caffeine will give you just as
much lift as twice as much caffeine will
give you on a full belly of pasta and
that's just the way that caffeine
interacts with blood glucose so what I'd
like you to imagine is if you had a
measure of focus from zero to ten these
are arbitrary units 10 being maximally
focused and zero being not focused at
all imagine a U-shaped function right
where if you're very fasted you're going
to have a high degree of focus and
concentration but then if you ingest
some food and your belly is full your
focusing concentration is reduced but
having enough blood glucose and maybe
even elevated blood glucose will
increase cognitive function so there are
two ends of the spectrum on one end of
the spectrum blood glucose is relatively
low and you're fasted and you can think
and behave in a very concentrated way
and on the other end of the spectrum you
have a lot of blood glucose or I should
say sufficient blood glucose you never
want your blood glucose to be too high
and that allows your neurons to encode
and perceive and basically allow you to
think really clearly so you sort of have
to pick your condition what do you want
for your bowel to focus and
concentration I actually do both so what
I do is as I mentioned before I eat my
meals sometime around 11AM my first meal
typically unless I'm very hungry when I
wake up and so I will do my workout and
one bout of focused work I always think
of this as my hard work early in the day
okay and I do that fasted I'll be
consuming water with electrolytes maybe
element or other electrolytes Maybe
some caffeine as well in the form of
yerba mate or coffee that's my first
Focus bout of 90 minutes or less that is
essentially done fasted and then I'll
eat and then I do notice after I eat I
actually have a diminished capacity to
focus but then again in the afternoon I
will do another 90 minute bout of focus
and I'll talk about some of the tools I
use to make sure that that bout of focus
is optimal for getting the most amount
of focused work done whether or not it's
mental work or physical work although I
tend to do my physical work early in the
day and my mental work both early and
late in the day so to make this very
simple or as simple as I can for you
being fasted is great for focus and
concentration provided you're not
thinking about food the entire time and
being fed is terrific for focus and
concentration actually can improve
neuronal function provided that you
didn't eat too much food so one way to
manage this is if you're going to have a
lunch to make sure that you don't stuff
yourself at lunch then you're not
overeating and to not get quite so full
that you put sheer nervous system into
this parasympathetic mode and make it
hard to focus in the afternoon I know a
lot of people experience a dip or even a
crash in energy in the afternoon that
make it really hard to focus for that
reason I'll just remind people of a tool
I've talked about many times before
which is based on the biology of
adenosine and caffeine Etc which is to
delay your first caffeine intake to 90
to 120 minutes after waking up I know
that can be painful for certain people I
violate that rule when I'm working out
very early in the morning I'll drink my
caffeine before my workout which often
occurs within you know 30 to 60 Minutes
of waking but in general unless I'm
working out very early I will ingest my
caffeine 90 to 100 120 minutes after I
wake up so again I want to emphasize
that if you hear somebody out there say
being fasted is optimal for focus and
concentration well that is true in one
context and perhaps ideal for a certain
part of the day and other people will
say no you know neurons run on glucose
you need glucose in your bloodstream in
order to get those neurons to be tuned
that is to respond with electrical
activity in the optimal way when you're
reading something or when you're trying
to perform exercise well that's also
true and of course you can incorporate
both I in fact as I just described
incorporate both fasted States and fed
States in order to optimize my
concentration and focus find
non-destructive ways to reset your
dopamine and your energy levels and do
those at least every three days
so for me it was kind of a a tough thing
to take a long walk or to spend I said
work really hard on Mondays really hard
on Tuesdays and I would not go in until
the afternoon on Wednesdays and
sometimes not at all
and then I go in Thursday Friday and
work really really hard and then not at
all on Saturday and then maybe do a
little bit of work from home on Sunday
and I was very productive that way that
those breaks are absolutely key and it's
not encouraged so much in academic or
Tech
or maybe anything now I hear about so
much stress and overwork I say you just
do it and Define the culture and let the
results and your focus be the the thing
that defines you not how many hours
you're in there but I realize there's a
huge cognitive load in energetic load
and for that I do think these non-sleep
deep breast Protocols are where it comes
in really handy they're at least two
faculty I know at Stanford one who's a
so-called Howard Hughes investigator
who's big is those are big deal
appointments they get tons of money et
cetera Etc and they do amazing science
most of the time
these individuals certainly do and they
take two 20-minute naps per day in their
office when this guy came and visited me
years ago when I was at a different
University he took the time that we were
supposed to meet in my office and talk
about data he asked if you could take a
nap
and he gave a great talk that afternoon
so
there you go I I do think you have to
take control of your schedule and do
those things I hope that helps and then
of course for some people
exercise and so on
um is the way they reset I do cry but
again about the things I mentioned
before I realize something by the way we
just recorded an episode on Grief it
hasn't come out yet uh fascinating topic
um I realized at one point by the way
I'll just give this away that
um I thought I was really sad about
losing them I thought I would tear up
really easily because I was sad about
them but then I realized this gosh I
can't believe I'm gonna do this but I
realized that feeling that I was feeling
is the exact same feeling of love that I
had when they were alive so grief is
love and when you look at the literature
it's it's basically that but your brain
is freaking out because that map of
knowing where people are in space and
time grief is basically a remapping of
the space where are they time when are
they and then this kind of abstract map
representation that we call closeness
and grief is this process of like
ripping ourselves off of that so in any
event what do I fear talking about
things like this
um
what do I fear
quite honestly the my biggest fear the
thing that would just make me feel just
horrible is I I fear letting down my
friends I have an amazing I love my
family and they're wonderful but I have
this in incredible relationship to
friendship and um I just I adore my
friends and I would sooner give up all
my limbs and die before I would I would
deliberately let them down so there you
go that's what I fear most okay this is
a wild literature and I love it and it's
changing the way that I do things I
thought that to remember things you're
supposed to get really really excited
really focused and remember them and
guess what that's not how you do it
there's there are data
and there are stories going back to
Medieval Times
that they used to teach kids things and
then throw them in the river
there's a beautiful annual review of
Neuroscience written by the late James
mcgaugh brilliant researcher who taught
me that in this review
and it turns out that if you want to
remember something you want to spike
adrenaline after you acquired that
information after
that means the Double Espresso and the
ice bath after you study for math
immediately after and you think about
this you know that makes perfect sense
right think about the one trial learning
that nobody wants to experience which is
a car accident or some traumatic thing
you didn't get the spike of adrenaline
first you got the spike of adrenaline
after
so
again you know I discourage the use of
excessive stimulants or you know
anything like that but if you're going
to try and remember information you need
to get your brain and body into a high
autonomic arousal State literally you
need to deploy adrenaline into your
system after you have made the attempt
to learn some information
so much so that if you give people a
beta blocker
after learning emotional information
they don't learn it as well incredible
just incredible data in animals and
humans is the the beautiful work of
Larry Cahill at UC Irvine and James
McGaw so that's how I would focus on
remembering things better and it's also
true that if you tell yourself that
something's really important to you
you'll you'll be able to learn it better
if you meet people and they tell you
their name and you forget two seconds
later well you should probably be
thinking and now I do this I meet people
and I think okay what what terrible
thing did this person do just trying to
spike my adrenaline or something like
that it's a terrible trick but I haven't
figured out a better way but that's
actually one that data supported way to
do that
easily a dozen or more studies in humans
on that very topic how is social media
changing our brains you hear all the
terrible ways in which it's changing our
brains and I think that
again we go back to this thing is is it
the aperture that we're looking at so is
it the format that we're engaging in
things
or is it
the content well the way I like to think
about the phone is the way that we've
been engaging with the phone and the
laptop for that matter in staring into
the small visual aperture each day is
sort of like walking like this all day
long
right we have this amazing ability to
shuffle our feet and take small steps or
to take big strides to run to move I
think that's the sagittal plane for
movement I know it for the brain but it
always messes the pts are vicious people
online by the way the pts and nutrition
people I've learned to just not
not say anything about that I'm not a PT
and I'm not a physical therapist and
they do incredible work but they're like
it's a very spirited crowd
and the nutrition thing is really weird
how there I mean it's just incredible
you either people are either throwing
liver at you or they're throwing celery
at you or they're they're fasting or
they're not fasting it's nuts
in any case
they
social media and staring at a small
visual aperture is changing our brains
here's one way I know in which is
changing our brains and then I'll tell
you how to fix it
if you stare or look at something to
within two feet of you for a certain
number of hours each day your eyeball
actually gets longer
and the visual image then is focused in
front of your neural retina not onto
your neural retina and you are becoming
myopic nearsighted
and if you look at things in the
distance enough guess what your eyeball
changes shape and your lens will focus
appropriately the image onto your retina
take some work kids that look at things
up close too much and adults that look
at things up close so much become
nearsighted
and there's a beautiful set of clinical
trials now where mainly in kids if kids
get outside for two hours a day getting
a lot of this UVB and blue light that
we're told is so terrible for us but
they get it from sunlight
they actually can reverse myopia or
reduce the incidence of myopia maybe
even glaucoma although that's a big
Maybe
so
how much staring into a small visual
aperture is too much
I don't know but what we do know is that
we are literally becoming myopic in
terms of our vision and we're becoming
myopic in terms of our cognition and
then there's the whole business of
what's actually contained in those
tweets and those social media feeds and
those news stories which frankly I feel
like you lose either way whether or not
you're in one political camp or another
political Camp you're upset about half
of the information out there
so I feel like it's you know I and I'm
not a a not someone who knows how to
talk about politics without stumbling
didn't do well in social studies and
this sort of thing it just never made
sense to me it just felt like the the
prize goes to the person who can shout
the loudest and the most coherently for
a moment so but I encourage of course
people to be politically active
and I vote
but but the
the content is tricky to navigate and I
can't really speak to that except that
it seems to be bothering everybody
on one side or the other or in the
middle and
the format is something that we really
understand and again I don't know of
many people that are talking about this
narrow visual window format thing it
came up more during the lockdowns when
we were all inside a lot and not looking
out at a distance the the data says
really to try and get at least 10
minutes of long distance viewing so
longer than 10 feet away from us for
every 30 minutes of close-up viewing and
not a lot of us are doing that if you're
walking to your car looking at your
phone you're definitely losing an
opportunity
I know many people are curious as to
whether or not caffeine can improve
focus and concentration and indeed it
can there is an immense amount of data
supporting the idea that caffeine
provided it's consumed in the
appropriate dosages can improve mental
Performance and Physical performance and
it largely does that through
improvements in focus and concentration
the dosage of caffeine of course is
going to depend on how caffeine adapted
you are how much caffeine tolerance you
have and that is going to vary
tremendously
depending on whether or not you ingest
that caffeine with or without food as I
mentioned earlier but there is a kind of
General range in which we can talk about
caffeine as being useful for focus and
concentration and the range is basically
from 100 milligrams to 400 milligrams I
want to caution everybody out there if
you're somebody who suffers from anxiety
or panic attacks and you're not used to
ingesting caffeine and you run out and
ingest 400 milligrams of caffeine in the
form of espresso or yerba mate or an
energy drink or in pill form that is
going to be very uncomfortable for you
you're going to be sweating profusely
your heart rate is going to increase
you're going to be quite panicked in
fact or at least anxious so be cautious
with your use and adopting of caffeine
if you're not already caffeine adapted
but most people do quite well to ingest
100 to 200 milligrams of caffeine prior
to doing some focused work and again I
recommend delaying your caffeine intake
to 90 to 120 minutes after waking unless
you are using that caffeine to really
jolt your system uh before a workout
caffeine can of course be ingested in
various forms even pill form but most
people ingest it in the form of coffee
or my particular favorite way to ingest
caffeine is yerba mate it is important
and I should note that you should
actively avoid the smoked versions of
yerba mate as they contain a lot of
carcinogenic cancer promoting compounds
there's some great yerba mate Brands out
there that most cost effective way to
consume it would be to use the loose
leaf tea and to to pour water over that
there's one particular brand that I like
I don't have any affiliation to them
whatsoever but I've been using it for
years as Anna Park it's an organic brand
that is sold I buy mine on Amazon but
you can find it elsewhere on the
internet as well again I don't have any
affiliation to them it's just very cost
effective very clean it doesn't have the
smoked flavor at least the one that I
buy is not the smoked varieties and none
of the carcinogenic compounds are in
there at least that I'm aware of and I
like the way it tastes and it provides a
very even lift and and stimulant of that
I think certainly works for me in that a
number of people I know that have
suggested to also enjoy
yerba mate or caffeine also have other
additional benefits in particular the
caffeine in yerba mate and coffee and
other sources of caffeine are known to
increase the density and efficacy that
is the number and the function of
dopamine receptors and this has been
shown in humans several times so by
ingesting caffeine pretty regularly
you're actually increasing the ability
of dopamine to have this effect of
increasing motivation and drive I tend
to ingest caffeine only early in the day
I tend to cut off my caffeine intake
somewhere around 1 or 2 pm to ensure
that I can get into a good night's sleep
but I realize that there are people out
there that ingest caffeine as late as
two or three in the afternoon and can
still sleep fine I will caution those of
you that think that you can drink
caffeine in the evening or nighttime and
still fall asleep all of the research
points to the fact that the architecture
of your sleep and the depth of your
sleep is disrupted even if you're able
to fall and stay asleep the sleep you're
getting is simply not as good as the
sleep you would get if you were to shut
off your caffeine intake at least eight
hours before bedtime and ideally more
like 10 or even 12 hours before bedtime
but of course there are practical
constraints as well okay so caffeine is
increasing dopamine's function by
changing the number and efficacy of
dopamine receptors but of course it also
increases our wakefulness our alertness
and that is largely through the
neurochemical systems related to
adenosine which is a molecule that
builds up in our brain and body the
longer we are awake it's part of the
sleepiness system if you will makes us
feel fatigued or tired and
caffeine also operates on the
epinephrine the adrenaline system in
fact if we ingest too much caffeine
we'll sometimes get the Jitters those
Jitters are really the sympathetic as
it's called nervous systems bias toward
movement and our pupils will dilate they
actually get broader now somewhat
paradoxically when our pupils get bigger
the peoples of our eyes that is
our visual World actually narrows it
becomes more tunnel like a lot of people
don't realize this when our pupils are
really small that means we are relaxed
so if you ever see someone with really
tiny or you know pin sized pupils
they're very relaxed if their pupils are
very big they're very dilated well then
they are very amped up they're V they
are very very alert
caffeine increases alertness by
increasing epinephrine adrenaline
release both in the brain and within the
body and so that's another way that it
facilitates focus and concentration I
want to acknowledge that many people
enjoy alcohol in moderation or even
light drinking the occasional drink or
the occasional two drinks or maybe even
on average one drink per night so seven
drinks per week I'm certainly not here
to tell you what to do and what not to
do
I do find it immensely interesting
however that first of all alcohol is a
known toxin to the cells of the body
some of you might immediately say well
wait what about hormesis what about this
phenomenon where if we regularly ingest
a toxin it makes us stronger in other
words what doesn't kill us makes us
stronger yeah there's you know some
reason to believe that might be
beneficial in terms of some forms of
seller resilience maybe maybe no
sorry it doesn't work that way there are
processes of hormesis in which for
instance exposing yourself safely to
increases in Adrenaline through you know
ice baths or other things that increase
adrenaline can raise your so-called
stress threshold but here we're talking
about cellular stress and damage to
cells
so my read of the literature and again
this is my read and I invite others to
you know provide studies or I would
prefer actually collections of studies
that point in the direction if they
exist that
alcohol can be beneficial but my read of
the literature or I should say my
understanding of what I would call the
center of mass of the literature on
alcohol
is that
no consumption zero consumption
consumption of zero ounces of alcohol
is going to be better for your health
than low to moderate consumption of
alcohol
and that low to moderate consumption of
alcohol is going to be better for you of
course than moderately High to high
alcohol consumption on the order of 12
to 24 or more drinks per week
I realize that for most people listening
to this it's probably low to moderate
alcohol consumption that is part of
their standard repertoire and
I'm not here to give you justification
for doing that nor am I going to tell
you not to do that I would like you to
consider perhaps however the negative
effects that we understand and that are
documented for instance the negative
effects of alcohol in the gut microbiome
and the things that you can do to better
support your gut microbiome the negative
effects on the stress system that HPA
axis that we talked about earlier and
the fact that even low to moderate
levels of alcohol consumption can
increase our levels of stress when we're
not drinking
and to think about
acquiring some tools and you know
getting some proficiency with tools
Behavioral or otherwise that can help
you with stress modulation that don't
involve alcohol consumption so again the
point here is to illustrate where the
problems lie with alcohol consumption
but also what I've tried to do is to
point you to some resources that can
help offset some of those negative
effects well they offset all the effects
I can't say that for sure but certainly
taking measures
to offset some of the negative effects
of any alcohol consumption that you
might be having or doing is going to be
beneficial to you and those tools and
Protocols are going to be Health
promoting in any case if we were to draw
a line between the obsessions and the
compulsions that line could be described
as anxiety
now we need to Define what anxiety is
and to be quite honest most of
psychology and science can't agree on
exactly what anxiety is typically the
way we think about fear is that it's a
heightened state of autonomic arousal so
increased heart rate increase breathing
sweating Etc in response to an immediate
and present threat or perceived threat
whereas anxiety generally speaking in
the scientific literature relates to the
same sorts of thought patterns and
somatic bodily responses heart rate
breathing Etc but without a clear and
present danger being in the environment
or right there so that's the way that
we're going to talk about anxiety now
and anxiety is really what binds the
obsessions and compulsions such that
someone will have an intrusive thought
so for instance someone will have the
thought that if they turn left on any
street that something bad will happen
Okay that's an obsession it's actually
not all that uncommon now how bad and
what the specificity of that bad thing
really is will vary some people will
think if I turn left something generally
bad will happen it just makes me feel
anxious so they always insist on going
right whereas other people will think if
I turn left
so and so will die or I will die or
something terrible will happen I'll get
a disease or someone else will get a
disease or I'll be cursing myself or
somebody else in some very specific way
this is unfortunately quite common in
people with OCD so
they have this feeling and the feeling
can be generally or specifically related
to a particular outcome but beneath that
is a feeling of anxiety a quickening of
the heartbeat a quickening of breathing
a narrowing of one's visual Focus I've
talked about this before on other
podcasts the master stress and other
podcasts but if you haven't heard those
let me just briefly describe that when
we are in a state of increased so-called
autonomic arousal alertness stress Etc
our visual field literally Narrows the
aperture of our visual field gets
smaller and that's because of the
relationship between the autonomic
nervous system and your visual system so
you start seeing the world through sort
of soda straw view or through
binocular-like view as opposed to seeing
the big picture why is that important
well it literally sharpens and narrows
your focus toward the very thing that
the obsessions and the compulsions are
focused on so the person walking down
the street who sees the opportunity to
go left or right will only see the bad
decision their visual field Narrows very
tightly along that possibility of taking
a left turn and I know as I described it
seems totally irrational but I want to
emphasize that the person with OCD knows
it's irrational they might feel crazy
because they're having these thoughts
but they know it makes no sense
whatsoever that left somehow would be
different than right in terms of
outcomes in this particular case and yet
it feels as if it would in fact in some
cases it feels as if they went left they
would have a full-blown panic attack so
the idea here is that the obsessions and
compulsions are bound by anxiety but
then by taking a right hand turn again
in this one particular example by taking
a right hand turn there's a very brief I
should mention very brief relief of that
anxiety
at the time of the decision to go right
not left and there's an additional drop
in anxiety while one takes the right
hand turn as opposed to the left-hand
turn and then as I alluded to before
there's a reinforcement of the
compulsion in other words by going right
it doesn't
create a situation in the brain and
psychology of the person that uh you
know what I'm not anxious anymore left
would have probably been okay it
reinforces the idea that right made me
feel better or turning right made me
feel better and going left would have
been that much worse again it reinforces
the obsession even further and again we
could swap out right turns and left
turns with something like hand washing
the feeling that something is
contaminated and the need to wash one's
hands even though one already washed
their hands 20 30 50 times prior we're
actually going to go back to that
example a little bit later when we talk
about one particular category of
therapies that are very effective in
many people for OCD which are the
cognitive behavioral and exposure
therapies because I think some of you
have heard of cognitive behavioral and
exposure therapies but the way they are
used to treat OCD is very much different
than the way they're used to treat other
sorts of anxiety disorders and other
sorts of disorders generally so it's
fair to say that up to 70 percent of
people with OCD have some sort of
anxiety or elevated anxiety either
directly related to the OCD or
indirectly related to the OCD and it's
really hard to tease those apart because
OCD can create its own anxiety as I
mentioned before it can even increase
its own anxiety and there's also an
issue of depression having OCD can be
very depressing right especially if some
of these OCD thoughts and behaviors
start to really impede people's ability
to function in life at work in school
and relationship they can start feeling
less optimistic about life and in fact
some people can become suicidally
depressed that's how bad OCD can be for
us so we have to be careful when saying
that 70 of people with OCD also have
anxiety or X number of people with OCD
are also depressed because we don't know
whether or not the depression led the
OCD or the other way around or whether
or not they're operating as we say in
science in parallel some of the drug
treatments for OCD and depression and
anxiety can tease some of that apart and
we'll talk about that but I think it's
fair to say that what binds the
obsessions and compulsions is anxiety
that there's a feeling of it or I should
say an urgent feeling of a need to get
rid of the obsession and the person
feels as if the only way they can do
that is to engage in a particular
compulsive Behavior so everyone knows
that the brain is very plastic early in
life so from birth until about age 25
you can learn so much for Better or For
Worse I always say the downside is that
early in life you're you have less
control over your life circumstances but
your brain is very plastic so there's a
you know darkened light to that later in
life you have a lot more control
generally over your life circumstances
but the brain becomes less plastic
however we know based on Nobel prize
winning work and recent work in addition
to that that the neuromodulator
acetylcholine is secreted when we pay
attention to something very specific it
acts as sort of a spotlight in the brain
making certain synapses the connections
between neurons more active and more
likely to be active again than others so
when you hear that song that you love so
much and it moves you and you feel
dopamine being pulsed into your body
that's a real thing you're actually
getting dopamine secretion you've formed
that deep association with that and
acetylcholine draws your attention to
that and that song is essentially
actually wired in a very indelible way
into your nervous system at multiple you
can probably even with certain songs you
can feel your body start to energize
because of course the brain through
connections with your muscles controls
your body so for things that are
traumatic or negative what we're really
talking about is neuroplasticity that's
focused on unlearning and most of the
therapies for this whether or not it's
EMDR eye movement desensitization
reprocessing or it's traditional
psychoanalysis and Psychotherapy or it's
somatic embodied release big you know
Kundalini breathing type almost all of
those are designed to do something which
is to bring the person or you bring
yourself into a state of heightened
alertness right you can't do this stuff
when you're sort of half asleep
heightened alertness and then focusing
your attention on the traumatic or
negative event this is the way that
works and then pairing that with
something new you know traditionally
this was done with things like NLP or in
talk therapy where people would feel the
relation the positive relationship with
the therapist that was kind of the main
rationale in association with this very
traumatic sometimes even you know
shameful type events and the idea is
that you you would simultaneously have
those two experiences the negative one
and the feeling of safety and you would
rewire those circuitries I actually
believe that can work but it can take a
lot of times it can take a lot of visits
to the therapist which is not to say
it's bad it's just not everyone has
access to those resources
things like eye movement desensitization
reprocessing simply moving the eyes
laterally while recounting these
negative events the woman who devised
this
figured out that somehow when people
recount these traumatic experiences when
they're doing these lateralized eye
movements not vertical eye movements
they somehow separate out the negative
emotions and I thought for years people
would ask me about this stuff Tom and I
thought this is ridiculous first of all
I'm a vision scientist and I work on
stress it's like there's no way and then
I really ate my words because four
papers two Inhumans two in mice and then
a fifth paper published in nature which
is kind of our Super Bowl of scientific
publishing
showed that these lateralized eye
movements quiet the amygdala they
actually suppress activation of this
threat detection Center in the amygdala
and why would that be true ah so this is
really where it gets cool turns out
because of when the way that we view the
visual world when we move through space
when our head moves or when we walk and
things flow past us that these
lateralized eye movements are what
happens when you move forward in space
when you're walking when you're moving
forward towards something and that
suppresses activation of the amygdala
now you say why well okay so then 2018
my laboratory did an experiment there
was an actual graduate student in my
laboratory where we're looking at fear
in this case we're looking at fear to
Big looming objects that either trigger
freezing or running and hiding there's a
brain area that's in your brain and my
brain that mice also have that triggers
a third option not run and hide not
freeze but forward confrontation this is
the no I'm gonna fight I'm gonna move
forward in the face of adversity this is
the growth mindset I'm going to lean
into friction and it turns out that this
circuit is linked to the dopamine reward
pathway when we move forward in the face
of a threat and obviously we want to do
this in healthy adaptive ways we
suppress activity of the amygdala
through physical action of moving
forward and there's a signal sent to the
areas of the brain that control dopamine
reward
those reward centers then trigger the
release of dopamine to reward forward
effort in the face of stress or threat
so when you hear about people saying
look take some physical action when
you're feeling exhausted take some
forward physical action when you're
feeling overwhelmed by this traumatic
experience now that could be in the form
of a walk in the now this therapist she
figured out with EMDR because you can't
take people walking around for therapy
sessions she figured out that these
lateralized eye movements are what
trigger suppression of the amygdala and
it makes perfect sense because the
amygdala this threat detection Center in
our brain it doesn't connect to the
limbs so how does it know if you're
moving forward well because the eyes are
moving you have these reflexive mind
movements that move anytime you're
moving through space so to make this a
little more succinct it's really forward
movement action pushing yourself across
that threshold not only rewards you but
it suppresses activity of the fear
centers in the brain and these are
ancient hardwired mechanisms these
aren't hacks these are things that
mother nature installed in US
dopamine is not just about reward it's
one of the biggest misconceptions
dopamine is about motivation and drive
it's like a jet that propels you along a
path how do we get more dopamine you
practice subjectively releasing dopamine
in your mind like wow okay so that's a
great question first of all there are
ways you can get more dopamine release
through thoughts or through drugs or
through supplements I want to be really
clear there is a drug there are two
drugs actually that will cause massive
release of dopamine they're called
cocaine and methamphetamine the problem
that's what gets us addicted because it
feels so good the problem is exactly the
problem is cocaine and methamphetamine
stimulate so much dopamine release that
the drug becomes the only source it
becomes the goal of the path it becomes
the path and the destination and you
look at people's lives when they do a
lot of cocaine and methamphetamine and
that Baseline on their life goes down
because there's no reason to work hard
at anything else because you feel good
that's right dopamine is the same
incredibly powerful molecule that allows
us to buffer the effort process it
allows us to be an effort longer and it
allows us to actually eventually enjoy
the process of effort and not think
about the reward but just say oh I'm
enjoying the process right well you just
described the first step the first step
in learning to attach dopamine to the
effort process which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to be
very careful about how much you focus on
the end goal keeping the goal in mind is
important for like a proper orientation
you have to know the ultimate
destination but if at any point we were
to evaluate our progress relative to
that end goal or if we don't know what
the end goal is there's a huge gap there
if we want to be very concrete we should
probably focus on actions and I'll use
Fitness as an example because it
translates to everybody whereas you know
people's circumstances different let's
say somebody really wants to take on a
fitness routine they hate running or
they want to lose weight in a healthy
way this kind of thing so we've all
heard the example well you put your
shoes by the door on day one day two you
put them on day three you go out the
door day four you walk around the block
and then you know and then eventually
like they're running marathons okay
great but to sustain that behavior or
even to make the the behavior
pleasureful and to give you energy the
key is to subjectively reward those
steps so it's not going to be let's say
I go out and I run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mile the hard part you want to
tell yourself this is the good part this
is the part that gives me energy and
I'll be very surprised if people don't
actually feel like they could continue
further so it's a journey of a Thousand
Miles starts with a single is made up of
you know single steps but the key is to
reward the harder steps not the easier
ones and not the ones where you get the
thing that you want I'm trying to write
a book and it's hard it's hard and I was
told that the harder it is the better
I'm probably doing it I was like great
my editor is ready to kill me and
because I'm slow and I and I know and
I'm a very slow person I I drive people
crazy I'm like glacially slow because
science is slow and I like to get things
right I want to rush it I like to get
things right but I'm very proud of the
fact that everything we've published I
can stand behind it was the best we
could do with the tools at the time and
I just know that when I look back on a
writing career or scientific career I
want to be able to say you know every
Journal we put in was Rock Solid
everything was Rock Solid we had fun
doing it the relationship so I go slow
yeah but as a consequence what I'm
finding is
there are a lot of interferences these
days I'm I'm I think social media is
great I teach Neuroscience on social
media because I think it's important to
do public education distraction too but
it's incredible and it's it's incredible
how much time and energy it can take so
what I've started doing now is I turn
off my phone and I lock it in safe
and I experience extreme anxiety right
it's so weird why is that is it because
it gives you so much dopamine that when
you're not having it well this is scary
because I actually think
um brief anecdote on the weekend I was
driving there's a kid that I mentor and
I picked up my phone I was texting while
I was driving and he said to me it was
really embarrassing for me he said you
know
I wish he wouldn't text while you drive
and I put it and I put it down and I
realized this is crazy I know that I
that my life and his life is far more
important and the lives of the people
around me are far more important than
any text message which means I wasn't
think doing it rationally it's just pure
reflex at this point so I was I don't
think I'd pick up the phone because I'm
I don't even know what I'm looking for
there anymore it's just become reflexive
so
for me lately the longer I can keep that
phone in a safe and right on a grant or
my or this book what I tell myself is
the agitation is good I'm it's at least
I'm not doing that and then I find that
as I start to write and I get into the
process I start feeling good about it
and I I'll pause and say okay I I have
control I have ultimate control over my
behavior I can put that thing away there
might be a nuclear war out there and
I'm just doing this anyway I have
control over my thoughts my feelings and
behavior so I tell myself that and then
I find I have immense energy and all I
want to do is write and I kind of tunnel
into the process wow and I think that
sometimes people need to write these
things out for themselves so it's really
concrete I think some people are so
unskilled at subjective rewards that
writing it out is really powerful so
what would you write out for yourself as
a subjective reward for this experience
as long as I'm writing I'm on the right
path as long as I'm not writing I'm
looking at my phone I'm not on the right
path because for me the the two or three
things that are most important for my
career are writing grants working on
this book manuscript and writing
scientific manuscripts I mean there are
other things anything else that you're
not doing is is holding you back from
doing that that's right so you need to
be focused Center Mass forward on doing
those things that's right so I don't do
any jumping around power poses things
like that I will use tools to kind of
ramp up my dope I mean there are certain
songs that are really embedded in my
emotionally my emotional thing they go
back to you know when I was a you know
wild you know skateboarding punk rock
teenager that will get me fired up and
though I think there's real utility
that's pure doping #growth mindset is
one of the most popular hashtags in
social media but most people don't
actually know what it means and again
this is Carol dweck's discovery not mine
it was discovered in a group of kids
that were doing math problems or other
kinds of puzzles that they knew they
couldn't get right but they enjoy doing
them and they perform exceedingly well
on lots of sorts of tests of that sort
when there is the right answer of course
and so what they do is they've somehow
they're wired for effort they're wired
for the puzzle not for the solution and
when I say puzzle I don't mean the noun
puzzle I mean the verb for being puzzled
for them feels good and so we need to
think if we're talking about the nervous
system and we want to make it actionable
for high performance whether or not it's
in business or sport or otherwise we
want to think in terms of processes not
events and verbs not nouns so growth
mindset as a verb as an action item you
know uh reward as a verb not just as a
you're going to just pat yourself on the
back like it's no it's what you
internalize it's a process that's how
the neural circuits that underlie reward
get stronger and the beauty of of the
brain is that you have this thing of
neuroplasticity which is its ability to
change itself throughout the whole
lifespan and the more you practice this
the better you get at it and it does not
mean you're walking around talking
delusionally about how great life is
when everything is terrible it means you
might even be very stoic you might be
hopefully you're very rational but you
have the energy to continue to push
forward there's an interesting process
that
um that occurs when people start to
realize that rewards are all internal
and what they start to do is they start
linking this duration path outcome thing
to their internal rewards and so to put
this simply one of the most powerful
things that any person can do is to
learn to control this idea of duration
path and outcome and attach an internal
sense of reward just that you're doing
well to reward yourself mentally just
say I'm doing well I'm actually on the
right path
to do that inside of the demands that
come from the external world the more
often that we can self-reward some
aspect of the process provided it's in
the right direction of what we're trying
to achieve
the more energy we're going to have for
that the more Focus we're going to have
for that and remember the nor the reason
I say energy I don't throw that around
Loosely is that limiting amount of
noradrenaline is constantly being kept
at Bay you're literally buffering the
quit response and so when people start
realizing that
if they set the goals inside of the
larger goal and self-reward each one of
those they essentially have an infinite
amount of energy to pursue
those goals they have an infinite amount
of focus to pursue those goals you see
this most uh in the Special Operations
community and people that are selected
essentially for this process it's one of
the things that's been intriguing to me
I have some friends from the SEAL Teams
and I don't begin to you know really
understand the real work that they do
deployed because I've never done that
kind of work but I've always been
intrigued by the selection process the
so-called buds process right because
carrying logs and getting in cold water
and all that that's not really how the
work is that's really not what the work
is about so the selection process is
interesting because everyone shows up
fit motivated and convinced that they're
not going to quit I mean I think like
there might be a couple people that just
show up to show up but everybody is
absolutely convinced and then a very
small subset of them make it through and
I'd be willing to bet that the ones that
make it through
of course they're gritty and resilient
but they all are essentially right so
that's necessary but not sufficient
obviously otherwise everyone would make
it through the people that make it
through somehow are able to tap into a
process maybe it's a reward process
maybe it's through self-punishment maybe
it's through self-reward
um in the positive sense but they're
able to control something inside an
environment that is not controlled by
them it's controlled by the by the
instructors and
I've always been struck by the fact that
in order to to not in order to get
through you just have to not quit
remember people aren't being deselected
they're not saying get out of here
you're not good enough you're not people
are deciding that for themselves and so
it's interesting because
it brings about a real world experiment
of people who are quitting and I believe
they're quitting because they can't
manage these neurotransmitters and the
people when I say manage I think that
the people they get through knowing some
of these people quite well had an
internal process by which they could
reward themselves for doing something
that might have just looked trivial to
everybody else but it gave them more gas
more energy right right and what's
interesting is the process the the kind
of unconscious Genius of of the buds
process is that they've picked two
sensory events that are
across the board challenging for
everybody one is cold water which is
great because it most of the time it
can't kill you right it's not like heat
which can kill you it's cold water and
sleep deprivation and so the ability to
do these like what I'm calling dpos this
uh duration path and outcome
steps and procedures is great on when
you're rested you know uh you know when
you have a when you have well-fed well
slept you can do anything you can be in
any hard conversation you can work
through anything so what they do is they
start taking the autonomic nervous
system which is these deep reserves of
the nervous system
that when our autonomic nervous system
is off it starts making us pay more
attention to how we feel than the
demands of the world around us remember
that yeah basic challenge in the nervous
system and so sleep deprivation
is the best way that you can pull
somebody down from their ability to
analyze duration path and outcome and
reward themselves sleep deprivation is
the way in which you essentially pull
apart the nervous system and the way
that it wants to function because it's
very easy again rested to do all this
but so what they do is they're sleep
deprived people they put them in cold
water they're trying to get them more in
touch with the way that they feel inside
than what they need to do in response to
the external demands right everyone I
know that's made it through that process
did it slightly differently but I'll
tell you how they didn't do it they
didn't do it through sheer grit and
determination they did it through
attaching a sense of meaning they did it
by micro slicing the day or slicing the
day into a series of meals that they
just needed to get to and then rewarding
themselves for getting to that next
Milestone so they don't know I mean most
of them you know probably had very low
concept of dopamine and norepinephrine
but that's the process that's also the
process I think that allows them to
finish an ultra I've never run an ultra
but I think that process of self-reward
is grit and resilience in a kind of
neurochemical definition yeah and I
think it's a thing that anybody can tap
into and I think it's therefore I think
it's it's so key because I think people
think that uh it's just so key that
people understand excuse me that these
circuits are not unique to people who
run Ultras or people that make it
through uh you know stringent filter
Special Operations Command I suggest
people avoid layering dopamine you know
you have one dopamine system that
fortunately can be activated by a lot of
different things so for instance I love
the feeling of being completely rested
going into the gym or going for a run
mid-morning after a cup of coffee
hydrating well using the bathroom
listening to my favorite music on a
sunny day but that's a lot of things
layering in for dopamine and what
happens is that if that becomes your
hope and expectation fine but if that
becomes your requirement for actually
having a great run or work out you're in
trouble because the next time you're
it's not going to be that exciting and
you're not going to be that motivated
you actually won't perform as well so
this year what I've been doing is every
third or fourth workout or so I think
I'm randomly I leave my phone in the car
I don't use any music and I don't allow
myself any kind of pre-workout stimulant
so I have to generate all the force and
energy and everything I'm going to do
from internal processes and you might
say well that's kind of masochistic why
would you do that it's supposed to be
fun well I'll tell you when the next
time when you bring your headphones
you're listening to music you feel like
a god in there what the Writ why because
you are secreting so much more dopamine
so much more noradrenaline so much more
effective at performance but then the
next time you have to throttle it back
and so I'm excited by all the tools that
are out there all the you know there's
all this like cognitive enhancement
stuff and people are you know plugging
into every device and they're trying to
figure out do I have white noise in the
background or metronomes all that stuff
but it's good to not layer in too many
things
um there are other examples of this
where
um are a little more
um unfortunate uh pornography is a
really good example there's a huge issue
now right because pornography is so much
more readily available on the internet
now let's just remove the kind of um the
moral uh judgments about it right
because that's not what this is about a
scientific discussion about this would
say that there's an enormous
availability and range of imagery that's
very powerful that feeds directly into
the dopamine system
and a lot of people young people who are
growing up watching a lot of intense
pornography are suffering from a lot of
sexual side effects and struggles and
sexual interactions in real life because
those interactions are not as intense as
the things that they're seeing the other
thing that's happening I should just
mention is that I've got colleagues that
work on this in Psychiatry that that
they are wiring their nervous systems to
become aroused viewing other people
having
sex as opposed to them having it and so
they're running into a lot of trouble
there so what's happening is very
interesting dopamine levels are so high
that real life circle it's like it's
like eating extremely palatable foods
that are just blitzing your system every
taste bud at high salt high sugar high
fat to the point where it's just and
let's assume delicious I don't generally
like those kinds of foods but and then
all of a sudden it's like here's a bowl
of rice or a or a salad it's gonna taste
like garbage to you because you're at
first anyway that's also got to be sort
of trickling over to just social media
in general and and the dopamine release
in response to that versus say for
example a real life conversation right
well and if you're on social media and
you're scrolling and you don't even know
why you're scrolling like you don't even
know what you're looking for your
dopamine system has been tapped out and
you need to take a break from it maybe a
couple hours maybe a couple of days I
think social media is great I teach
signs on social media to you all the
time on social media you know there's a
lot of great social interaction there's
a lot of opportunity to learn and see
things some are funny some are
interesting some are disturbing but when
you're at the point where you're
engaging in something and you don't even
know what the win is but you find
yourself reflexively engaging in it your
dopamine system is now plummeting and
that's a serious issue so the other
thing is that a picture is worth a
thousand words and a movie is worth a
thousand pictures
our visual system is so tuned to watch
motion and to see movies so you're
seeing movie after movie after movie
after movie what's happening is the
context is switching constantly our the
human brain has never been confronted
with context switching at this rate you
know a television you know went from you
know six channels to 12 to 200 but this
is the first time that you can walk
around with your television you can have
it in your car you can have it on the
phone excuse me on the plane so I use
social media and the internet a lot
um unlike email or reading an article
online social media is you know you can
scroll through a thousand different or a
hundred different contexts within five
minutes and that's a big override for
the brain and then the rest of the world
seems kind of boring
like you know you see people at dinner
scrolling their phone it's because
actually the brain wants novelty it's
seeking novelty all the time these days
I'm I'm turning off my phone in the
evenings I'm sort of I'm on there a
little bit but I'm finding I'm kind of
sick of the phone I think a lot of
people are kind of hitting this point
where they're like nah I'll get on
social media for an hour or two a day
but this is getting a little pointless
yeah I think that an ability to know
that things pass an ability to know that
what you're feeling in the moment is not
a permanent State and doesn't
necessarily return an ability to know
that your identity 10 years ago
hopefully isn't your identity now and
you can actually transform your identity
over time is immensely powerful it's
when we get into these locked regimes of
who we are how we feel how we think that
kind of the like impending doom really
takes over not to be dramatic about it
but everyone I know that is that isn't
able to adopt a kind of different ideas
about how things could be different on
the outside and on the inside
is suffering right and everyone I know
that has the kind of mindset
unfortunately I happen to know a lot of
people like this that understand that
yeah your internal state is something
you can shift with exercise with
movement with ice bath with breathing
with whatever your your particular
leanings are then they seem to
understand that that like grabbing hold
of that internal real estate first is
kind of a door that opens like oh my
world and my life is actually something
I completely control and so this
conversation there's this portion of the
conversation might not seem that
scientific but it's absolutely
scientific in the sense that the brain
is a time-space statistical guessing
machine it just wants to know what's
coming next that's all it wants to know
and so if you can start to expand the
notion of what's come what could come
next you really start to open up
possibility an impossibility you start
to open up the physiology of the body to
explore and in Exploration you get
different outcomes so these I think that
this kind of mystical or abstract level
of the conversation is really at the
core of what human beings are best at
which is using the front of our brain to
conceive new ways of doing things this
is like the reason we're not this is the
reason we run the planet and other
animals don't it's like my dog Costello
doesn't wake up and say oh you know
I want more food so I'm here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna tomorrow you know he
just basically is like he does what he
needs to to get what he needs in the
moment we're the planners and in
planning we can do so much more but in
planning it's also where we suffer if we
plan to feel the same way so in a lot of
ways we're planning to feel the same way
people vary in the extent to which they
feel or have the capacity to feel bonded
to anyone
and it is now
generally understood that some of that
variation might depend on variations in
oxytocin receptors or what are called
Gene polymorphisms for oxytocin genes
can have a number of different sequences
in them they're nucleotide sequences we
won't go into genetics right now ages
and G's and C's and T's in various
combinations are what make up the genes
genes are transcribed into RNA RNA is
translated into proteins that affect
cells okay the oxytocin Gene encodes for
oxytocin and variants in that Gene
change the amount and function of
oxytocin there's a really interesting
study published just this last year in a
relatively new Journal that journal has
a kind of an unusual name it's helion I
think it's helion and not helion but
helion
h-e-l-i-y-o-n this is a cell Press
Journal as far as I can tell it's a very
solid Journal certainly the cell press
label is very stringent in this paper
is entitled the relation between
oxytocin receptor Gene polymorphisms
which just means changes in in genes
or variations in genes adult attachment
and Instagram sociability and
exploratory analysis this is a really
wild study but I like the study it's
very thorough first author last name
carollo
c-a-r-o-l-l-o and what they found was
that
by analyzing the genetics of different
individuals who are on social media
and looking at how many people
those individuals follow and how many
people follow them and what they come up
with is a so-called social desirability
index they were able to correlate in a
very straightforward way that people
that carry certain variants in the
oxytocin and oxytocin receptor genes
actually seek out more online social
Instagram interactions so some people I
know I won't name their names only
follow you know anywhere from zero to
six accounts other people follow
thousands of accounts and they take the
ratio of how many accounts people follow
versus how many followers they have
arguably not a perfect measure but a
nice one in the sense that you can do
this in a completely unbiased way with
many many thousands of subjects and then
they were able to get genomic analysis
from a number of these subjects and it
turns out that people who have let's say
higher levels of oxytocin function or
potential
levels of oxytocin function actively
seek out more social interactions on
social media so this I think represents
an important first in the area of how
social media and data from social media
are starting to merge with biological
data
in terms of predicting how avidly people
will seek out social interactions of an
online type and nowadays we hear a lot
about how online we are connected but
we're not really where what is it we're
communicating but we're not connected or
the connections aren't real I think
we're going to need to revisit that
while I'm certainly a believer in the
idea that face-to-face communication and
common interactions with people
standing in the same space or playing
sports together enjoying music together
enjoying meals together is vitally
important there's an entire generation
or several generations of people that
are coming up who much of their social
interaction has been online and if you
think about it all of the things that
we've spelled out earlier about common
mental narrative this left brain system
Allah Allen Shore or autonomic bonding
or synchronization of heartbeats
according to Common stories all that is
happening in online social interactions
when a thousand of us look at the exact
same Instagram post yes we will have a
thousand independent responses to that
but chances are many of us have a
similar or same response based on the
data that we talked about earlier in
synchronization of heartbeats and so we
are socially bonded with other people
through social media and it's very
apparent that the oxytocin system is
playing some role in that and this if we
zoom out makes perfect sense because
again
dopamine serotonin prolactin oxytocin
none of these systems were placed in us
or are organized within us in order to
encourage specific and only specific
types of social interactions the one
that we can say is absolutely critical
is the child parent interaction right
because children simply can't take care
of themselves they need a caretaker I
should have said caretaker not parent
but infants if they don't if they're not
taken care of will die but beyond that
we have evolved or come to realize many
different types of social interactions
and online interactions nowadays are
very very common I'm certainly involved
in them I'm guessing you're involved in
them as well we're involved in one right
now for example
the oxytocin system is absolutely
threaded through and largely responsible
for those types of social bonds as well
violent aggression is entirely
appropriate at a professional boxing
match provided it's occurring inside the
ring and only between the competitors
and within the bounds of the rules of
the sport
Etc
however there are some things that tend
to bias certain social contexts toward
being more aggressive or less aggressive
and not always physical aggression and
those generally come in two forms that
many of you are familiar with which are
alcohol and caffeine
let's discuss caffeine first why would
caffeine increase aggressive impulsivity
well the general effects of caffeine are
to increase autonomic arousal the
activity of the so-called sympathetic
arm of the autonomic nervous system
which is
to put it very much in plain language
it's the alertness arm of your nervous
system that is it creates a sense of
Readiness in your brain and body and it
does so by activating the so-called
sympathetic chain ganglia again as I
always remind people simpa and
sympathetic does not mean sympathy means
together or all at once and
caffeine tends to bias our brain and
body to activate the sympathetic chain
ganglia which run from about the base of
your neck until the top of your pelvis
and deploy a bunch of chemicals that jut
out into the rest of your body activate
adrenaline release there's a parallel
increase in of adrenaline in your brain
creating the state of alertness and
Readiness that state of alertness and
Readiness can be for all sorts of things
not just aggression however when we are
in a state of increased sympathetic tone
meaning more alert
such as after drinking caffeine we will
bias all those brain and body systems
the hormones the chemicals Etc that
exist toward action as opposed to
inaction so put simply caffeine can
increase impulsivity no surprise there
on the opposite end of things alcohol
tends to decrease
activity in the sympathetic arm of the
autonomic nervous system tends to make
us feel less alert now initially it can
create a state of alertness because of
its effects in inhibiting the forebrain
our forebrain prefrontal cortex in
particular has what's called top-down
inhibition it exerts a inhibitory or a
quieting effect on some of the circuits
of the hypothalamus such as the ventral
medial hypothalamus the way to
conceptualize this is that your
forebrain is able to rationalize and
think clearly and to suppress behavior
and to engage the no-go Pathways telling
you don't say that mean thing don't do
that violent thing Etc alcohol initially
tends to increase our level of overall
activity by reducing inhibition not just
in that forebrain circuit but in other
circuits tends to make us more active we
tend to talk more than we normally would
move more than we normally would but
very shortly thereafter starts acting as
a sedative by way of reducing activity
in the forebrain
releasing some of the deeper brain
circuits that are involved in
impulsivity but also causing a somewhat
set of effect and then of course as
alcohol levels increase even further
people eventually will pass out blackout
Etc
so what we've got with alcohol and
caffeine is we've got two opposite ends
of the spectrum caffeine increasing
arousal and Readiness and the tendency
for impulsivity and alcohol also
increasing
impulsivity but through a different
mechanism
previously I told you that it's great to
foreshadow failure that that's a great
way to get your system into a state of
activation I also told you that you want
to set goals that are challenging but
possible and again here I'm paraphrasing
from the work of Emily balcedis I want
to be very clear
there are a few other things that one
can do in order to bias the likelihood
that you will succeed in trying to
achieve your goals first of all
limit your options
trying to pursue too many goals at once
can definitely be counterproductive now
I realize that life is complicated
we all have multiple goals that we're
trying to pursue but if we have
particular goals that are important to
us we have to be careful to not get
distracted by other goals and many
people run into this problem so setting
one or two or maybe three major goals
for a given year is going to be more
than enough for most people and is
actually going to be challenging for
most people now of course we have daily
goals and monthly goals and yearly goals
but if we have big lofty goals we need
to be careful not to contaminate our
mental space and our visual space with
too many goals and why do I say visual
goals well
what various department stores and
supermarkets have discovered is that the
greater the number of things in our
visual attention the more that we can
draw our attention and our goals off a
line of pursuit what does that mean well
let's think about in the Practical
context this has actually been done big
department stores have figured out that
if they stock their shelves
chock-a-block with many many options of
food or clothing items or object or
anything like that people simply buy
more stuff people are very prone to
orienting their attention to whatever is
in front of them you put a lot of stuff
in front of them their attention drifts
you'd put fewer things in front of them
their attention is more narrow
in a later episode we'll talk about
designing a workspace that's optimized
on the basis of this it doesn't mean
being in a room with nothing except just
your desk and a computer doesn't have to
be that sparse but visual sparseness
actually can help us Orient our focus
and our behavior when we have a lot of
things in our visual environment or a
lot of things in our cognitive
environment it's the same thing and so
if you're going to try and pursue a
fitness goal a relationship goal an
academic goal and a long-term Life
Financial goal all at once that's four
things and you're going to have to come
up with systems that allow you to
isolate those goals in a very rigid way
if you want to learn and change your
brain as an adult there has to be a high
level of focus and engagement
there's absolutely no way around this
because so focus and intensity and that
kind of the the Goggins phenotype right
I think Gaga's is now a noun a verb and
a pronoun right it's like it's amazing
so if you're going to goggens this
process we need to do is you need to
regardless of how agitated you feel you
have to lean in and focus extremely hard
now the reason for that is that there's
a neurochemical norepinephrine also
called adrenaline same thing that's
released in the brain and body most
people back off at that point because
they feel this agitation but we have to
remember that that neuroadrenaline was
designed to get us into movement that's
the purpose of noradrenaline to take us
out of Stillness and into movement and
then the other thing we have to do is we
have to take that elevated level of
alertness and we have to focus it and
there's a second neuromodulator called
acetylcholine which is secreted from
this little structure in the base of the
forebrain when we visually focus on
something or in the case of maybe if
you're doing auditory learning when you
focus with your auditory attention
neuroplasticity is triggered when
urgency and focus combine
acetylcholine is released for the
aficionados out there it's called the
nucleus basalus but that doesn't matter
there's a little compartment of neurons
in the base of your forebrain that
doesn't like to release acetylcholine on
a regular basis it's a it's greedy it's
greedy and it doesn't want to use that
with your child it'll brain your brain
with acetylcholine but as an adult 30 40
updates because the you know Mother
Nature designed us to learn what we need
to learn and then do that reproduce and
die I mean not to be you know how rude
dark about it but I always say evolution
is not about us it's about The Offspring
yes like 100 you know it's and then it's
not even about them it's about their
offspring exactly never ends we are
being manipulated From the Inside Yes I
mean that's what it you know it kind of
Drew Me In neurobiology is that all
these complex things you see in the
world it's all internal
so
you know if you get urgency it can come
from let's use David as a he's a shining
example of this right you can sit there
and just ramp up your level of urgency
through purely psychological means you
could take an ice bath you could do high
intensity breathing anything that brings
your level of alertness up I believe
that you know tattoos are I mean this
has come as no surprise or a literal
expression of what we feel on the inside
and you know I and I'm not recommending
this kids don't do this I started
getting tattooed really young about 14 I
got my first tattoo no way we did them
ourselves within your first one please
don't know please no one do this India
ink and a needle and um we used to do
these as really bad they're called
knickknack tattoos or we kind of would
do this at home don't do it it's really
bad you get bad infections they're ugly
they they
blur they bleed that it's not good
um yeah I started getting tattooed I
when I was a kid and growing up
skateboarding in the punk rock scene
there were these guys that um the town
where I lived they call themselves The
Yahtzee guys I don't know why I don't
know what that was about but they all
had full sleeves and they were super
nice guys and they were all into
skateboarding and you know and vehicles
and I just looked up to these guys I
thought like someday I want full sleeves
I
yeah I've got full sleeves I'm basically
like neck to neck to wrist sort of chest
pieces yeah but yeah uh backs covered
yeah nothing on my legs nothing on my
stomach ribs yeah yeah the tops of my
tops of my shoulders and um I got a big
picture of Costello my dog back there
I've got a picture of his paw back there
I've got a picture of another dog he
used to have
um there's still some space for a few
things there's some things very personal
to me
um is that the reason that you prefer
not to show them yeah you know I think
that there are a couple reasons I'll
just be clear as to why first of all
um when I show up to podcast it's the
same way I show up to lecture in the um
classroom Auditorium and I
I swear in my life this is my mindset
and this is my Mantra when I do it I'm
there to teach it's not about me it's
about the student it's about the people
learning
I don't want it ever to be about me I
don't want the focus to be on me I mean
obviously I'm the voice and the person
talking but I really want people to
internalize the information and I do
think that the tattoos because they have
nothing to do with the information or a
distraction they're just a distraction I
I don't know it would sort of like be
wearing like a bright yellow shirt or
something it's not my style I prefer to
kind of make myself disappear as much as
I can and let the information come
forward that's you know even when I gave
scientific lectures which I still do of
course for my my professor job
I generally liked the room to be pretty
dark and I wanted the light to be on the
data on the slides I was happy to do the
voice but I want people thinking about
the data so podcasting is a little
different you come through as a voice
not we're on YouTube a voice in an image
but I really prefer that it not be about
me now there's a human element too and I
think things have changed a lot when I
was growing up tattoos were not accepted
there are many work environments where
if you have for instance where people
prefer that their surgeon or their
doctor not have tattoos some people
might prefer their surgeon or doctor
have tattoos when I was growing up if
you had a uh I never had one but if
someone had a nose ring they had to
cover it up with a Band-Aid or take it
out if they worked at the coffee shop
remember that you probably don't you're
probably young enough no or eyebrow ring
think Trends have changed right things
have changed and I'm kind of old school
because I'm kind of old Now 46 and the
etiquette for me has always been to you
know and this is Lex does this too is I
I personally find that if I can just
show up as formal and consistent as
possible that people at least know that
I'm taking them seriously so I don't
really do it for me I pretty much do it
for the audience
um and also none of the tattoos are like
that interesting it's my dog I really
like Raptors I've got a bunch of birds
I've got I mean I have all sorts of
different things like Raptors like the
dinosaur no Raptors like um red tail
hawks and blue you know I like birds I
had either dinosaurs or trucks yeah like
yo you really need to love Ford Raptors
no no Ford Raptor I drive a Toyota
4Runner and I love it I've got one truck
and I love that thing
um although with gas right now I mean
it's you kind of got to wonder about
having a gas driven vehicle like a
forerunner in any case yeah the tattoo
thing I would say for for younger people
coming up just be aware that you can't
control other people's perceptions
either and so you know I always made it
a point that I didn't want things on my
knuckles I didn't want them on my hands
I didn't want them on my neck I didn't
want them on my face do I judge people
when they have them no but do I want
them for me no I also think that this is
very neurosciency
as a neuroscience is that we have
dedicated brain areas called fusiform
gyrus it's a face area that's dedicated
to the processing of faces even if I
just put two dots and a line in between
them on a piece of paper you see that as
a face
when one puts a tattoo on their throat
or on their face it actually changes the
way that the face is perceived right I
mean it almost looks like another mouth
there right it's a very different look
it can be a little bit jarring I'm not
saying one shouldn't have it but it can
be a little bit jarring it's it changes
the look of the person forever it's not
just that it's above the neckline it's
that it kind of competes with the
processing of their face in its normal
way and so for me whenever I see
somebody with a throat tattoo or a face
tattoo sort of like it's hard to kind of
Orient around that and I think there's
some biology to uh to that relates to
that but look when it comes down to it I
mean people need to be individuals and
live their life the way they want to
live their life I've also never been
that much of an iconoclast I'm not you
know I'm I grew up in the punk rock
thing
um you know I hate in group out group
stuff I always had friends from a lot of
different you know friends or jocks and
hippies and punk rockers and you know
straight and gay and like I don't care
as long as people are living their best
life and they're not harming anybody
like I'm like great go for it I I'm very
laid back in that way of course if
people are harming other people then I
believe that like Liberty and
independent freedom I mean Liberty is
you know one of the highest things that
you know for me so
but I don't tend to I don't consider
myself a very judgmental person but you
can't always control the perceptions of
others so I would just think people
should be thoughtful about what they
want to accomplish in life in terms of a
life mission and just ask whether or not
some of the permanent cosmetic changes
they might make might might align with
compete with or be neutral for those
life missions my life mission is very
simple I want to teach people the Beauty
and the utility of biology I'm going to
do that today I'm going to do that until
I take my last breath in one form or
another because that's what excites me
and that's like what keeps the dopamine
cranking I like the idea of
authenticity without over sharing right
you're very authentic but there are
aspects to your life that I'm aware of
that your audiences will never be aware
of and their aspects of your life that
I'll never be aware of and so you're
still authentic but yeah which way which
ones are you aware of people are going
to wonder like what what is you think
I'm a Triplex dungeon what is this no no
no but interesting but interesting
choice of examples
um
no but I think that um
you know people lose lose careers on the
basis of the movement of their thumbs
right I mean the chair of Psychiatry at
Columbia recently lost his position
based on a response to a tweet people
can look that up this is one of the most
famous Psychiatry departments in the
world and he put something out there
that was very insensitive at frankly and
um everyone that I talked to about it
was like gosh that was very very
insensitive not thoughtful at all and
and he lost his job right or at least
had to step down I don't know the
specifics so
um
you know
I I think I read someplace that more
than half of the uh job loss due to
online behavior is because people were
trying to be funny
to what extent does our subjective
narrative the story the story We Tell
ourselves actually means something for
the body and to what extent does the
body actually mean something for the
subjective narrative so this gets into
some areas of work that we're doing now
and so I do want to highlight that it's
ongoing work but I think you know the
old narrative meaning a few 10 years ago
was that if you're feeling depressed
just smile well if that worked right we
would have a lot less depression than we
see out right the reason I call it a
brain body contract early on is that
their the brain and the body are
constantly in dialogue so you know the
idea that when we're depressed we tend
to be in more defensive type postures
when we're feeling good we tend to be in
more like relaxed and extended postures
all true
but it does not mean that just by
occupying the extended posture that I'm
going to completely shift the mind right
that's a first step think about like two
interlocking gears it's one gear that
turns the other but then they need to
kind of dance together before you can
get the whole system going and so you
get it to dance together exactly so
subjective there is one way in which
subjective thought and deliberate
thought is very powerful Over States of
mind and body to answer your question
can you think your way out of the ice
bath being cold so a couple things that
are important first of all just to go a
little deeper on what thoughts are
thoughts happen spontaneously all the
time they're popping up like a poorly
filtered internet connection
but thoughts can also be deliberately
introduced for instance right now
I can say okay have a thought that just
decide to write your name and your you
can do that I'm going to decide to write
my name and you can do it so that's a
deliberate thought which says that you
can introduce thoughts so I think it's
very hard to control negative thoughts
directly by trying to suppress them
generally they tend to just want to
continue to geyser up all the time but
we can introduce a positive thought an
ability to control your levels of stress
in real time is extremely powerful
it turns out you can do this using
physiology and Neuroscience
your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate and your level of stress or
calm here's how it works
when you inhale your diaphragm moves
down this creates more space in your
thoracic cavity and your heart actually
gets a little bit bigger as a
consequence the rate of blood flow
through that larger heart volume slows
down a signal is sent from a group of
neurons on your heart called the
sinoatrial node that signal goes up to
the brain and your brain sends a signal
to speed the heart up in other words
inhaling
speeds your heart rate up
the opposite is true as well when you
exhale your diaphragm moves up your
heart gets a little bit smaller because
there's a little bit less space in your
thoracic cavity as a consequence blood
flows more quickly through that smaller
volume the sinoatrial node registers
that and sends a signal to your brain
and the Brain sends a signal to slow the
heart down so in other words inhaling
speeds your heart rate up exhaling slows
your heart rate down so if you want to
speed up your heart rate and be more
alert
inhale more or make those inhales more
vigorous more intense if you want to
calm down you can do that quickly by
making your exhale slightly longer than
your inhales or making them more
vigorous this doesn't require any breath
work this is something that you can do
in real time and that's what's called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia that's the
technical phrase It's also the basis of
what's called heart rate variability or
HRV but all you need to remember is
inhaling deeper and longer will speed
your heart rate up exhaling longer and
more intensely will slow your heart rate
down and will allow you to calm down in
real time the reason I encourage people
to get sunlight in their eyes especially
early in the day is that it helps wake
you up it improves your mood improves
hormone output it improves Focus it's
good for so many aspects and it helps
you hurting and it helps you sleep at
night okay so what you want to do people
have different levels of sensitivity you
want to look in the general direction of
the sun okay if it's low in the sky it's
no problem you could literally look at
it like this now the higher It Gets In
The Sky the more imposing it is and
you'll want to close your eyes if it if
it forces you to Blink you need to look
away from it a little bit indirect light
is fine on a real really clear day yeah
um if it's
if it's very very bright and you need to
blink blink I'd say take your sunglasses
off for doing this Eyeglasses and
Contacts are fine and after you know two
three minutes you're good and if you're
walking to work in the morning it's nice
sunny morning but the sun is New York so
a lot of the sun's blocked by these big
buildings you just get the indirect
sunlight and that's okay that's okay but
through a window these tinted windows
that are everywhere here or through
windshields not going to happen it's
just never going to set this this
mechanism in the ways you need so if you
you know watching a sunset you can
literally watch it yeah Isla Vista we
used to watch sunsets right we're going
to disappear off Del Playa with the oil
rigs out there and every people don't
know these oil platforms that sit off
the beach in Santa Barbara and they it
seeps up all this tar
um but it's very beautiful sunsets out
there and you can look directly at it
when the sun is low in the sky
um when the sun is overhead is when it
tends to be really bright don't stare at
it so what is the advantage of this it
just wakes you up so you have neurons
nerve cells in your eye that connect
that when that sunlight hits them they
send a signal to your brain that's a
wake-up signal gosh improves your mood
increases testosterone it increases
metabolism it lets you focus better and
it sets a timer so that you can fall
asleep fall asleep at night about 12 to
16 hours later if you're not getting
light in your eyes and if you wake up
and you're just on your phone
that's fine if the sun isn't out but if
you're on your phone for the first two
hours a day and then you get outside and
get sunlight and the sun's already
overhead
and you go out with your sunglasses on
that kind of thing you're you're going
to find it's very hard to fall asleep
that night because you're not setting
the timer that's right think of the
morning the morning bright light is your
wake-up signal got you get as much
sunlight in your eyes as you safely can
throughout the day I wear sunglasses but
not when I do this morning sunlight
viewing and then in the evening try and
catch some sun before it goes down in
the winter obviously that's going to
happen earlier and then at night you
really want to try and dim the lights
it'd be I always say like like the
fighters at the fight last night like
we're wearing sunglasses yeah you know
dim the lights dim the dim the screens
um between 10 pm and 4 a.m now look you
guys were at the fight last night I
happen to be there too I'm sort of a new
UFC fan so I'm not very educated on this
but it was really bright it's not big
deal every once in a while to get stay
up late I was up till 1 30 which for me
is very late but you know I would say 80
of the days and nights of your life get
some sunlight in your eyes and try and
dim the lights at night but you're in
New York yeah Bright Lights big city
right so you're gonna have to do a
little bit more sunlight viewing in the
early part of the day if you wake up and
the sun isn't out yet you know once it's
out get out there okay yeah it has huge
outside positive effects
like a lot of guys are or and women say
oh you know I don't feel well I'm having
trouble focusing I'm having trouble
sleeping before we could get into any
discussion about supplements or hormone
therapy or ice baths and saunas all that
stuff is great but the number one thing
for health is going to be quality sleep
and the best way to get quality sleep is
get sunlight in your eyes early in the
day and on cloudy days when you can't
see the sun people always say there's no
sun here I'm like the sun is still there
yeah it's just and you get a lot of sun
through that those clouds just get
outside a little bit longer I forget who
said it was it like St Augustine or
something said that like a good life
requires like a constant reordering of
our loves or something like that I'm
terrible at quotes but constantly
updating what it is that we that we are
in love with for that moment and then
shifting to the next thing yeah of
course that serotonin system is vital
you know if if we cannot enjoy the
things that we already have and that
require no Pursuit if we can't take
ourselves into those moments of just
really appreciating what we have and and
not just gratitude but really savoring
the experience of what we're in we will
never be able to go back to the gold
Pursuit mode as a as well or as
efficiently so it really is like the
seesawing back and forth between loving
a good night's sleep
but also loving being the person who
bounces out of bed in the morning with a
goal right
um loving like being for me you know
like just being to a total sloth all day
one day a week I mean I turn into it
like I literally think about the animal
the sloth I even have a sloth on it that
day it's ridiculous well just I
literally take a full day of each week
and try and just enjoy being in the
microscope of like just hanging around
and doing that I don't always achieve
that because of Life constraints but
then also on Monday morning or Sunday if
it were whatever your schedule is really
putting you know the goal in the
crosshairs and getting that dopamine
system ramped up again why do we have
fears why do we have trauma why do we
have shame and here's the Stinger it was
all set up for you in your youth I don't
want to focus on the bad but most of the
stuff when you're young you're just a
passive learning machine it's all coming
in little kids are learning three
languages with no accents flexibly
they're not even thinking about they're
learning instruments you know someone
asked a great question the other day at
the workshop wait now I know I want all
that stuff how come it's so much tougher
there's a lot of biology I'd be happy to
tell you about that explains why that
all shuts down after these so-called
critical periods during development so
what happens when you're an adult and
you want to change your brain so now I'm
going to get into stuff that's that
hopefully is useful to you okay so these
basic facts that changing your brain in
a real way as an adult requires that you
do particular things that activate
particular chemical systems in your
brain so how do you do that right I
could tell you all about the chemicals
and I'll tell you a little bit about
them but how do you do it okay so this
is a right here right now urgent
situation car wreck it's terrible you
can imagine any other trauma in its
place when that happens a little area in
the base of the brain the name isn't
important but if you care it's called
nucleus basalus does its job which is
just it's an alert system it puts all
its attention on right here right now
get everybody safe it's your alert
system and it has this effect of dumping
out a certain chemical called
acetylcholine at specific locations in
the brain that are paired with that
experience and forever that experience
will be traumatic unless something else
is done
okay so there's some nuance and some
details to this but that pretty much
summarizes it it's been replicated many
many times in dozens of studies you can
pair pretty much any experience with
stimulation of nucleus basalus this
thing in the in the base of the brain
and that experience will be mapped or
remapped in your brain as an adult and
that's remarkable it's also exciting
because then I someone like me says well
then how do I change my experience how
do I change the meaning of what happens
how do I change something from traumatic
to positive the good news is nucleus
basalus is just a slave to whatever is
exciting traumatic it likes emotion it
like it likes Peaks and lows and so if
acetylcholine is released that means you
can massively change your brain at that
moment with whatever's paired with it
and so when you get into a peak State
here and you're jumping up and down or
in a really low State and you're
thinking how miserable something is you
have to be really careful because those
are the things that you're wiring in all
right so you can move to a state like
this about driving later if you form
enough associations with driving to
really eliminate to over provide the
fear you need to create a positive
experience in its place
so how do you do that so I'm going to
tell you that the way I do that is not
to think too hard and to not verbalize
things too much and this is coming from
someone who spent 25 years three times a
week on a couch letting subconscious
things geyser up and that's where I
really learned that it was really the
things that you don't realize that have
the potential to have the most impact
but this power of emotion the ability to
couple really strong emotions with
things is so useful if you want to
change your brain for the better and the
way you do that
is clear in the physical space we all
know this story there are many news
cases like this woman's child stuck
under car super human strength we heard
a lot of amazing stories about
desperation JJ's story was one of
desperation she's like no I'm not going
to accept failure because failure in the
case in the case she was describing was
potentially the death of her child so
desperation is a strong one and it's
motivated motivated by fear but what if
you're not in a desperate State and you
really want to do something in that case
there's something remarkable and then we
should and we should ask ourselves why
are children such great passive Learners
they're not trying they're just learning
they're coming home with all sorts of
things sometimes things you don't want
them to come home with right it's
because they have this element of play
and what is play play isn't just
movement although it includes movement
it's giving things everything you've got
but keeping it in perspective it's that
sweet spot of enjoying life and trying
really really hard at it at the same
time it's essentially what we all strive
for and there are these incredible cases
throughout history famous scientists
because I grew up in a house where
people you know revered scientists like
like Richard Feynman Nobel Prize winner
he's most famous for Bongo drumming
naked on the roof of Caltech and he
became an amazing artist in his 60s and
he developed all sorts of other skills
and he always had this childlike way of
looking at the world he never let
himself get stuck in his ways never
became a curmudgeon and a remarkable man
and that's something that I if you come
away with nothing else I encourage you
to do that you want your brain to change
stay light stay loose but give it
everything you've got can a person make
it so they never
get depressed they never react to
um
their perception their people's actions
towards them where they never get to a
state of uh I don't feel good I'm
feeling more depressed I'm in a dark
place now I'm stuck in this place is
there a way that we could ever defend
ourselves against negative stressors
negative emotions or are we just are
they do we need them as well to have
contrast in life well there's sort of
two views on this I'll reveal mine after
I um sort of explain the two views one
is that these states I guess I'm
automatically calling things like
depression a state of mind and a body so
when I say a state of mind I mean brain
and body because your body is really
feeling it's like the brain is connected
to the body right and so if you're
saying internally the thought of like
I'm depressed I don't feel good or I'm
sad or I'm lonely or I'm not good enough
the body's gonna react is that what I'm
understanding absolutely the body's
going to manifest what the Mind Is
Telling You absolutely the thought the
idea you're gonna be like I'm sad I'm
not good enough you're gonna shrink
right is that right that's right I mean
they're really two forms of depression
um sometimes they're intermixed but one
is anxiety Associated depression and you
you if you've ever experienced it or for
anyone that's experienced it they feel
agitation in their body
and their mind races but in their body
so the body is recruited
there are also depressive states that
people feel very fatigued and exhausted
it's been overwhelm and they also
experience that in their body the the
idea of getting out of bed in the
morning is hard um motivating to
exercise doing the sorts of things that
we know
are powerful for pushing back on
depression so the body is recruited I
think most people would say that
depressive states are bad when they
bring down the Baseline on life I just
as a brief aside anytime there's a
question about mental health or
addiction or trauma or anything one
could look at it and make up some
argument of low evolutionarily this
makes sense we all get depressed or but
we have to be fair to the person
experiencing it of course and have
sensitivity that some behaviors will
keep the Baseline of our life steady
meaning job relationships Etc will
continue as they are other activities
will tend to improve the Baseline on our
life job activities relationship Etc
will will improve and then there's some
things like heroin which does very
quickly we can predict that very quickly
the Baseline on life is going to creep
down regardless of who that person is
right so people say can you get addicted
to water well maybe but I have to train
drink a lot of water before the Baseline
of My Life Starts to go down so it just
feels uncomfortable that's just like man
I'm so bloated exactly right so we tend
to throw around things like addiction
and depression a little Loosely so yeah
I think that it's fair to say that
depression is wired into us as a
possible state that we could all fall
into but that it's very important in my
opinion that humans have tools to remove
themselves from that state of course to
avoid you know tragedies like suicide
but also because when the Baseline on
someone's life goes down far enough they
find it increasingly hard to do the
sorts of things that didn't get them out
of depression so you or I could say so
they stay in that state of depression
because it's too hard to go work it's
too hard to change my habit of eating
healthier so I'm going to stay
I'm going to keep eating ice cream which
is going to make my body you know
depressed that's right right if I can
keep eating bad foods if I keep staying
up till 4am if I keep staying in a toxic
relationship I want to feel depressed
that's right and eventually because of
this very
um Inseparable relationship between the
brain and body eventually what happens
is that because the brain controls the
body but also the body can control the
brain people lose the ability to
intervene in this depressive process so
you or I could say look
if someone who's depressed they what
they need to do is get up early get some
light in their eyes get some movement I
know you put this information out there
which I love because these those tips
are grounded in oh they're not even tips
they're really tools and they're very
powerful because they're grounded in
excellent science you get that dopamine
release early in the day that's
anti-depressive you time your sleep
better when you get sun in your eyes and
you get movement early in the day for
most people that's accessible and they
should be they absolutely should be
doing it everyone should be doing that
but for people who are far enough down
that path of depression
because the body and the mind have this
relationship that's so close there is a
crossover point where they really can't
do those activities because they're so
far deep in the depression the body
won't do what they decide to do and so
now I'm not trying to give anyone a pass
because ultimately we are all
responsible for our own mental health
certainly adults more than kids but you
know we're all responsible for our own
mental health and only we can direct our
own brain changes that's the Stinger
once we're you know 25 years and older
we are the only ones that can change our
brain and we can talk about
neuroplasticity if you like but the
depressed person has to take
responsibility for their behavior but
this is why it's so important to catch
this brain body relationship early and
build
routines that keep one out of depression
so that was a long path back to answer
your question succinctly I hope which is
we can stay out of depression but we
have to keep depression at Bay by doing
things regularly for better for worse
there is a tremendous literature on the
biology of social isolation and all of
the terrible things that happen when
animals or humans are socially isolated
at particular phases of life
now for those of you that are introverts
you are not necessarily damaging
Yourself by deciding to spend less time
with other people many people like time
alone I personally am an introvert I get
a thrill out of spending time with one
or two close friends
but I enjoy a lot of time by myself
I like to socialize so I wouldn't call
myself an extreme introvert but I know
there are some extreme introverts out
there but when we talk about social
isolation what we're referring to
is when animals are humans are
restricted from having the social
contacts that they would prefer to have
and to just briefly touch on the major
takeaways from this literature which
spans back 100 years or more
being socially isolated is stressful and
one of the Hallmark features of social
isolation is chronically elevated stress
hormones like adrenaline also called
epinephrine like cortisol a stress
hormone that at healthy levels is good
for combating inflammation helps us have
energy early in the day focused
throughout the day but if cortisol is
elevated for too long which is the
consequence of social isolation the
immune system suffers and other
chemicals start to be released in the
brain and body that are designed to
motivate the organism animal or human to
seek out social bonds
an example of one such chemical is a
peptide called tachykinen tachykinen is
present in flies in mice and in humans
and under conditions of social isolation
its levels go up and because of the
brain areas that contain receptors for
tachykinen people start feeling very
aggressive and irritable after social
isolation now that should be a little
bit counterintuitive to you you would
think oh you know if you isolate an
animal or human and then you give them
the opportunity for social interaction
they should behave very well they should
be thrilled they're finally getting the
nourishment the social nourishment that
they've been lacking for so long it
turns out that's not the case chronic
social isolation changes the nature of
the brain and body such that it makes
social connection harder and it makes
the person who's been isolated irritable
even aggressive with other people
now I don't want to go too deeply into
the biology of social isolation because
it doesn't actually afford US that much
insight into what healthy social bonding
looks like so today we're going to focus
more on the functional biology uh dual
meaning of the word functional as
opposed to the Pathology of social
isolation
however I do want to point out that
social isolation starts to deteriorate
certain aspects of brain and body pretty
quickly but how quickly depends again on
how introverted or extroverted somebody
is so if you're somebody who's socially
isolated for the holidays or has been
socially isolated for a period of time
and is craving social contact that is a
healthy craving and as we'll learn next
the healthy craving for social contact
has a very specific brain circuit has a
very specific neurochemical signature
associated with it and has some
remarkable features that you can
leverage in Social contacts of all kinds
I think some of the more important and
exciting work on social bonding comes
from the laboratory of K Thai K is a
professor at the Salk Institute for
biological studies she's an investigator
with the Howard Hughes Medical Institute
and in recent years I would say in about
the last five or six years her
laboratory has made a fundamental
discovery
as to why we seek out and put so much
effort into social bonds and the key
discovery that she made is that much
like hunger much like temperature much
like thirst we have brain circuits that
are devoted to what's called a social
homeostasis
many of you have probably heard about
homeostasis before homeostasis is the
characteristic of various biological
circuits and even individual cells to
try and maintain a certain level it's
most easily thought of in the context of
hunger if you don't eat for a while your
drive to pursue food and think about
food and make food and spend money on
food and indeed to enjoy food goes up
whereas when you're well fed you don't
tend to seek out food with as much Vigor
or as much intensity you wouldn't invest
as much time effort money Etc so
homeostasis is the aspect of cells
tissues and organisms to seek some sort
of balance to regulate themselves
in a crude way you can think about the
thermostat on your home as a homeostatic
circuit when the temperature goes up a
little bit it cools things down to
maintain a certain temperature when the
room gets cold it hits a certain level
and a sensor detects that it clicks on
and then the heat goes on to maintain a
certain set temperature so that's a
simple way of thinking about homeostasis
every homeostatic circuit has three
components or at least three one is a
detector meaning the organism or the
thermostat on your wall has to have some
way of detecting what's going on in the
environment all right in the context of
social bonding whether or not you are
interacting with others and whether or
not those interactions are going well so
that has to be detected that's the first
thing then there has to be a control
center that's the second thing and the
control center is the one that makes the
adjustments to in the case of social
bonding to your behavior and to your
psychology so you'll soon learn that
there are ways in which the more time
that you spend alone the more motivated
you are to seek out the pictures of
faces the interactions with actual
people physical contact and so forth now
that might seem obvious to you but
thanks to the work of ketai and others
it's remarkable to learn that there are
specific brain centers that are
adjusting our psychology and biology so
that we seek out bonds more aggressively
or maybe we don't because we are
perfectly sated or satiated with respect
to how much contact we've had with other
people
now the third component of this
homeostatic circuit is the effector the
effector is actually what drives the
behavioral response is what it's what
leads you to pick up your social media
and start scrolling it's what leads you
to text a friend it's what leads you to
call a friend or make plans and what
leads you to follow through on those
plans so again those three components
are a detector a Control Center and an
effector and as you'll soon learn the
neural circuit that controls this social
homeostasis actually as a fourth
component and that fourth component is
one that places subjective understanding
as to why you are doing what you are
doing and
establishes your place in a hierarchy
now in other words hierarchy can be a
little bit of a of a barbed wire one
because people immediately start
thinking about boss and subordinate or
in couples a leader and a follower but
when we talk about social hierarchies
in the context of human interactions
social hierarchies are very plastic
meaning in one setting one person can be
the leader in another setting the other
person can be the leader you probably
have groups of friends or family members
where you're constantly passing the the
Baton as to who's going to drive who's
going to navigate who's going to pick
the restaurant who's going to clear the
dishes and who's going to do certain
activities and not others so hierarchies
are very Dynamic and as a consequence
social bonding has to be very plastic
and very fluid so that you move from one
environment to the next even with the
same people you have to be able to make
those adjustments and in the case of the
social homeostasis circuit those
adjustments are made by a particular
brain structure I've talked about on
this podcast before it's called the
prefrontal cortex it is the seat of our
higher Consciousness if you will it's
what allows us to place subjective
labels on things so we are not strictly
input output we're not robotic meaning
if you go to dinner with a friend and
they are exceptional at choosing
restaurants well in the context of the
social homeostasis circuit your
prefrontal cortex would allow them to
pick the restaurant because basically
they are dominant over you in their
capacity to pick good restaurants at
least in this example whereas as you
leave that restaurant and perhaps you
are navigating to uh where to get a
drink after dinner or where to walk
through the city perhaps you have the
better sense of direction and so then
the social bonding has to be maintained
as you switch the hierarchy okay so
that's the role of that fourth element
the prefrontal cortex there are three
ways you can do sauna that I can just
toss out as like brief things if you
want to get a really big growth hormone
release for sake of metabolism fat loss
you're training really really hard in
Jiu Jitsu and you want to recover you
don't want to sauna too often because
the study that um identified this
massive 16-fold increase in growth
hormone they had people do this it's
crazy they got into okay temperatures
are 80 to 100 degrees Centigrade so
that's 176 degrees Fahrenheit to 212
degrees Fahrenheit for 5 to 30 minutes
is the typical ranges that people work
in in these research studies
for maximum growth hormone hormone
release don't do sauna more than once a
week but get into the sauna for 30
minutes
as hot as you can safely tolerate so
probably for you that'll be 210 because
you're I suspect you'll be on the high
end of things
then get out for five to ten minutes
no cold exposure get back in the sauna
for 30 minutes then they had them do it
again out for five minutes back for 30
minutes out for five minutes back for
three minutes they had them do two hours
of sauna exposure to get that growth
hormone release now for the reduction in
likelihood of dying of a cardiovascular
event stroke or otherwise the more often
you do sauna the better so if you look
at all calls all cause mortality or
death due to cardiovascular events and
you look at sauna use frequencies using
the same parameters 80 to 100 degrees
Centigrade
one to seven times per week basically
the more often you get into the sauna
for 30 minutes
across the week so 30 minutes a day is
better than four times a week four times
a week is better than two times a week
and two times a week is better than one
and the reductions in mortality are
really impressive 27 if you get into the
sauna the way I just described not the
two hours a day but 30 minutes
twice a week or three times per week you
reduce the likelihood of dying of a
cardiovascular event by 27 percent
if you do it four or more times per week
you reduce the probability of Dying by
50 of a cardiovascular event and in
these studies they rule out other things
that people are doing smoking they even
ask them do you live in an apartment are
you in a happy relationship like they
evaluate other potentially confounding
variables now for people that don't have
access to a sauna a hot water bath or
hot tub is going to be your next best
bet and if you don't have access to that
do like the wrestlers do which is you
know put on two sets of uh sweats and a
hoodie and a stocking cap and wrap
yourself in Plastics underneath all that
and go for a run but don't please nobody
die of hypothermia I mean you can die of
warming up too much is this experience
um Pleasant or stressful in the way so
is it as stressful as a nice bathroom
okay great question people always ask
how cold to make the ice bath or the
cold water or the shower you want it to
be uncomfortably cold meaning you want
to feel like I really want to get out
but you can safely stay in and that's
going to vary by person and experience
with experience yeah with the sauna it's
the same thing
how hot to make it well don't kill
yourself obviously be smart if you're
pregnant you shouldn't be doing this
anyway
um but it's very clear that what you
need is the release of something called
dinorphin we have endorphin which makes
us feel good it binds to these mu opioid
receptors in the body you have dinorfin
which is the terrible feeling that you
get when you're in really hot
temperatures it's also the terrible
effect that alcoholics feel when they
are in withdrawal you feel agitated you
want to get out it's really unpleasant
it's dinorphin binding to the so-called
Kappa opioid receptor is that's what
you're trying to trigger when you do
that a number of things happen you set
off heat shock proteins that go repair
broken proteins and misfolded proteins
it also makes it so that later endorphin
binds its receptor more strongly so when
you have this uncomfortable experience
in the heat
you literally feel better in real life
when pleasurable events come on
when you experience them in the same way
I like to say this that when you get
into a cold ice bath or cold shower the
increase in
epinephrine and dopamine is two to three
hundred percent these are huge increases
and they last many hours this is shown
because lately I've been getting a
little bit of pushback on Twitter that
which is you know interesting place
um people say well that's just in mice
no all the studies I just referred to
are all done in humans men and women
fairly broad age ranges so you want to
be uncomfortable in the cold you want to
be uncomfortable in the Heat this is why
I'm not a big fan of infrared saunas
because they only go up to about 160 170
degrees
infrared light and far red light of all
kinds has been shown to be beneficial
for wound healing acne skin eyes there
are even guys now putting on their
testicles because it can increase
testosterone and sperm production yeah
hormone release hormone release but in
terms of the sauna you want that strong
heat stimulus yeah and that's when you
get crawl up to the 200 Mark and so on
whenever I'm in New York and there's
also one in San Francisco although the
one in San Francisco is is clothing
optional just to warn people there's a
place called Archimedes Banya is there
any scientific evidence that being naked
is beneficial in the sauna well in
certain contexts it leads to childbirth
okay but
um I suppose it's not required right for
childbirth but
um but in all seriousness you know in
New York I'll go to a place called Spa
88 and actually uh khabib's picture is
on the wall he goes there and it's a it
there that one it's clothing it they
require clothing I always just say that
because it can be a little bit of a
shock to people sometimes if they kind
of walk in their a bunch of naked people
that went in San Francisco I if I go I'm
clothed mostly because you know I run
into co-workers or things like that you
know I I sort of more uh old-fashioned
in that way I suppose but um that you
like to wear clothes they're on
co-workers yes yeah I mean it's just to
me it just seems like you know that just
be aware but but nonetheless the banyas
have very Hots on us because they're
russian-owned and in New York there's
one on the Lower East Side but the spa
88 place they have some saunas that the
moment I get into those I have a hard
time catching a full breath it burns
they've got a cold dunk that's like a
shock and then they've got a sauna wet
sauna steam room that's a little
mellower so the nice thing about a Banya
is you can kind of find your place and
then they do the plaza where they take
the eucalyptus leaves and you can pay
someone and you basically you cover your
groin and then they beat you with the
the the the leaves and it's supposed to
bring the vasculature to the surface
I've only done it once and frankly I
found it um to be a little bit um
unnerving I didn't really like the
experience but I I'll try and get into a
sauna as often as I possibly can which
is you know once or three times per week
and I try and do the cold exposure
shower or immersion but early in the day
because it really wakes you up when
you're chasing something or you're
you're saying you don't have it you're
like needing something you're saying you
don't have it but when you become
comfortable with Where You Are
things start to attract to you and you
have energy and you have energy and
you're like a magnet as opposed to an
opposite magnet resisting these things
that you need and want Pursuit is very
taxing and the reason is there's a
biochemical reason for this is it's like
wandering in the desert not knowing if
there's water at all that's really
depleting I mean epinephrine is in the
brain and it's a it's chemical
equivalent in the body is adrenaline
those are the same thing and if you're
constantly in Pursuit right you're just
pursuing external goals external goals
external goals it will wear your nervous
system down you will be exhausted and
you will one will eventually run aground
you'll become mentally depressed the key
is to figure out what are the rewards
that you can acquire along the way
internally remember it's subjective
there can also be external rewards
because many things have Milestones you
know a series a or series B for a
company then the IPO or later reaching a
million users are doing this yeah that
we have engagements before we have
weddings typically right
um there are those rare instances where
people just go and get married but
typically there's a lot of build up that
is designed you know that fortunately it
you know provides these uh reward
mechanisms so the key thing is that
you can't just be all gas pedal all the
time without rewarding yourself however
the reward that dopamine is so powerful
because it actually as I mentioned
before it actually is the chemical
substrate for epinephrine it creates a
reservoir of more energy and again I'm
not talking about caloric energy or
glycogen mind energy it's it's mental
energy it's the it's the desire to push
on it's a desire to keep going so we
need some consistent dopamine hits
throughout the days or months to give us
more energy to pursue that's right but
we don't want to be over pursued because
then we'll burn out that's right and so
everyone has to find where that sweet
spot is that kind of you know on the
freeway driving where it's really smooth
and seamless where you're not on the
accelerator the whole time where you're
in a gear that's appropriate and you
know we're talking now in terms of sort
of
um you know Neuroscience lens on these
things but the key is always going to be
practices it's going to be just as early
as we're talking about bringing stress
levels up or down depending on you know
alertness levels up or down depending on
the kind of stress you're experiencing
the reward system is great because when
you let's say you're a person that can
very easily access this dopamine reward
so you're always excited you know people
say hey let's do this and your your
mantras let's go and you just kind of go
well we would call in science very low
activation energy you just go
that's great those people do run the
risk of burnout although there are these
people that we occasionally encounter
that just seem to have Boundless Energy
for everything and they tend to get a
lot more done because they have a lot
more internal reward and you'll notice
they're getting rewards from all the
little things and it's a hundred percent
subjective it's like hearing funny jokes
all day long you can just keep going and
certainly the beginning of relationships
when people fall in love you know that's
a real thing but it is associated with
with a big flood of dopamine in the
system makes everything seem exciting
and possible and new and I think that
we also know other people that they have
a very hard time accessing this dopamine
system and they either place it under
the complete control of external things
so they're miserable until they get the
payoff
and then sometimes they're even
miserable again or they really just
don't they haven't learned the skills of
how to access it so how do we trick our
mind to find rewards in subjective
things that aren't actually physically
coming to us okay so um I'll tell a
brief anecdote about an experiment
that's really important this was done
many years ago in a psychology
department
think it was done at Bing Nursery School
at Stanford but I could be wrong about
that so um I don't want to uh state that
as absolute fact but the experiment
nonetheless was done where they looked
at kids in schools these are kids about
Nursery School age or maybe a little bit
older and they looked at what they did
during recess and they they found that
some kids really like to draw
and so these kids would naturally
disorient towards the crayons and pens
and draw and then
for a short while they rewarded the kids
for drawing those same kids they would
give them a gold star or a little
sticker or something that was special
and made them feel special so they were
giving them an external reward then they
removed the reward and what they found
is those kids drew at a much lower
frequency they somehow lost the
intrinsic pleasure of drawing huh
because they were used to getting an
extrinsic suddenly they Associated the
drawing they thought they they weren't
conscious but they their nervous system
said oh I guess I was doing it for the
reward now there's less reward and
without going into a lot of details
there's a very solid scientific
phenomenon called reward prediction
error which says that if you get less
dopamine at the end than you anticipated
it's a letdown if you get more at the
end then it feels great now what this
all translates to is once again learning
how to attach internal rewards to the
process of whatever it is that you want
to do in order to get you to the thing
you really want and so the the short
answer in this actually I was asked this
um recently someone said okay how can I
ensure that once I succeed this was
somebody who was doing very well in
their pursuit of a goal and they were
getting close and they said how can I be
sure that when I get to the win that I
don't lose the ability to keep working
because I really want this page not
satisfied right and I said well there's
two ways one is make sure that that
reward really bask in it really
appreciate what you've done and what's
come to you and but and here's a very
important but is but take that feeling
of being saturated with dopamine the
huge win and attach it to the effort
process that got you there the most
dominant zeitge Gaber as we say time
keeper that governs all these States
including sleep is light there's no
question about it and you ask any
circadian biologist to say there's a
kind of a principle of circadian biology
which is that light is the dominant
zeitgeberg called zeitgeber because the
people who Define this were German and
I'm pronouncing it incorrectly because I
don't speak German
the it's clear that if possible one
should view sunlight or at least get
outside even if it's cloudy outside
within the first hour of waking
and if you wake up before the sun comes
out to flip on as many artificial lights
as possible if your goal is to be awake
if your goal is to go back to sleep
definitely keep the lights dim but
getting sunlight in your eyes even
through cloud cover is going to set in
motion a number of different biological
events read out first through certain
cells in the eyes these so-called
melanops and intrinsically
photosensitive ganglion cells is the
fancy name they were discovered by David
Burson at Brown University and they send
a signal to your hypothalamus which then
sets in motion a huge number of hormonal
and neural events in the body they
create a cortisol pulse that wakes you
up further sets the Baseline for your
attention throughout the day also sets a
timer of about 16 hours not
coincidentally on your first melatonin
pulse which will happen in the evening
so it's timing when your sleep is going
to come people who stay indoors in dark
environments for the early part of the
day just looking at their phone you're
not getting enough light stimulation
the tricky thing is that later in the
evening
about 17 hours after you've been awake
or when you woke up what you'll find is
that even a minimum of light from
screens can shift your circadian clock
and the reason is that there's a gradual
shift in the sensitivity of the retina
to external light so you need a lot of
light ideally sunlight early in the day
and of course you don't want to stare
directly at any light that's so bright
that it's painful you don't have to look
directly into the sun absolutely blank
you can be kind of off-center from the
Sun but try and get out there without
sunglasses if you can people always ask
can I wear eyeglasses or contacts I say
absolutely because that actually will
focus the light to your retina that's
what they're designed to do
through a window or a windshield simply
will not work as well because of the
filtration of the wavelengths of light
that you want and then there's a lot of
data to support the fact that getting as
much bright light in your eyes
throughout the day provided it's not
painfully bright is excellent for your
wakefulness mechanisms and even for the
mechanisms of the brain and body that
control metabolism and feeding mood and
well-being this is the work mainly of
Samra hattar at the National Institutes
of mental health he's the uh the head of
the chronobiology unit at the National
Institutes of mental health so Sarah
would say get as much bright light in
your eyes as you can early in the day
and throughout the day and then
somewhere close to bedtime trough that
and live in the darkest environment you
possibly can manage safely he's not a
big fan of being in completely
light absent environments but that
simple behavior of early light viewing
most days if not all days sets in motion
these three phases that lend themselves
best to focused work creative work the
ability to stay awake most of the day
naps are fine we know provided they
don't interfere with nighttime sleep so
naps should be shorter than 90 minutes
but if any if a nap of any duration
prevents you from falling and staying
asleep at night then you don't want to
nap so light is the dominant way that
you set this this whole process in
motion and we know based on work that I
wasn't involved in but that David
Spiegel did with the great Robert
sapolski that if these cortisol pulse
doesn't arrive early enough in the day
and it start because starts arriving in
the afternoon that's a physiological
signature of depression and anxiety so
that cortisol pulse is happening one way
or another and you want to Anchor to the
early part of the day and so if you're
feeling Wide Awake anxious in the sort
of wired and tired late in the day
chances are you're not getting enough
sunlight early in the day and throughout
the day if people out there think that
the moment you start achieving some
success that things are going to get
easier it gets worse there are more
opportunities and therefore your
structure gets disrupted more email more
texts come in more amazing possible
relationships and places to eat and
things to do it it actually starts to
undermine the whole process if you're
not careful I have a list and now I make
it every day because when I just put it
next to me and I didn't write it out it
didn't work but like it literally starts
dog walk number one get sun I mean like
really basic stuff get sunlight then I
do a 90 minute work block which means I
use the program freedom on the computer
no internet no phone I turn off the
phone I put in my car sometimes it's
really bad I mean the phone is it's a
it's such a pull ask me for some code to
get into something and then I think I
need the phone next thing I'm doing
something else so 90 minute work block
but what's beautiful is that the nervous
system and I don't know the underlying
basis of this but the nervous system has
this feature to it where when we take
the the chaos of choice
and we restrict ourselves to one of
those choices you get a neurochemical
payoff and it comes in the form of
dopamine there's something about
activities that are forced restriction
to one particular Focus right so I'm
gonna write for 90 minutes or I'm going
to
um think for 90 minutes or I'm just
gonna walk the dog I live in an area now
where I don't get reception on my dog
walks at first it was excruciating I
love it now it's like I just walked the
dog and there's mornings I have a
bulldog he does not like to walk so I'm
like I gotta get back and I'm frustrated
and I know and it's hilarious right
because I notice myself
and the way that my my
um tripwire to agitation is so slight
I'm like one of these people I can just
in a second I'm aggravated because it's
not happening as quickly and so I've
learned to make the whole walk a process
of me just like
recognizing these features of myself and
my Bulldog Costello just applauds a lot
he could care less right so the walk is
very it's only about walking the dog
and the the email if it's email is only
about checking email right and there's
something valuable to this and I think
the brain loves this when we give it
this and the Brain
unfortunately is also happy to just take
a smorgasbord of you know pseudorandom
thoughts and actions all day every day
but there's something so deeply
satisfying about Focus
and um
I think we could all uh benefit from
doing more of that it's just so hard to
do and I'm not an anti-phone guy I'm
from Silicon Valley I use the phone I'm
addicted to my phone I admit it I'm
addicted to my phone but I'm trying
really hard to
cultivate a different relationship to it
because I think that uh in now that it's
2021 I think looking back phones we've
had them for about 10 years there are so
many examples of ways in which they
erode our best relationship to life so
many ways
that I don't think we should get rid of
them but I think we really need to start
being conscious of of the ways in which
they are eroding our productivity our
creativity our relationships and I don't
have any obvious answers to this I just
have tools that I use
um and that I've found to be of benefit
but I think in the next five years we
are going to see a shift toward people
really moving away from from phones in
um as much as we use them now I have
really tried to adopt this idea that
when it's inevitable
and it will inevitably arrive that
stress grows us that it really sharpens
decision making it really sharpens
decision making and you know if you have
a very stressful event and then you
recover from it that the worst thing to
do is just go and keep going you need to
take some time and reflect about what
led into that so I've I think I'm very
good at leveraging fear into positive
change if I really think about most of
the major shifts in my life it was
I'm scared as hell to remain in this
situation and I'm very good at
broadcasting fear into my future uh you
know if I've ever been in a bad
relationship it was clearly if I stayed
in it couldn't have been so bad that I
felt like I had to leave so I would
broadcast and project you know how
horrible it would be for my future
children and I might even build that up
a little bit my system now one could say
well maybe you could have navigated it
successfully I'm better at projecting
fear into my future and that has led me
to make I think better and better
decisions over time how do you get
motivated well one way to do that is if
you are good at subjectively attaching
dopamine to the pursuit just knowing
okay I really am hungry for this I'm
just I'm going to tell myself that you
know making you know making it one
percent of the way is a success and I'm
going to keep going and I'm going to
keep ratcheting on and that's great if
you can do that but for people that
can't do that understanding this
relationship with the pleasure pain
balance can be more powerful just
understanding the more friction and pain
that you experience the greater the
dopamine reward you will get later and
that serves as its own amplifier of the
whole process of pursuing more dopamine
and then the other aspect of it is that
anytime that we're leaning into action
you know it has the the possibility of
being an amplifying process or a
depleting process and the key to that is
making sure that you're balancing the
dopamine and epinephrine systems you
know epinephrine being this molecule of
universal currency of energy output it
could be out of hate or it could be out
of love epinephrine doesn't care and
actually dopamine doesn't care none of
these systems care about us they just
work underneath our sub underneath our
conscious control but when you start to
understand that hitting the gas pedal is
great but hitting the gas pedal and then
coming off the gas pedal a little bit
you can kind of sit in a more relaxed
RPM actually allows you to go much
further I think that people leaning into
action is terrific I always say you can
either be back on your heels flat-footed
or forward Center of mass the best
situation is actually to be
right upright but just know that you can
be forward Center of mass at any point
and you know that to take it back to sex
and reproduction because it's a Salient
Example The Arc of of sex is very
interesting when because when you think
about autonomic arousal it turns out
that the the arousal stage of sex
actually involves release of dopamine
but is what we call parasympathetic
dominant it's actually has to be relaxed
enough
in order to occur okay everyone can read
between the lines on this
orgasm is actually a
I don't want to say full-blown it's a
it's a it is a sympathetic nervous
system driven response it's identical to
the stress system it's driven by the
same neural circuits as stress and then
what comes afterward
the parasympathetic system goes back up
again it's that deep relaxation so why
do I say this not to talk about sex to
be you know to to serve as a highlighter
but rather our species arrived here
because of this dance between arousal
and relaxation arousal and relaxation
and one thing we can say for sure about
every human being that's alive now is
that their parents at least once
mastered this dance of relaxed but not
and excited but not too excited then
really excited and then relaxed that
dance was Mastered by all of our parents
and that's what delivered us here to
some extent and so I what this means is
that all the neural circuits from the
ones that led to our conception to the
ones that lead to us pursuing goals have
this balance this almost like a like a
seesaw right there's activation and calm
activation and calm and it's that
Dynamic process that's important to
master in every Endeavor so we use sex
as an example but in pursuit of goals
you have to learn how to pursue
short-term goals and like the goals
within the day make a cup of coffee and
go and long-term goals and when I said
dopamine is what's setting the your time
perception it's an Interval Timer
what you're saying is it's like the two
marshmallow experiment done at Stanford
defer the dopamine
and actually if you can turn the
weighting into the dopamine and then you
can extend out the reward for you know
waiting for the second marshmallow 15
minutes later et cetera Etc and there
are many many examples of this in the
Psychology and Neuroscience literature
and I would say finally in 2020 we
finally as a field got a clear idea of
how dopamine is really working because
before it was all about
work dopamine hit right sex gives you a
doberman hit the internet gives you a
dopamine what we didn't realize is that
repeated engagement with these things
leads to dopamine depletion and that the
pain and pleasure balance is always at
work the beliefs are attached to a set
of rewards so what now the dopamine
system is exceedingly powerful because
dopamine is is a kind of a dumb molecule
it has no brain of its own it's just a
it's just a molecule right it's just a
chemical but when dopamine is released
in our brain
we first of all it tends to orient us
towards
goals in the outside environment it's
the it's the molecule not just a reward
but of motivation and when we release
dopamine we tend to see the world in
terms of external goals and so you can
imagine now if there's a process built
up inside us where our thoughts are
causing
dopamine release and dopamine is shaping
what we see as rewards what we perceive
as Rewards
that can be wonderful or terrible
depending on how that's let me
understand this when we have dopamine
triggered in our body it's attached to
because it's attached to some type of
belief we're going to continue to say
this feels good that's right so let me
keep thinking this way and viewing the
world in this way because it's going to
keep making me feel good that's right
physically that's right wow even if it's
there's some fact or Not facts right
scientifically true we're not sure
harmful to other people or harmful to
yourself if it makes you feel good you
might stick to that belief that's right
so a good example with dopamine is it
with anytime thinking about science and
Neuroscience in particular thinking at
the extremes can be kind of useful so
people who are very depressed who see no
possibility in the world if you talk to
a depressed person every response they
give is going to be but it's not going
to work out they are absolutely certain
that things are going to turn out bad
and there's a benefit for having that
belief and they're entrenched in it they
may actually be rewarding that somewhat
although typically depressed states have
very low dopamine at the opposite
extreme is Mania when people are in a
manic phase dopamine is very high we
know this and they see possibility
everywhere and there's certain things
are going to work out they they will
spend money they don't have they'll
create relationships they don't have
time and energy for they will overdo
everything and so somewhere in the
middle is this healthy range where where
can where we realize that how we view
the world is shaping the release of
these chemicals and I do believe this
happens when we have positive thoughts
we we get a lift if we if we can get a
lift from our positive thoughts
and then dopamine itself puts us in
relationship with the outside world such
that we view the outside world as having
more possibility that is going to put us
into forward momentum they're good there
are a lot of studies to support that
when dopamine is low we tend to see very
little possibility in the world and so a
positive thought triggers
forward movement potentially yes yeah so
positive thinking which a lot of people
say well that's just positive thinking
it doesn't work some people say well be
positive think positive others are
saying that doesn't work
but with science I'm hearing you say it
gives you a little bit of a lift
absolutely the the key with positive
thinking it is that it has to be honest
it it can't be I've already won you know
I don't have an Olympic gold medal if I
could tell myself I'm gonna get one
tomorrow but I just don't have the
skills so that's not going to release
dopamine in my system how do you know
it's honest if you're in a depressed
state and you don't believe that you are
actually better off than where you're at
the key is to attach the so one thing to
understand is that dopamine release in
the brain is always subjective there's
no experience that that says uh that has
unique domain over dopamine release that
will only allow dopamine release so
if it's very subjective so if I say to
myself
I'm going to get into the process of
doing something we have a new year
coming up so there's going to be a lot
of resolutions soon the
it's not about if you attach the
dopamine release to the process of
effort or goal setting itself you'll
have more energy to be an effort and
then if you can attach dopamine release
to the belief that you're at least
heading in the right direction you'll
have more energy to keep going in the
right direction people make the mistake
of thinking that
the the positive thought process should
be attached to the finish line it's not
about thinking of already one it's not
about being delusional it's about
thinking that your training is going to
take you to the finish line and so it's
about moving that mental Horizon in more
close and more closely and then
triggering some sort of positive
internal representation of what you're
doing meaning thinking positive and
people this is usually where I get
stopped and people say wait but it
sounds so subjective tell me exactly how
to do it but here's the thing I thought
it's it's supposed to be subjective this
is for you everyone needs to figure out
what allows them to continue to be in
forward momentum what allows them to
constrain the world of possibilities
and to go after goals and how often to
self-reward because but the key is the
self-word because if you start only
pursuing external rewards that's when
you are no longer in control of your
dopamine system because you're relying
on actually something physically
happening in the physical world not
internal that's right and let's be
really really honest and burst the the
bubble that I feel like should have been
burst a long time ago which is yes
everybody including me it is possible
that you can do everything and still
fail no one wants to say that but the
way that you ensure against that is to
attach reward to the effort process
because the dopamine molecule creates a
sense of certainty and you're not trying
to create certainty about the final
outcome you're trying to create
certainty only about the next outcome
that's enroute to the final outcome the
next action so you want to think about
Milestones yes and so people set out
with oh I'm gonna I'm gonna write the
Great America novel or I'm going to
um you know get the IPO and of course
that's an important you need to have a
sense of what the Finish Line would
actually look like but the more that one
can attach this subjective release of
dopamine process to the intermediate
steps through positive thinking and
action positive thinking in action the
the higher that probability goes toward
in science we say there's a probability
of zero to one the higher that
probability goes to one which is
certainty now
everyone knows in the back of their mind
that there is no absolute certainty when
I hear about you know athletes or
Fighters I was certain I was going to
win we all know that there's a point
zero zero zero zero zero doubt
in everybody right point zero zero
whatever that is now for some people
they might be able to push that number
way way out but certainty about outcome
is actually a form of delusion certainty
about a Mania yeah that's right that's
right you see this in Mania and that's
why people start engaging their
behaviors
this is going to happen that's right the
silver lining in this is that when you
create certainty about outcomes you know
you can control
you take over this neurobiological
system and you create almost certainty
that you will complete the process to
the end goal
perfectly how do we start opening up and
being more comfortable in the discomfort
of change not just growth but just
change in shifts that we don't expect
and predict yeah I think two ways um one
I'll just go back to this fundamental
feature of the nervous system which is
it's trying to make predictions so the
reason why change is stressful even
positive change believe it or not is
quote unquote stressful I agree uh is
because of this then the release of
adrenaline and and Associated molecules
with any time things change I mean if
you look at the psychologists have
worked this out there's a hierarchy of
stressors
um and of course at the at the top of
that hierarchy are awful things that we
don't you know I think at the top to be
honest I think death of a child is is
perhaps the the greatest stressor
divorce death of a loved one
um these kinds of horrible things that
we wouldn't wish on anyone then as one
goes down not too far below you see
things like moving to a new home or
apartment you think well that could be a
great event right birth of a new child
and you think wait a second I thought
that's supposed to be one of the
greatest joys in life and indeed it is
but it's stressful to the nervous system
because so many things have to be
reconfigured not to say anything about
the lack of sleep with a newborn and
this kind of thing so
change is always going to force our
brain to make more assessments of our
environment one of the things that we
can say about the brain for sure is that
once it learns something it likes to not
have to think about it when you walk
because you already know how to walk you
don't think right left right left right
left but when you learn how to dance a
new step or something of that sort or a
new skill uh Sports skill you have to
think about it and it's work and anytime
we have to think about behaviors and
they aren't simply reflexive that work
as we call it isn't It's a combination
of the release of things like adrenaline
epinephrine in the brain and body I
should say from the adrenals in the body
but also in the brain from a little
brain area called Locus ceruleus that is
acts as kind of a sprinkler system for
the brain to kind of wake up all brain
areas saying okay let's pay attention to
a lot of stuff here very basic system
um but but very fundamental system it's
literally a wake-up system for the brain
works in parallel with the release of
adrenaline into our body
now
one way to deal with change is to Simply
know this right to understand that if
one feels stressed or agitated around a
new move or you have a partner who's
really stressed about a new move even
though it's exciting it should be
exciting that that's perfectly normal
because what they're experiencing is
this increase in agitation and alertness
and it also makes it harder to enter
deeply relaxed States because the brain
is in a mode of predictions making
predictions what's happening next
thinking thinking thinking and one of
the things that's key to falling asleep
each night and replenishing our ability
to think and make predictions is the
ability to turn off thinking this is why
I'm such a fan of what traditionally was
called yoga nidro which literally means
yoga sleep lying down it's a form of
meditation as you know and with
breathing Etc
um I I certainly I want to point out
that I have no desire to rename any of
these ancient practices these are
beautiful practices they've been built
up over thousands of years the reason I
call uh sometimes batch Yoga Nidra with
so-called nsdr non-sleep deep rest is
that on 4 fortunately both in science
and in traditional cultures around some
of these behaviors the language has
become a barrier for people to try them
I agree I'm not trying to wash away any
of the the wonderful culture and
tradition around these I want to be very
clear about that but ultimately it's
about accessing a state of mind as for
anyone that's listened to a Yoga Nidra
script and I should say I do Nitra every
day I have for almost a decade now it's
without question along with viewing
Morning Light sunlight the most powerful
practice I think I can recommend to
anyone
um it is about as you always hear in a
classic nature script you move away from
thinking and doing to being and feeling
now what is that if we take a
neuroscience lensity what is this
thinking and doing being and feeling
it's about shutting down of the
prefrontal cortex which is making
predictions what's happening next right
as we move into sleep you enter that
kind of liminal state where things
become disjointed right a cat flies
through the room and then you might jerk
yourself awake and it's kind of odd but
that that's the state of not thinking
and doing and just being and feeling
being in one's pure somatic experience
so I would say
in order to move through change
designate 20 to 30 minutes each day to
put the brain into a state of
non-thinking non-doing and into a state
of quote unquote being and feeling so
not making predictions now the tricky
thing is when one is stressed that's
especially hard to do yeah and this is
why I think what is it Tik nahan said
you know what is that who said you know
um when stress you know I meditate every
day but when stress meditate twice as
long or something like that right when I
don't think I have time like that is
almost exactly to make the time it's a
skill and so this ability to turn off
thinking enhances one's ability to enter
sleep which is vital for mental and
physical health obviously
learning etc for reasons we discussed so
develop the ability to deliberately
disengage from thinking and doing and do
that during periods of low stress right
20 to 30 minutes a day even 10 minutes a
day of just learning teaching oneself
and practicing the art of turning off
prediction is an incredibly valuable
skill and then the other one is to just
understand that we're being bombarded
with contextual change all the time you
know I love Instagram I teach science on
Instagram I see you there daily yeah um
and so scrolling on Instagram is an
interesting experience because in five
minutes you can look at a thousand
different contexts the human brain has
never dealt with that kind of change
before even when television when I was
growing up there were three or four good
channels then it went to cable and then
now you get onto an airplane or
something you've got 240 channels yeah
that's that's a drop in the bucket
compared to what we can get in in a
social media feed yeah so I think we
just need to be aware that the brain can
work with that but then what you're
turning on is an ability to walk into a
new context and and figure it out the
statistics imagine if if an Instagram
feed and I'm not demonizing Instagram I
think they're wonderful I think they
provide a wonderful resource truly but
imagine if we walked out of this room
and it was a completely different
landscape it was a jungle then we turned
the corner and go into what I would
think was the kitchen and it was the
kitchen of the some you know of what
some Thomas Keller uh restaurant in New
York turned the corner and all of a
sudden we're under water that's social
media yeah and we can cope with that so
so if I think about it that way then I
think if we can cope with that then we
can cope with transitions in so called
real life with with ease now some people
have more situational awareness than
others they walk into an environment and
they're sensing all the things other
people walk into an environment and
they're very good at narrowing their
attentional Spotlight the latter group
actually has a bit of an advantage they
probably wouldn't be so good as a
special operator in the military that
has to develop situational advantage or
a police officer or a teacher but
they're going to be immensely good at
one-on-one interactions because they can
make the room disappear
and so but we need both kinds of people
and we all need to learn how to sort of
brighten and broaden these attentional
spotlights and narrow them as well and
I'll just briefly say we are Old World
primates as it turns out and we have the
capacity to do what's called covert
attention yeah I can pay attention to
you but I can also notice that in my
periphery there's something else going
on so I've got two spotlights now but I
am dividing my attention we can't do
three simultaneously but what I can also
do is decide to merge those two
spotlights and intensify them and narrow
the aperture of my visual window and my
auditory window so we should always
think of ours that our attention is two
spotlights that can be very broad or it
can be very narrowly focused and that we
can overlap them yeah and I think that's
fantastic I think we should all know how
to do both yeah we should learn how to
narrow the aperture of our Focus deeply
engage but also deliberately disengage
and the process of falling asleep that
we were talking about before is the
practice of learning how to take that
attentional Spotlight move those those
two apart and then dip not dim them but
extend that same Luminosity out more
broadly more broadly and then we're off
to sleep yeah so so it's about
deliberate control of the nervous system
and unfortunately we all know how to
focus on something if we're very
stressed or excited by it most people
don't learn how to turn off this focus
and learn how to deliberately disengage
and one of my Great Hopes for Humanity
is that children and adults will learn
how to deliberately disengage yeah
because it benefits sleep which benefits
mental and physical health and also if
you think about it most of the bad
things that we do to ourselves and
others and that people do to one another
most not all but most are from a
heightened state of reactivity yeah
where we're just not conscious yes and
that's because our aperture our window
of attention is too narrow we're not
taking in to account the full space and
time of what we're thinking about yeah
and as a last Point space and time are
linked in the brain
if you have a narrow visual Focus you
tend to have a narrow time slicing right
which makes sense if you think about
like a little kid watching ants on the
ground and then gets called into dinner
and all of a sudden the way you batch
time is different when you're sleepy you
tend to batch things in Big Blocks okay
or when you're bored big blocks of time
when you're very excited stressed or
happily excited you're in that fast
frame rate you've gone from 60 frames
per second which I think is a typical
smartphone to a thousand frames per
second
wow so you're catching all the micro
nuances but you're missing everything
else if ever there was a phenomenon in
life that I'm struck by is uh it's
trauma and
um you know it's it's incredible to me
how
you know we experience these things uh
to some for some people more than others
right um you know to some extent
everyone has trauma to some extent I
think we need to be fair and say that
some people have a tremendous amount of
trauma in other people less
um but that there's some consistent
themes that the psychoanalyst actually
had right which is that for many people
there's this what the analysts would
call a repetition compulsion right
somebody experiences something really
terrible as a child and then as an adult
they find themselves seeking out similar
types of situations and it's just the
most illogical thing one can imagine and
the analysts would say well this is a
reparative wish an attempt to
throw oneself back subconsciously throw
oneself back into these scenarios to get
a different outcome right so for example
if you had a deadbeat dad you're gonna
you're a young woman you're gonna search
out you're gonna seek out like a
boyfriend who has those same behavior
patterns
logic yeah in one case it's the exact
opposite in which case we might say well
that's a more functional step in the
other case it's um yes this repetition
compulsion making the same mistakes
despite knowing better right and not
necessarily from this standpoint of
addiction where there's some deeper
dopamine circuits driving that
um so you know trauma is fascinating in
that way I mean what do we know about
trauma and again I'm borrowing from some
of my conversations with David Spiegel
and with Anna Lemke who I know you've
had on the podcast
you know it's very clear that relief
from trauma in some way or another
almost always involves going
deliberately bringing oneself back into
the state of mind and body that occurred
during the trauma as horrible as that
might seem avoiding that seems to be an
issue and then gradually or hopefully
quickly but in some cases gradually
desensitizing oneself to that experience
as not just a overwhelming horrible
experience but a sad but no longer
overwhelming experience so that they can
gain some sort of
um ability to think inside of the the
memory and to parse
uh it parse what happened one resounding
theme that I've collected in talking to
trauma therapists and exploring a lot of
the therapies for trauma is that you
know oftentimes trauma involves a deep
confusion for whatever reason a deep
confusion about who was responsible and
this is something that's somewhat
complicated and um can be troubling to
think about but people will experience a
a trauma a car crash a sexual assault a
um devastating Financial loss can also
be a trauma and then somehow in that in
one's mind
it's not clear whether or not that was
something that happened to them or that
they created for themselves now the
typical script of this was people
talking about oh you know I shouldn't
have been out that late or dressed that
way or acted that way but it's actually
can be much more subtle and diabolical
than that it can be that uh it can start
to Route into people's own perceptive
self like maybe I'm not worthy of being
happy and therefore the fact that this
happened makes total sense people create
these these crazy scripts and crazy
because they don't match any real world
facts but they do match a lot of
internal structure and so it becomes
very complex to unpack all this but what
we know for sure is that accessing the
state of mind and body that resembles
the state of mind and body during the
trauma is the first step in moving
trauma out of the body so-called trauma
release now almost always that has to be
done in concert with a really
well-trained uh physician or clinician
because that can be overwhelming
certainly the first time there's also
some evidence based on some decent
studies that show that
accessing deliberately accessing states
of high autonomic arousal that are
independent from the trauma so things
like ice baths things like Hard Exercise
things like very very intense
experiences separate from the traumatic
memory can be useful in allowing people
to attain Comfort at high levels of
autonomic arousal right I mean you're
trying to essentially say you know go
back to this place and work it through
try and get some space or some distance
from the emotion and yet for some people
just an elevation in heart rate is
overwhelming for them and so they're not
even going to set foot on the first step
up the mountain when in fact that's
exactly what they need to do so there's
now a kind of movement in Psychiatry and
psychology to bring in more of these I
guess you could call them somatic
approaches but to my mind they're really
physiological approaches they're really
approaches that teach people how to be
tolerant of high levels of autonomic
arousal and so that's that's something
that we're starting to see a shift in
the other thing I should just
acknowledge is that you know until the
psychoanalysts the cognitive behavioral
therapists the neuroscientists and the
psychiatrists join arms we are going to
go around and around and around this
Merry-Go-Round of not knowing how to
deal with trauma and feelings right I
mean we're all told to feel our feelings
but not trust them as facts and yet here
I'm telling you that most successful
trauma therapies involve getting right
up close to that event really letting it
almost overtake oneself and then start
to create these these gaps and these
gaps that I'm referring to are real gaps
in neural circuitry that that worked
from Spiegel and many others have shown
and the work doing brain imaging under
conditions of ketamine and other types
of pharmacologic therapies have shown
that there there are active associations
normally between the prefrontal cortex
which is thinking planning and reasoning
the insula which is an area of the brain
that monitors how we feel internally and
then some of these areas like the
inter-singulate cortex which are
involved in kind of self-monitoring and
figuring out how much of what I'm
experiencing is coming from thoughts and
things within and from things in my
environment and under conditions of
extreme autonomic arousal and somewhat
counterintuitively under conditions of
deep relaxation those neural circuits
are able to rearrange themselves and
when one emerges from those treatments
the default Network then is one of
perspective it's one of saying ah this
is something that happened but it was
not my fault or this is something that
happened and indeed it set me up for a
number of positive opportunities in my
life all those sorts of stories that we
hear about all the time so if this is
sounding a little bit abstract I'm
trying my best to put some structure on
it but where there's a lack of structure
I'll
um you know kind of wriggle out of that
by saying that you know there is no
clear answer as to where trauma is
represented in the nervous system many
people talk about trauma being manifest
as physical symptoms in their body and
that used to be considered kind of you
know it's pseudoscience makes perfect
sense makes perfect sense after all the
nervous system is the brain the eyes and
the spinal cord for central nervous
system and then every organ in your body
is innervated by
nerve cells neurons and the peripheral
nervous system so the manifestation of
things in the body and in the brain is
shouldn't surprise anybody and I think
one of the Great
expansions of Neuroscience in the last
few years is that whereas five ten years
ago you would find very few grants and
laboratory you know grants funding work
in Laboratories and Laboratories working
on elements of the nervous system in the
body very very few maybe 98 of the focus
was on things within the brain memory
Consciousness Vision hearing Etc now an
enormous number of Laboratories are
moving into this mind-body relationship
but they don't call it that they call it
the peripheral nervous system the
autonomic nervous system right they call
them the gut brain axis right so we have
fancy names to um to disguise the fact
that we're studying mind and body right
dopamine as I've said is involved in
anticipation of wanting not of having
it's involved in motivation toward the
thing that you want and it biases us
towards action
reward prediction error equals the
actual amount of dopamine that's
released in response to something versus
minus the amount that's expected okay so
if you tell a kid we might have ice
cream they hear we're going to have ice
cream and they expect it and if you
later say well we're not going to have
ice cream and I said maybe that's
actually going to lead to a much bigger
crash in dopamine it's going to lead to
a negative signal a punishment signal
it's gonna literally going to feel like
pain so kids you can leverage this
if your parents say maybe they're
effectively telling your dopamine system
absolutely now adults are like this too
if we think something might happen and
it doesn't happen there's a big crash in
our in our affect and our emotionality
and that's because that dopamine system
goes from firing about three to four
times per second to about 10 or 15 times
per second in the possibility that
something might happen possibility is
deeply woven into our biology of the
dopamine and motivation system as a way
for us presumably in ancient times to
explore novel territories and get a
sense that maybe there's water there
maybe there are mates there maybe
there's better food there maybe there's
resources there the maybe is an
important thing that in language terms
maybe means maybe but in neurobiological
terms maybe means perhaps there's going
to be the surprise of an even bigger
dopamine reward and the one thing
dopamine loves more than anything else
is surprise growth mindset which is the
academic discover recovery and
laboratory discovery of my colleague
Carol dweck at Stanford is the Hallmark
of growth mindset is really two things
one is I'm not where I want to be now
but I but I will I'm capable of getting
there eventually the other is to attach
a sense of reward to the effort process
itself in fact don't reward the result
reward the effort that's right and if
you look at true High performers people
that are consistently good at what they
do they don't peek and go through the
postpartum depression and crash and come
back and their life is a cycle of ups
and downs but really people who are on
that upward trajectory consistently
those people attach dopamine to the
effort process and actually Carol's one
of her original studies on the discovery
of growth mindset was these kids that
love doing math problems that they knew
they couldn't get right
so it's like the people love puzzles but
in this case they knew they couldn't get
it right but they loved doing it and it
incidentally or not so incidentally
these kids are fantastic at math when
there is a right answer because they
they feel some sense of reward from the
effort process yeah now the cool thing
about dopamine
is that it's very subjectively
controlled we can all learn to secrete
dopamine in our brain in response to
things that are in a purely subjective
way our interpretation our
interpretation and but it has to be
attached to reality so you know one
should never confuse what is real right
so no so if you're F if you're thinking
about the effort you're expending so
let's say somebody right now is
financially back on their heels and
they're setting up a new business for
instance and it's hard
if they can take a few moments or
minutes each day to reflect on the fact
that the effort process is allowing them
to climb out of their hole potentially
that it's giving them an opportunity
that it's
somehow
they are on the right path or if they're
not in movement along that path or at
least oriented on the right path they're
not lying in bed all day they're taking
a step if they can reward that process
internally two things happen
first of all the brain circuits that are
associated with building subjective
rewards and dopamine gets stronger so
you get better at that process and
second and most importantly dopamine has
an amazing ability to buffer adrenaline
and buffer epinephrine and what I mean
by that is there was a study that was
published in the journal cell excellent
Journal cell Press Journal a couple
years ago showing that with repeated
bouts of effort we use and we release
more and more epinephrine it's kind of
adrenaline but in the brain
with more effort every time every time
you put in effort so every time you make
look for this let's keep it if I were to
keep it in the business context every
time you make write that email every
time you let's say it's a person who's a
Craftsman and a crafts woman every time
you're working in the in the shop and
doing that every bit of effort
you're taking a little bit of money out
of this epinephrine account you're
spending epinephrine at some point
those levels of epinephrine get high
enough that you you feel like quitting
it feels exhausting this was done in a
beautiful study actually where
um they control the visual environments
and they have the subjects
exert effort and they can control the
visual environment so sometimes the
effort of of taking steps and moving
forward this is actually kind of pushing
forward and kind of swimming motion
um would give them the Sensation that
they were actually making progress and
other times it was an exercise in
futility where they would just keep the
the visual World stationary and they
would expend effort and they didn't
think they were going anywhere
epinephrine's climbing climbing climbing
and eventually they quit now dopamine is
able to push back on that epinephrine
and give you
anyone the the feeling that you could
continue and maybe even the feeling that
you want to continue and you've seen
this actually football is a good example
two teams play say the Super Bowl both
teams are Max effort the entire time
yeah Max effort
the team that wins suddenly in a moment
has the energy to jump all over the
place party for days they can talk I
mean they they they're exhausted right
before that well that wasn't glycogen or
stored energy of any kind except it was
neural energy and what happened was
effort is this adrenaline adrenaline
adrenaline adrenaline eventually people
quit they just quit the
dopamine is able to suppress that and so
then you're expending effort but you're
doing it from a place of feeling like
you have energy for it so last year
there was a paper published
that essentially was asking why any
human or animal quits at any Behavior
now certain behavior is like I can't
lift a car unless it's a very small car
I can't lift a car but if it's we're
talking about running or we're talking
about long bouts of work the question is
why do we quit like what is that it
turns out that every time we exert
effort a certain amount of noradrenaline
in the brain is released and there's a
sort of a counter in the brain stem and
at some point enough noradrenaline is
released and it shuts down cognitive
control deliberate control over the
motor circuitry and we quit that's it
but the thing that can restore those
levels or can sort of reset those levels
lower and give us more gas more mileage
is dopamine and it makes perfect sense
because our species had to move against
very challenging things in in nature and
in in terms of in culture at every stage
of our Evolution including now 2020 is a
good example of this and when a good
example would be if you're really
slogging it out and things are miserable
just think like the worst family
vacation everything's a disaster or a
very hard physical event
and someone cracks a joke
you're almost immediately feel a sense
of relief you see this in the team that
wins the Super Bowl both teams slogged
it out you have to believe they were
both at Max effort the entire game look
at the team that wins they have extra
energy they're jumping all over the
place so it can't be physical energy it
can't be glycogen related it's not
Ketone related it's nothing in the body
in that sense it's dopamine's ability to
take that level of norepinephrine and
smack it back down and so we can learn
this right I mean I think this is where
there's real power like in your story
um or the story that I'm familiar with
from your book like the the ability to
push through those pain points is
something that we really can export to
other aspects of life because it's the
same neurochemicals that are involved so
when you get to a particular location or
maybe you're I recall
um you know a portion where you're just
you're feeling lousy you know you're
injured or you feel like you're hurt and
you can reframe it mentally
and think I'm actually still on the
ladder I'm still holding on to a rung I
know at least that much I'm still
breathing I know that much and the lift
that we get is not some psychological
pump up it's a neurochemical thing it's
dopamine suppressing norepinephrine and
saying you're on the right path you can
keep going it's a permission to keep
going and we grant that permission to
ourselves no one grants that permission
to us I think one of the other kind of
misconceptions that we want to dissolve
is this idea that external rewards can
actually Propel us down long past of of
success and high performance they can't
no it's an internal sustainable fuel
source yeah yeah I have a friend from
the SEAL Teams and somebody asked us
recently we were given a talk um and
somebody said how can I make sure that I
continue to self-reward and I'm not
driven by these external rewards how can
I continue to have that drive and uh his
answer was very good he said give away
all the external rewards you know and no
not all everyone can afford to do this
just about you and you it's just you and
you and the more attached there's a
famous Stanford study done at Bing
Nursery School probably not far where
from where you were in the dormitory
there's a little Nursery School in
Escondido Village and they did this
study where they looked at kids that
like to um playing during their recess
it's all recess in nursery school but
they're drawing and they took the kids
that really like to draw
and they started giving them little gold
stars on their drawings and then they
liked the gold stars for a kid that's an
extrinsic reward and then they stopped
doing that and the kids stopped drawing
they just they they associate the good
feeling of doing it with the external
rewards and we have to be very cautious
about how much of our internal dopamine
we attach to external rewards if we want
to continue to grow and pursue and focus
and work hard if you just want to get to
some place and cash in
then fine but most people find
themselves in a pretty miserable place
because their dopamine was so attached
to external rewards they need more and
more we often hear that you know the
social media getting dopamine hit after
dopamine hit
when we first get on social media after
a while for the first time or after a
long period of time the amount of
dopamine that's released we think is
quite substantial it's novel remember
dopamine is about novelty surprise and
the sense that we are on some exciting
track that's what dopamine is really
about it puts us into states of
Readiness anticipation looking seeking
Etc almost always for things outside the
confines of our skin just to contrast it
maybe for a bit more of a future
discussion
serotonin does the opposite when there's
a lot of serotonin in our brain and body
typically it makes us feel satisfied
sated and more quiet and comfortable
with what we have in our own immediate
sphere and within us right the comfort
of a good meal the food you have
dopamine is about go go if you look at
somebody who's high on cocaine or
Methamphetamine it's all about Pursuit
because that's a very dopaminergic drug
you look at somebody who's taking a drug
and I'm not suggesting people do this
but it really ramps up serotonin let's
say a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor Prozac Zoloft Etc the side
effects of those drugs if the dosages
are too high lack of appetite lack of
libido kind of meh about life you know
and so they'll adjust the dose down
that's because those are serotonergic
drugs so
in in general
when we are in pursuit of things
dopamine is is quite high so now you
have to remind me your question because
I've set up the dopamine serotonin uh
cell phones uh cell phones yes
um forgive me so
the thing about cell phones is when you
first get on there and you haven't let's
say you're no Wi-Fi on the flight or
something and you land it can actually
be quite stimulating you get a lot of
dopamine oh there's this oh there's that
but very quickly when you're scrolling
on social media
you're no longer getting the novelty but
you're continuing to do it you almost
don't know why you're doing it at that
point it shifts over to something that's
a bit more like an obsessive compulsive
Behavior where that we can define an
obsessive-compulsive Behavior where the
obsession leads to a compulsion so the
obsession is a thought that compulsion
is a behavior but the acting out of the
compulsion merely serves to increase the
obsession right this is very different
than being obsessed with food or
obsessed with cleanliness there's no
payoff right exactly there's no Anxiety
Relief by carrying out the compulsion
with OCD behaviors
like scrolling social media the dopamine
quickly wanes and then you find that
you're just sort of and we've all been
there you're scrolling you're like why
am I doing this this isn't that
interesting that is this isn't that
interesting now the algorithms for
social media are very clever and I don't
want to demonize it I you know provide a
lot of a lot of my life has spent on you
know on social media now but
in the algorithms that they've
Incorporated function on the the most
powerful way to keep people doing a
behavior or an animal for that matter is
intermittent random reward a random
intermittent reward that you don't know
when you're going to hit the jackpot so
you're scrolling you're scrolling and
then you see something typically it's
very high what you know in nerd speak
we'd say signal to noise so if you're
reading some interesting things this
came out in the news this came out and
then it's all of a sudden a riot or a
person that is Jump is base jumping off
a building or
um you know for people that are are
scrolling looking at bodies or something
like that live bodies that hopefully
people aren't looking at dead bodies but
look if something's very tragic then
that has this gravitational pull and
then you what happens is you start
getting
the system working for that next
dopamine hit that you don't know when
it's going to come it's just like
gambling so I look at social media as
initially being very dopaminergic
driving rewards surprised and excitement
but very quickly transitioning to
something more like OCD and the kinds of
behaviors where it looks if you if we
were to look at ourselves through the
lens of an experiment like we would an
animal experiment we think that animal
is sick if you saw an animal digging in
the corner looking looking looking
looking for a bone the dog is looking
looking looking looking looking you'd
think that's really sad that's us right
that's us I'm pointing myself
intentionally that's us so we have to
learn to self-regulate the amount of
time but that doesn't have to be a
process of you know scruffing ourselves
and saying don't do it don't do it think
about it in terms of the positive the
more time away from something the more
positively reinforcing it will be when
you return people form these
associations whether or not through
experience or through indirect
experience observing others
I think public speaking is one of the
greatest fear of dying yeah it's funny I
don't it's not funny but figure of
speech I never think about dying and
being afraid of dying I think about all
the scary things that could happen while
I'm living but there are many people who
are just intrinsically afraid of dying
and so that's that's a big one
um for people that uh don't swim fear of
drowning for people that swim less so
um for people that have some sort of
psychiatric disorder genuine psychiatric
disorder like obsessive-compulsive
disorder which is not just pers
obsessive-compulsive personality but
obsessive-compulsive disorder fear of
the of being discovered and the shame
that they have around their obsessions
and compulsions these are true OCD is
very common do they all live in the same
place
all of these different fears that all
exist yeah so I was rattling off and I
didn't answer your question
um to the the more important point so
forgive me
the short answer is they have a final
common pathway which is increased
autonomic arousal and that is funneled
through a couple what we call limbic
structures among others so there's
certainly involvement of the of the now
famous amygdala this which means almond
is almond shaped structure on the two
sides of the brain there's also area of
the brain called the Streator terminal
analysis also involved in fear and then
the hypothalamus this small collection
of neurons just above the roof of your
mouth which is really to me one of the
more fascinating areas of the brain
Harbors neurons that create a body-wide
and brayden-wide response to something
that the higher order areas of the brain
like the forebrain
see and perceive as dangerous as
threatening so the short answer is yes
it all funnels through hypothalamus
amygdalaustria terminalis and autonomic
nervous system that's the final common
pathway but in terms of the variety of
different things that can stimulate fear
and the ways that they can do that that
is highly contextual so the forebrain
this real estate in the brain right
behind behind the forehead is incredible
because it's sort of free real estate
for you to customize for your life
according to what happens to you early
on so for instance you might not be at
all afraid of heights and you say well
why is that so well maybe when you were
a kid you were one of those Maniacs that
like you know doing within the states we
call them Cherry drops the kids that
could you know swing on their feet and
then jump off the the bar and then other
kids are timidly crawling to the top of
the thing don't even want to go up the
ladder to the slide there's a ton of
variation and that variation does not
exist in the kind of deeper circuitry
the final common path circuitry it
exists in the learning that we
experienced early in life one bad fall
can do it I mean I Was Bitten very badly
by a German Shepherd when I was a kid
who had almost got my eye but you know
for whatever reason I've always liked
dogs anyway but there are other things
that I've experienced that have left
long-term negative imprints so I it's
highly contextual and a lot of it has to
do with what happens immediately after
the bad experience this is why nowadays
there's a lot of legal use of the drug
ketamine after traumas you know this is
all very dark stuff unfortunately but if
you you know you just imagine the family
member that was just in a car crash and
saw their the driver their loved one
impaled onto the steering column I mean
what could be more horrible than that
nowadays if they come into the emergency
room they will often give them an
injection of ketamine which is the
dissociative anesthetic to get them to
dissociate from this extreme emotional
state
so there are ways now to treat this
um and ketamine is used clinically at
later periods too people that are always
in anticipation and desire and seeking
that's wonderful for pursuing goals
however it's terrible for enjoying life
and actually those people are actually
quite difficult to be around there's a
certain almost um sociopathic element to
people who are what they call
hyperdopaminergic people who are always
on the dopaminergic scale to the point
where they are always pursuing goals in
fact those people are known to be at
least in the psychological spectrum they
can be very manipulative you know
dopamine and the pursuit of something
doesn't necessarily have to be high
energy and intense from the outside when
you observe it from the outside in fact
there are people who will manipulate in
order to get what they want this has
been shown who have high levels of
dopamine release in their brain but
they've learned that a kind of passive
manipulation is the best way to maneuver
through a particular environment I don't
want to focus too much on sociopathy
because those are kind of extreme
examples
but it just goes to show that people who
identify a goal and realize the series
of steps that they need to take in order
to achieve that goal can either do it
through ethical means or non-ethical
means they can do it through active
Pursuit being the kind of type a person
that's always declaring their goals and
going after it posting it on Instagram
telling everybody about it trying to
recruit others there's that phenotype
there's that kind of signature of
dopamine and then there are the people
that want to get what they want and
they're doing it by always serving other
people by always taking care of
everybody else's needs by always trying
to accomplish their goals but through a
mode that at least from the outside
seems more passive or more about
supporting others neither of these are
good or bad and that's because dopamine
is a molecule it doesn't care how you
reach your goals it only cares that you
reach your goals because the sense the
internal sensation is one again of mild
pleasure
a little bit of pain although more pain
over time if you're not reaching those
goals and it takes you away from the
Here and Now how to get enough sleep and
how to make sure you get into all these
different sleep States and this is
particularly important for you so-called
night owls
there's a lot of controversy out there
as to whether or not different so-called
chronotypes exist that is people who
just naturally or genetically want to be
an early bird wake up early and go to
bed early so these people that wake up
at 4am and would be most comfortable
going to bed by seven or eight pm or
nine PM then there are so-called night
owls people that would feel best or tend
to feel best when they go to sleep at
1am 2 A.M even 3 A.M and like to wake up
later 8 9 10 or even 11 A.M or noon and
then of course most people go to sleep
somewhere between 10 pm and midnight and
wake up somewhere between 5 a.m and 7
A.M or I suppose more typically 6 a.m
and 8 A.M now whether or not real
chronotypes exist or whether or not
people simply select schedules for sleep
and wakefulness that they like because
of their social schedules or the
activities they enjoy for instance some
people like to really go out they like
to go out dancing or hear music or spend
time in venues that are only open late
at night and don't even open until noon
or after other people like myself rarely
go out at night but I like to get up
early I like to exercise I like to see
the sunrise Etc so I don't know if I'm a
morning person or an evening person I
just know the things I enjoy tend to
happen in the early part of the day and
the things that I don't enjoy quite as
much didn't happen late at night
regardless of whether or not they're a
real genetic propensities to be a night
owl or an early bird or a sort of
typical person right there in the middle
it's very important that people have
some control over their sleep schedule
and even more important that people are
able to get sufficient amount of REM
sleep and slow wave sleep for many
reasons but including the reasons I
discussed in the previous study related
to metabolism
I'm very excited there for about a study
that came out in sleep medicine this was
a few years ago but somehow I missed
this one it was published in 2019 and
the title of this article is resetting
the late timing of night owls has a
positive impact on mental health
physical health and performance this is
a study done in humans focusing
specifically on people that like to stay
up late and sleep in but who desire to
be able to get up and feel Alert in
order to go to work or study and they
want to go to sleep a bit earlier and so
there are a lot of questions embedded in
this study in particular whether or not
people can actually shift their schedule
by a few hours or more some people out
there contend that if you're a night owl
that's just going to be impossible or
very very challenging to do turns out
it's not impossible and it's not even
that challenging to do provided you do
the right things just a brief overview
of the study and then I'll give you the
key takeaways it was a randomized
controlled trial it involved a number of
different people both male and female
and what they did was they used
non-pharmacological practical
interventions in in a real world setting
here I'm paraphrasing they use targeted
light exposure they used consistent
sleep wake times they used fixed meal
times caffeine intake and exercise this
is one of the reasons I love this study
so much because I've done episodes where
I've talked about temperature exercise
feeding and most importantly light
exposure as a way to control and shift
your sleep wake Cycles your so-called
circadian timing and entrainment
what did they find well they found quote
significant improvements in terms of
mood so far less depression and stress
subjectively measured as well as
improved cognitive performance that was
objectively measured so improve reaction
times improved physical grip strength
which is actually a measure not just of
strength per se but also of nervous
system function and a number of things
that people could do in order to
optimize their morning hours even though
they were night owls previously what do
they have people do well I'm just going
to list this off
and sort of Rapid Fire succession then
we'll provide a link to the study if you
want to learn more first of all they
told participants to try and wake up two
to three hours before their typical
wake-up time two to three hours that
seems brutal to me and probably seems
brutal to you if you're somebody who
typically wakes up at 10 am to try and
get up at eight or even 7 A.M
consistently
but they were also asked to maximize
outdoor light exposure during the
mornings for reasons that if you've
listened to this podcast before if
you've heard me talk about before you
know that I'm constantly talking about
I'll probably go into the grave shouting
please get as much light exposure from
sunlight early in the day as possible
because it sets in motion a huge number
of things that are beneficial for your
mental health and physical health
including dopamine production timing
melatonin production correctly reducing
cortisol Peaks late in the day etc etc
so they asked them to get a lot of
outdoor light exposure they didn't give
them a specific amount where they said
maximize outdoor light exposure during
the mornings the time before noon and
again they had them waking up two to
three hours before their habitual
wake-up time they were also told and
this is very important if you're going
to shift your schedule earlier to try
and keep sleep wait times fixed
between their work days and their
weekends so not sleeping in on the
weekends or not having any sleep in days
regardless of how well they slept the
night before
how fixed within 15 to 30 minutes of
their
pre-designated time so if they were
waking up at seven o'clock one day they
set their alarm and they made sure they
got out of bed at seven o'clock every
day plus or minus 30 minutes but never
later than 7 30. never earlier than 6
30.
participants were also asked to try and
go to sleep two to three hours before
their habitual bedtime so again these
are people that want to stay up late
like 11 p.m perhaps but even as late as
1am or 2 A.M and now they are asked to
go to sleep two to three hours before
the habitual bedtime end to wake up two
to three hours earlier as I mentioned
earlier
they were also told and I love this
because it fits with many of the things
we've talked about on this podcast
before to try and limit light exposure
during the evenings dim the lights or
limit altogether artificial lights
lot of reasons for that I covered that
in the master sleep episode I covered
that in the optimize Health using light
episode you can find those at
hubermanlab.com they're asking them to
do that here and they ask participants
to keep a regular schedule for their
daily meals not eating on the hour
consistently you know at 9 00 a.m noon 3
P.M exactly but within again about 15 to
30 minutes
they're always eating at the same times
that was also important and again that's
because we have these so-called food and
trained circadian clocks when you eat
tells your body when to be alert and
when you're not eating when to be asleep
and they were told to not drink any
caffeine after 3 P.M in the afternoon
another theme that we've talked about on
this podcast they were also told not to
take naps after 4 pm naps are an
interesting feature of the sleep wake
cycle to be very brief about this and to
pull from the episode that I did with
World sleep expert from University of
California Berkeley Matt Walker naps are
great for many people but don't nap if
it interferes with your nighttime sleep
and in this study they told them don't
nap after 4 pm and if you are a napper
don't nap for more than 90 minutes 10
minute naps are fine 20 minute naps are
fine zero minute naps are fine but don't
nap for more than 90 minutes and don't
nap after 4 pm and to exercise during
the morning now this one can be a bit
contra virtual because I know a lot of
the pts out there and a lot of the
online you know gym rats and people who
and Runners too for that matter will say
well according to body temperature and
research it's best to exercise in the
afternoon look it's better to exercise
sometime as opposed to no time but if
you're focused on how to shift your
schedule earlier meaning get up early
and go to sleep earlier this study had
people exercise in the early part of the
day certainly before 2 pm and ideally
before noon so again this is a really
important study because it combines a
lot of different variables to arrive at
this very impressive shift where people
can get up two to three hours earlier
and then pretty consistently and
reflexively start going to bed two to
three hours earlier feeling more alert
during the day again improvements in
cognitive performance mood and physical
performance grip strength Etc very few
studies are able to or willing to tackle
so many variables and combine them in
one study this paper I think does a
marvelous job of doing this and it's
incorporating things that individually
each have some support for them in
animal studies and previous human
studies but as far as I know this is one
of the few studies that really combines
all these different features in one
place
eating times keeping those consistent
getting maximal sunlight exposure
earlier in the day getting up at a
consistent time going to sleep at a
consistent time and on and on it's a
really marvelous study for that reason
and I think for any of you that are
night owls and any of you that want to
reinforce your early waking and early to
bed times and I think for most all of
you who fall into that General middle
category of tend to go to sleep
somewhere between 10 pm and midnight
because that's most people and tend to
wake up sometime between 6 a.m and 8 am
well maybe you want to become more of an
early riser or maybe you're going to
travel or the seasons are changing and
you want to shift your time or you have
a new job Etc or something that's
actually very common in terms of
relationship struggle you want to match
your wake sleep times or maybe you want
to offset your wake sleep times from a
significant other
these sorts of approaches that I
described here and that are supported by
the data in this paper
are absolutely powerful and science
supported and I'm certain that if you
were to apply them that you would see
essentially the same effects that were
observed here the discovery of growth
mindset is worth thinking about so
Carol's Discovery was these kids that
for whatever reason
you know like doing math problems even
though they knew they couldn't get the
answers right these were sure fail
problems so it's the same kind of people
that like doing puzzles and these kids
not surprisingly go on to do
phenomenally well in a number of
different areas of academic Pursuit you
know but what's interesting about growth
mindset is that it seems like there's
some attachment of the reward systems of
the brain so the action or the pursuit
of a goal not just achieving a goal and
when we step back and we look at what
that really entails at a neurochemical
level we have reward systems in the
brain they generally fall into two
categories they're the reward systems
that make you feel really good with kind
of the here and now and everything
that's it within the confines of your
skin and the things you already have you
know love of your dog love of your
spouse gratitude for all the things you
happen to have and that and those are
generally governed by the release of
molecules like serotonin and oxytocin
okay but then there's another reward
system which is the one that drove a lot
of human evolution which is the dopamine
reward system now dopamine is a very
misunderstood molecule it's often talked
about only in the context of reward like
I'm going to work to this goal I'm going
to build my company I'm going to you
know get 10 years of press whatever it
is and you reach it and you get this
dopamine reward and indeed that's true
but what's often not discussed is that
dopamine is secreted enroute to rewards
while you pursue rewards now the ability
to tap into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals is an
absolute Game Changer when it comes to
things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this covered you know pandemic
situation the but the amazing thing is
remember the brain only does five things
and we get to decide which of those
Sensations and perceptions have
relevance and which ones don't or which
ones are attached to a goal and which
ones aren't so growth mindset in its
purest form is the attachment of these
reward systems to the effort process to
the friction process and not just to
obtaining a reward and just as a kind of
final point to that there's a very um
well-known body of literature and
Neuroscience at least among
neuroscientists that talks about
something called reward prediction error
and it says if you can dose the dopamine
subjectively as you go through the
pursuit of something and then have a lot
of dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger so the next time you
will revisit those sets of behaviors the
opposite can happen too where you're in
real anticipation of something this is
gonna be great this is gonna be great
this is gonna be great and then you
reach that goal and it's kind of
underwhelming and that generally
triggers this the circuit that I refer
to earlier this kind of disappointment
or pro-dopressive circuit so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards and
so as you reach a milestone or as you
tell yourself I'm on the right track
this friction I'm feeling this late
night this early morning this hard
conversation with somebody that doesn't
feel good I'm gonna tell myself this is
for a larger purpose that's that
subjective insertion that abstraction
that we were talking about earlier and
when you start releasing dopamine to
those kinds of things there's
essentially no limit on the number of
things you can do or the energy to do
them so just as a last last point about
dopamine when we're in effort we're
always secreting adrenaline we're always
in Pursuit and it's draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer adrenaline and you know this
you've experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team has depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke and all of a sudden in an
instant it's like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks it had to be
neurochemical it absolutely had to be
neurochemical and that neurochemical is
dopamine we've all heard the sayings you
know how do you you know Journey Of A
Thousand Miles starts with a single step
or how do you eat an elephant one bite
at a time or you know they're all these
sayings and and it goes back to the
Bible and earlier right I mean this is
not new these are not new sayings but
they're showing up in different forms
what's lost in those short descriptions
however is that every step is not
equivalent if it were just at a journey
of a Thousand Miles starts with a single
step everyone would pursue their goals
everyone would push back against
adversity everyone I mean you can read
the inspirational stories as many times
as one needs and I do think
inspirational stories are a very high
value in fact I think they're vicarious
dopamine I think they give us the sense
that we could which then Orient hope
which then orients us to the world to
start yeah maybe it's possible for me
that's right so let's say um let's take
the example of somebody who's
um okay there's a thing is that's that
story of it's not about just taking a
single step and one step at a time
is it because there's adversities every
10 steps you go and so it's harder and
harder it's not just well it's just very
non-linear you know it's it's some days
ago you know I know this from my
scientific career it's you know some
days it's easy some day is hard it's all
over the place right so I think the
thing to remember is that dopamine is
this incredibly powerful molecule that
allows us to buffer the effort process
it allows us to be an effort longer and
it allows us to actually eventually
enjoy the process of effort and not
think about the reward but just say oh
I'm enjoying the process right well you
just described the first step the first
step in learning to attach dopamine to
the effort process which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to be
very careful about how much you focus on
the end goal keeping the goal in mind is
important for like a proper orientation
you have to know the ultimate
destination but if at any point we were
to evaluate our progress relative to
that end goal or if we don't know what
the end goal is there's a huge gap there
and it can feel overwhelming and
depressing and I'm not good enough
that's where I should just give up what
am I doing this for that's right it's
thoughts will affect us and they're very
realistic right I mean as Carol will say
and other people have said in the
psychology field you know positive
self-talk oftentimes unless you do it
correctly you're badly wrong you know
lying to yourself won't work saying
saying I'm I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm
a winner or you haven't won yet is is
great but that's not the most effective
use of these systems well you're also
being out of Integrity with yourself
you're you're telling yourself a lie
right you're like and then you're losing
your ability to have confidence because
you just lined yourself right and if
it's really extreme there's a name for
it it's called delusional right right
and people will start to point that out
and then it becomes harder to recruit
people into your your goals so I think
the key thing is to attach that sense of
reward to the effort process it's saying
look
I am oriented in the right direction and
rewarding the things you're not doing
I'm not back on my heels I'm not just
staying you know I'm better anymore yeah
a good example of this came to me
recently I have a good friend he did
nine years in the SEAL Teams his name is
Pat dossett and and we were talking
about you know the Admiral mccraven
thing you know get up and make your bed
and you know and they they really do
that and I think the way it was
described was
um you know so at the end of the day
even if everything doesn't go well your
bed is still made for me that's not that
big of a reward frankly right but I and
so I said that and I I love it though I
make my bed oh I definitely made my bed
in the morning but I mean going back and
seeing that at the end of a hard day
it's not enough I felt like there was
something else there so I asked him he
said well it's very interesting because
part of it is about not just making your
bed but it's the things you're not doing
by making your bed you're not lying in
bed and ruminating you're not back on
your heels and on your phone that's
right yeah when so when you look at and
you have spent a lot of time with people
and High performing communities
mainly through some Consulting work but
what you find is that you know we can
all be either be back on our heels
flat-footed or forward Center romance
and when you look at people who are in
these high performance communities they
try and keep their Center of mass
forward
almost through what seemed like trivial
things like making your bed or making
the cup of coffee but it's not just
about what you're doing it's all the
things you're not doing interesting that
can put you down the path of ruminating
or put you down the path of
um unhealthy Behavior so the key to this
is if we want to be very concrete we
should probably focus on actions and
I'll use Fitness as an example because
it translates to everybody whereas you
know people's circumstances different
let's say somebody really wants to take
on a fitness routine they hate running
or they want to lose weight in a healthy
way this kind of thing so we've all
heard the example well you put your
shoes by the door on day one day two you
put them on day three you go out the
door day four you walk around the block
and then you know and then eventually
like they're running marathons okay
great but to sustain that behavior or
even to make the the behavior
pleasureful and to give you energy the
key is to subjectively reward those
steps so it's not going to be let's say
I go out and I run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mile the hard part you want to
tell yourself this is the good part this
is the part that gives me energy and
I'll be very surprised if people don't
actually feel like they could continue
further so it's a journey of a Thousand
Miles starts with a single is made up of
you know single steps but the key is to
reward the harder steps not the easier
ones and not the ones where you get the
thing that you want don't reward
yourself for putting your shoes on and
taking a step outside you could if that
was a huge barrier for you it was very
hard it was very hard for you running to
10 miles that's hard find the wall
and push a little bit further through
that wall and reward that process so
this is why I think reps in the gym the
final reps like reps to failure
are usually not the best example first
of all most people aren't doing reps to
failure and it doesn't translate to
young kids and stuff where they probably
shouldn't be doing heavy reps to failure
this kind of thing what you want however
is if you're going to go there to think
about these are the this is the hard
part because that's when adrenal and
norepinephrine are getting maxed out and
that's when you have an opportunity to
bring dopamine in and teach those neural
Pathways to slam that back down and
I don't want to um highlight them too
much because they are a very Niche and
specialized Community but you look at
people in Special Operations you look at
the
um process like the whole evaluation
process of who gets in and who doesn't
it's really about putting people into
stress and seeing who can not just make
it through that stress but buffer that
stress reward the process through
teamwork reward the process of stress
through some internal dialogue that has
everything to do with not being back on
your heels not being flat footed but
Center of mass forward and I should also
be clear I'm not talking about everybody
being super aggro and always like you
know work work yeah in fact if you're
spending too much epinephrine if you're
too much of an adrenaline junkie you
will burn out eventually unless you can
find ways to recover yourself or to
buffer that with dopamine and the
recovery process is especially important
there's a second reward system so you've
got the dopamine system and I guess to
really put a box around it
the subjective reward needs to be done
at the hardest portion of a process the
tough conversation with a significant
other it's like when it's really tough
and you want you just that's when you
want to start telling yourself this is
the this is the good part because I'm
not speaking or this is the good part
because because I think right I'm not
reacting or this is the good part
because I'm probably not doing it
correctly but I'm on the right path
right
um they're upset they're not feeling
your empathy you know this kind of thing
or you're not really understanding
what's going on you're getting
frustrated but if you tell yourself this
is this is the neural pathway getting
ground in there like it really dialed in
so that the the next time this I'm going
to Breeze right past this that's really
how the process works because dope
remember no one comes along and drips
dopamine in your ear even if you get a
billion dollars or you win a Nobel Prize
or you win the presidency it's all
internal these neurochemicals are all
internal and while some of them are
designed to be released in response to
things very reflexively like um you know
food sex sleep you know all these things
will trigger these neurochemicals we
have this big forebrain which allows us
to place subjective context on things we
are in many ways defined by the by the
competitions that will that we will
Embrace and whether or not that
competition is with you know
um mental material like books and
studying or whether or not it's physical
competition we need external influences
like I think we these days we're so
attracted to the idea that we can you
know control everything from the inside
but you need human interaction uh it's
absolutely necessary and I think that
um you know it sort of Harkens back to
the story at the beginning it's like all
the the stress and that I was going
through in those years I mean it
absolutely made me better right
absolutely maybe I wouldn't trade it for
anything I don't wish hardship on people
but humans are remarkable in their
ability to step into Challenge and to
meet challenge you know I think that
there's this important and very very
serious conversation now about mental
health right the number of people
suffering is just tremendous but I think
that we also are forgetting that you
know that suffering process is is it's a
jumping off point right and
now I've had a number of friends commit
suicide I understand just how you know
that's that's a horrible tragedy and
depression is absolutely terrible but
there's also this question of you know
sort of like what is our expectation
about our mood right like we're so what
do we really what are we really trying
to achieve with our moods and so I
always say you know there are five
things that embody our whole existence
it's like our Sensations what we feel
our emotions our perceptions our
thoughts and our actions that's pretty
much it and of all of those the emotions
are the most mysterious it's like it's
kind of a combination of perception and
thoughts you know you can control your
behavior you can control your thoughts
people often forget this but your
thoughts are your choice right I'm not
saying you can suppress thoughts I think
there's been a lot of attention on
trying to learn how to suppress thinking
I've never been able to suppress
thinking ever but what I can do is
introduce new thoughts actually Stephen
pressfield who wrote The War of art
brilliant author and ex-military guy he
he really I think he said something like
you know he was like in his mid-40s
before where he had his first real
thought and what I like to think he was
referring to was the first time that he
realized that you could actually
introduce a thought that thoughts aren't
just all spontaneous so they can be
deliberate you know your Sensations you
can control by your environment and your
perceptions are largely about kind of
like what sends you you know your
thoughts about what you sense right but
your feelings I think we overvalue
feelings and here I'm going to come
across as you know kind of a hardened
male and about this I you know I would
place myself actually kind of on the
wide emotionality scale but I've learned
over the years that emotions are just
kind of a mishmash of perception and
thought I think we over we overvalue
their utility and this is just my
opinion I don't have any scientific data
to support it but I also don't even know
how you study emotions in the lab every
time I see a laboratory that claims they
study emotions they're studying Behavior
every time there's it's I you know
people are talking about fear and about
courage they're talking about a behavior
that's measured we don't know what these
animals feel you know the foggiest I
don't know what you feel right now I
barely understand what I feel right now
so I think that as a species we've been
and in terms of mental mental health
we've been over focused on feelings and
I think we need to think more carefully
about physiology I think we're kind of
in the physiology movement right now
where people are realizing wow you know
these drugs these like the opioid crisis
really impact our physiology and
therefore our emotions and people are
are stricken it's really terrible when
you start thinking about things like
growth mindset in terms of how they
convert to neurochemical signatures it
leads us to this place of okay if it's
all subjective then you know if I just
say look I'm going to stand up out of my
chair and and that's going to feel
amazing is that going to work well no it
depends on the meaning that I attach to
something and this and this subjective
part can be a little tricky and a little
bit hard for people so I want to try and
lay it out in a in a concrete way so
that if they want to apply this they can
incidentally or not so incidentally I
should say when you look at communities
of very high performers and I'm
fortunate enough to do some Consulting
with some people from Special Forces
communities and so forth they're very
good as are you at attaching a reward to
specific behaviors in subjective ways so
growth mindset and these dopamine
rewards that we subjectively apply are
not about saying oh you know I had a
terrible day I performed poorly but you
know what it's great I just feel great
anyway it's not about that it's not
about attaching your sense of reward to
the ultimate goal it's about attaching
your sense of reward to the fact that
you're making action steps that are
generally in the right direction the
more you can reward the effort process
the better off you are at building these
kinds of neural circuits and these kind
of Tendencies to be able to lean into
anything challenging over essentially
any duration so how does this work like
how would somebody do this right well
keeping in mind that adrenaline and
epinephrine are all great for getting us
into action this is Mother Nature's Way
of chemically making us feel kind of
agitated remember stress was designed to
agitate us to move us away from things
and toward things but realizing that
that's a a limited resource that
eventually that same chemical is what
makes you have a negative mindset it
feels painful it's the burn in your body
it's uncomfortable and realizing that
dopamine can push back on that
neurochemically it can suppress those
sensations of wanting to quit you say
well then how do I get this dopamine to
work for me before I hit a goal because
not every day is going to be a real win
there's some days I mean I know from my
science career there were days that were
really hard experiments didn't work
papers got rejected and yet you know
I've spent two decades or more just
drilling on and drilling on and it's
been a sheer pleasure at times but
there's been you know some pain points
along the way so what is this process
really about and how would somebody
Implement these dopamine and epinephrine
type nor chemical events in their own
life well we all know the example of
like wanting to run a marathon I've
never run a marathon but
um that'd be a nice goal to have let's
say tomorrow morning I set my shoes near
the door now a lot of people have talked
about this day one you set your shoes
near the door day two you go out the
door day three you run around the block
day four but the key thing is not just
to go through the actions but when you
hit each one of those self-designated
Milestones the Milestones that you're
setting out for yourself you have to
pause for a moment
and tell yourself I'm heading in the
right direction I haven't run the
marathon yet but this is the foundation
upon which I'm going to lay another
Foundation upon which I'm going to lay
another foundation and those little
pulses of dopamine allow you to get that
action step without the depletion that
it would normally bring otherwise you're
just like you're spending money this is
like replenishing this bank account that
you have and it's a neural bank account
and so dopamine is the is the thing that
you can control the dosing of and so if
you say today it's my shoes at the door
but tomorrow it's around the block and
that's it but that's in the direction I
want to go what you do is you now get
those two events plus the next day the
mile long run and so forth without it
depleting you it actually builds this
capacity to build more reward and this
is what you've done this is what people
from elite special forces can do they
know how to make small
simple
physical steps in the real world that
allow them to build on these reward
circuitries but they don't get
delusional about how they're doing they
they know they keep the end in mind but
they get very micro they move the
Horizon in very close and so if you can
move the Horizon to something you know
you can complete and you reward that you
essentially are where you were before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go you're not depleting you're
not spending out anything and it feels a
little weird because none of us like to
reward things that aren't external but
the ability to control these internal
reward schedules is everything learning
is a two-stage process and the learning
I'm referring to is specifically
deliberate learning you know children
are learning passively all the time
they're taking in new information their
brain is it's not a complete Tabler also
it's not a complete Blank Slate there's
some hardwired functions they show up
with thank goodness like breathing like
heart rate uh heart controlling heart
rate but that helps I mean you know
offload as much as you can to the
genetic Pro program to hardwire the
nervous system so they can learn how to
walk and walking is a good example a a
kid learns how to walk and then walks
reflexively but of course at any stage
you can think about how you're walking
you can do Hopscotch it means you have
to change your Cadence of jumping and
walking right so that's this uh flexible
transition between voluntary and
involuntary movement but you have to
learn how to walk and so but what we're
talking about now is generally
deliberate learning language learning
skill learning learning knowledge of any
kind
um learning how to you know navigate the
emotional dynamics of a relationship
anything
two phases one is active engagement and
focus uh much of the trigger for
neuroplasticity is a process is engaged
by dopamine and norepinephrine and a
molecule called acetylcholine which is
liberated from multiple sources that we
always talked about how acetylcholine
controls the the contraction of muscles
but in the brain acetylcholine is mainly
comes from two sets of neurons one in
the brain stem and another in the basal
forebrain and it serves as a kind of a
highlighter marking particular
connections or neurons that later stand
a chance to become stronger so let me
give an example
I don't speak a second language but
let's say I decided I was going to learn
conversational French I would learn some
nouns or some verbs I would I would
focus on this and the greater degree of
focus that I bring the greater amount of
acetylcholine is released
at that time and at the particular
locations in the brain they're involved
in enunciating the words and writing the
comprehension you know multiple spots
within the brain that kind of marks
those or Flags those areas as
potentially
changing later but the actual rewiring
of the nervous system happens during
states of deep sleep or sleep-like
states and so so when we say
neuroplasticity the brain's ability to
change in response to experience that's
a two-part process it's a process it's
not an event we always think about
things as events but in biology almost
everything is a process so the the
takeaway from this is in order to learn
at any age the most critical thing is
that you bring as much focus and active
engagement to the learning the the
encoding of the information bringing in
the information and then that you get
into a state of deep rest as quickly as
possible typically that would be the
night after you learn after you have
this trigger but there are some
beautiful studies published in cell
reports last year and the year before
showing that people who take a 20-minute
nap within the four hours after these uh
triggering learning or people that do a
non-sleep deep rest type protocol even
just sitting there quietly and not doing
anything they learn much faster in other
words the brain rewires much faster
interesting it's very interesting and
what's happening is very interesting
we've long known that during sleep
there's a replay of the neurons in the
same sequence that they were played
during the activity in the earlier in
that day sometimes even backwards for
some reason that it's like the songs
played backwards at night who knows why
I don't think we should focus too much
on that right now
but that replay is the consolidation of
the information you learn this is why
you try something physically try it
physically you can't do it you can't do
and then you come back a week later and
voila you can do it you had the
opportunity to change the neural
circuits so that now you can do it I
would hide in the tower books section uh
in the evenings and I would read
everything about Fitness psychology
anything I could I've always devoured
information my favorite book when I was
a kid was the encyclopedia or the
Guinness book of Worlds Records so I was
like when I was a little kid I'd walk
around the Aspen Center for physics and
I would tell anyone I didn't even ask
them if they want to hear about like the
what's the world's smallest etherean
mammal you know I would like you could
tell you all these facts that were kind
of meaningless at the time but
um I've always been fascinated by the
inventory of different animals on the
planet and their different behaviors and
so yeah voracious reader and still now
yeah I love I love information we have
these so-called receptors in the eyes
and the ears and the nose and the mouth
on the skin that take physical entities
in the in the universe that a real fixed
non-negotiable things like sound waves
and photons of light and chemicals in
the environment traveling that make it
into our nose and things like that and
convert those into the second thing
which is perceptions so the nervous
system's responsibility is to take those
Sensations which are non-negotiable and
perceive certain ones and not others so
for instance right now until I say you
know what's the sensation of your feet
contacting the floor or the bottoms of
your shoes you weren't thinking about it
but those pressure receptors were being
engaged the entire time so your
perception is like a window or a
spotlight that's very much linked to
attention then there are emotions often
called feelings
and those are really designed to push us
down particular Avenues of perception
and the next thing which are thoughts
Okay so we've got sensation perception
feelings and then there are thoughts
which really have a lot to do with what
we're perceiving and the way we're
organizing those perceptions what they
mean and generally that's put into the
context of what we already know or
memories and then the fifth thing is
behaviors
or actions and of course neurons are
responsible for generating actions and
they're really two kinds of actions
they're the actions that you generate
reflexively like your breathing and your
heart rate right now are largely
reflexive or you could decide troll of
your respiration and be make it
voluntary right and not just reflexive
so those five things Sensations
perceptions feelings thoughts and
actions really Encompass all of our life
experience and that's from the very
mundane of getting up in the morning and
brushing her teeth to the most
awe-inspiring uh goal motivated uh
Pinnacle moments of your life the
nervous system not the immune system not
the digestive system all of which are
important but the nervous system meaning
the brain spinal cord and the
connections with the body and the
connections from the body back to the
brain and spinal cord are responsible
for all of that and as a just a final
point the nervous system is also
responsible for telling the immune
system something that's very relevant
right now in this covet pandemic when to
be active you know we don't often think
about the immune system as governed by
anything but it's actually governed by
the nervous system everything that
happens to you your entire experience I
don't care what anyone says I don't care
what alignment the Earth is in
everything is happening because your
brain has these three jobs and all of
your experiences filtered through that
thing in your head that pile of cells
that's arranged in a very specific way
that we're still trying to understand
called your brain just like we could be
talking about the heart whose job is to
pump blood so I want to describe just
how the brain works in three basic ways
two of which you've heard about before
we all have heard the lizard brain the
thing that freaks you out when you think
there's someone standing in the corner
and they turn on the light there's
nobody or if you were to come up on a
car wreck and all of a sudden your
heart's pumping your brain is very good
at that stuff and that's great that's
why you're alive at this moment it is an
unerring unfailing system keeping you
alive your lizard brain and it's
generally designed to keep you alive and
to scare you from doing things that
would hurt you it's a shame because I
would have liked it to be generally good
at making me feel good all the time but
that's generally not what it's good at
and I'm stealing from the great Tony
Robbins who says you know there's paved
roads to fear and misery and Cobblestone
or dirt roads to happiness and that's
true at the level of neuroanatomy you
don't have a whole lot of your brain
devoted to happiness you got a lot of
your brain designed to keep you safe so
anxieties and fears come about a lot
easier you need to combat those we're
all getting better at that thinking
planning imagining and doing is the
other kind of end of the spectrum I
talked about that and then there's the
one that really counts right which is
this thing in the middle which is the
way that those things are connected what
do you think depends on how you feel
what you feel depends on how you think
we know this now this kind of common
knowledge and it's these maps of your
experience it depends on what happened
to you and how you view the world and we
know this at a psychological level
neuroscientists sometimes talk like this
they often don't I'm in the minority but
there's a lot of neuroanatomy there's a
lot of powerful Neuroscience to support
this what do I mean by your maps of
experience I mean what happened to you
shapes how you view the world and so
what's important is how you change how
you view the world if you want to go
forward beyond what would just how you
were programmed let's say the brain is
basically designed to be customized in
the early part of life and then to
implement those algorithms and that
circuitry for the rest of your of its
life and so the brain can change in
adulthood and it can change provided
that there's an emphasis on some
perceptual event so in other words if
you want to change your brain as an
adult let's say you want to be less
anxious you want to learn a new language
you want to be more functional in some
way presumably
the key thing is to bring Focus to some
particular perception of something
that's happening during the learning
process and the reason for that is that
there's a neurochemical system involving
acetylcholine and it comes from these
two little nuclei down in the base of
the brain called nucleus basalus
all day long you're doing things in a
reflexive way
but when you do something and you think
about it very intensely acetylcholine is
released from basalis at the precise
neurons that were involved in that
behavior and it marks those for change
during sleep or during deep rest later
so for people that want to change their
brain the power of focus is really the
entry point and the ability to access
deep rest and sleep because most people
don't realize this but neuroplasticity
is triggered by intense Focus
but neuroplasticity occurs during deep
sleep and rest one of the things that's
really important also think about how
the brain works in terms of plasticity
and all this stuff is what the brain
really wants to do is also pass as much
of what it does after reflexive Behavior
as possible so yeah so when we're
talking about Focus I think it can get a
little bit vague but it might be useful
thing about like what exactly is focus
and what triggers plasticity so the
brain loves to be able to just do things
pick up coffee cups and drink and walk
and talk and do things and not put much
energy into it when we decide to focus
what the brain really does is it
switches on a set of circuits that
involve the frontal cortex and nucleus
basalus and some others and it's trying
to understand duration how long
something's going to last path what's
going to happen an outcome what
ultimately is going to happen so
duration path and outcome you know the
the events of early 2020 are a good
example of this one of the reasons why
it's so exhausting to be alive in 2020
is because we are now having to pay
attention to duration path and outcome
how long is this thing going to last
winter
you know when are they going to open up
all businesses did I touch that door
handle does it matter you know right who
are the experts are there any experts
you know there are a lot of questions
whereas normally we can just move
through life without having to do all
that analysis
so if it's a simple example like trying
to learn a new language or a new motor
skill or a new way of conceptualizing
something maybe somebody's in a
therapeutic process and they're trying
to work through a trauma or something
like that duration path and outcome
is built into the networks of the brain
we can do that very easily but it takes
work and it almost has a feeling of
underlying agitation and frustration and
that's because the circuits that turn on
before acetylcholine are of the stress
system so when you or I decide we're
going to learn something and really dig
in
norepinephrine which is adrenaline is
secreted in the brain stem and in the
body and it brings about a state of
alertness then our attention which is
mostly a diffuse light is brought to a
particular duration path in outcome
analysis this would be thinking about
what somebody is saying what are they
really trying to say a hard passage of
reading a hard you know set of math
problems you know a challenging physical
workout
when you do that these two systems have
to work very hard and the adult brain
doesn't really want to change the
algorithms it learned in childhood but
if you do those two things you have
alertness and focus the acetylcholine
and the norepinephrine converge to Mark
those synapses for Change and so so the
way to think about neuroplasticity if
one wants to change their brain is bring
about the most intense concentration you
can to something
and then later bring about the least
amount of concentration of that thing
trauma needs to be dealt with hopefully
with a professional but we can all apply
these mechanisms and these neurochemical
reward schedules there's a classic study
where researchers not my lab put two
rats or you could do this with mice into
a tube and the tendency is for them to
try and push one or the other one out
one always wins and pushes the other one
out we call the one that got pushed out
the loser the one that pushed him out
the winner
here are the interesting things about
this first of all the winner
will tend to win with other in other
battles even though these are just
pushing battles more because it simply
won the time before the loser by losing
will tend to lose and so people say oh
well that explains a lot about Society
Etc well here's where it gets really
interesting you can even take a mouse or
a rat and push it from behind and make
it the winner and then on subsequent
trials where you're not pushing it it
will tend to win more often so the wind
doesn't even have to come from itself so
last year there was a very important
paper published about this where a set
of researchers just said well what is it
like what is this winning circuit and
this losing circuit enough with the
demonstration that this happens like
what's happening on what's under the
hood and so they went into the brain and
they identified
a brain area which is part of the
frontal cortex the area that we
typically think about planning action
executive function all the kind of high
level stuff and what they discovered was
this brain area is more active in the
winter
than in the loser in fact they could
take the loser and over stimulate this
area and turn the losers into winners
now it gets even more ridiculous than
that if you quiet this brain area
winners become losers okay and and if
you take a winner and let's say at this
tube battle and you put them into let's
say a cold environment with a bunch of
other mice and you have just a warm
Corner mice don't like to be cold and
you say who gets the warm corner right
who gets the luxury spot it's always the
winner so it even breaks down at the
level of social interactions and so you
say okay all right now we know that
cisbrainer it's this it's this one area
of the frontal cortex but what's it
actually doing right okay what's it
actually Tran what how can we translate
this turns out this brain area that's
responsible and required for winning in
this series of experiments is actually
driving up the level of activation what
you and I would call agitation or stress
to the point where that animal is more
likely to move forward it's simply
taking stress which is wired into us in
order to make us feel agitated instead
of suppressing us you know instead of
saying you know I'm just going to sit
here I'm overwhelmed I'm not going to
I'm just going to move into action so
there's a circuit for winning there's a
the same circuit when it's
hypoactive not active enough is what
causes losing in these competitive
scenarios and similarly there's a
circuit for quitting there's an a
norepinephrine circuit in the brain stem
this was published in the last couple
years showing that when animals or
people are in constant effort eventually
that level of norepinephrine gets so
high that it triggers a circuit that
shuts down the motor control over the
limbs and you just say that's it I give
up I'm done so these mechanisms were
hardwired into us we all have them
whether or not it's from Evolution
Mother Nature God the universe it is
it's irrelevant to the discussion that
these circuits exist in everybody and I
think it's a select few people who
really understand that forward action
is what drives these circuits it's the
ability to take that agitation stress
agitation increase our focus and they
bias us for movement and nature wanted
that they want us to move forward in the
face of challenge not to be quiescent we
weren't sitting around battling tigers
and sabertooth tigers all the time more
likely we were in caves and we were
getting hungry and we had to go out and
search for things agitation and stress
were designed to get us up and move us
and when we try and fight that too much
and we try and quiet that stress
that actually can be problematic you
have to decide are you going to try and
quiet stress or are you going to
actually lean into action that's a
critical Choice point for everybody
who's experienced anything negative or
positive for that matter
the Mind plays an important role in
interpreting whether or not it's
overwhelming or tolerable so intense
breathing like tumor breathing or ice
baths or cold showers or intense
exercise like you know high intensity
interval training type stuff
teaches the mind to be comfortable in
these higher stress states where in
other words it teaches people to be
comfortable when they have a lot of
adrenaline in their body this is like
this is basically stress inoculation but
stress inoculation is not about not
getting stressed it's actually about
divorcing the mind-body relationship a
bit so that you're calm in the mind when
your body is very Amplified yeah so if
you've ever done tumotype breathing or
you've done a cold shower the goal is to
get the adrenaline release the nervous
system is designed to orchestrate all
the processes in the body not just
thinking and not just behavior and
really can be divided into five things
so there's sensation
and sensation is really bound or
restricted by The receptors in the body
so receptors in the eye that perceive
photons light energy receptors in the
skin that perceive pressure you know
touch receptors smell taste appearing
Etc
and the interesting thing about
sensation and the fact that the nervous
system needs to pay attention to
sensation is it's non-negotiable
the nervous system of humans is designed
to extract physical phenomenon from the
universe that are non-negotiable photons
of light I can't see in the infrared
with my eyes and I can't see ultraviolet
light with my eyes I can't perceive that
because I don't have the receptors for
it
so you know other animals can perceive
some of those things but that leads us
to the next thing which is perception
which is which Sensations are you paying
attention to so all the time you're
sensing things like right now your feet
are sensing the contact with your shoes
but you're not thinking about it until I
say that and then you shift your
perception right so perception is like
the spotlight so the brain wants to
constantly bring in sensation it's
non-negotiable what's coming in it's
just depending on your environment
perception is negotiable you can control
that because I just said shoes and you
thought about your feet and there you
are
then there are feelings which can be a
little bit nebulous but feelings are a
link between our emotion and it
generally invokes The Body Sensations in
the body and Concepts in the mind of
what those Sensations are about that's
really what emotions are animals
definitely experience them I'm kind of
appalled to think that 10 years ago
people like do it animals have emotions
of course they have emotions right
because those are bodily Sensations
merged with some perception so of course
they do and then there's thoughts and
thoughts are interesting because
thoughts happen spontaneously think
about like a web browser that's
constantly giving you pop-ups but
thoughts can also be deliberate so you
and I can decide right now that we're
going to think about a plan for
something or we're going to think about
what's going on in the world so thoughts
happen spontaneously and they can be
deliberate and then the final thing is
behaviors and actions so the nervous
system is responsible for sensation
perception feelings thoughts and
behaviors
and what's interesting we start to think
about that as you're like okay that's a
lot but what is the nervous system
really trying to accomplish like on any
given day or at any moment What's it
trying to accomplish and it's really
trying to accomplish one thing which is
to take
perceptions of the outside world
and merge those with perceptions of the
inside world what we call interoception
and to link those in a way that's
operating on our environment in the
appropriate way so what do I mean by
that so if I'm feeling anxious and I'm
in a very calm environment I'm going to
perceive that rapid heart rate and kind
of feeling of agitation in my body as
inappropriate for the moment right and
my goal then as a as an organism is to
adjust my my level of what they call
autonomic arousal or alertness down if
I'm at a at a great party or I'm at a
wedding or it's a celebration or I'm at
a protest or you know
um then I might feel that my level of
alertness is appropriate for my
environment so the nervous system is in
this constant Dynamic interaction with
the outside world and trying to figure
that out one way and this can be kind of
conceptualized is there's an emerging
idea that's kind of interesting about
impatience
so we've all had the feeling of being
impatient some people are far more
patient than others but if you've ever
been in line at the store and you feel
like something's going very slowly you
know the person in front of you is
taking a long time they're doing some
returns here getting kind of impatient
maybe breathing in a mask and you're
like oh like you're you know
what's the idea is that if you're
getting a certain frequency of Pulses
from your body and if those pulses are
coming in quickly like you're perceiving
your yourself that interoception quickly
it's like pulse pulse pulse pulse you're
going to be more geared towards your
internal representation and then you're
seeing what's going on in the outside
world and it seems like it's going very
slowly but there are other times when
you're in line at the store someone's
getting some returns and you're texting
on your phone or you've had a great day
you've had a great run your family's in
great shape and you're fine why well the
frequency of those pulses that
enteroception is matched pretty well to
your outside environment and so
impatience is really when you're in
internal sort of metronome
is not matched well to the external
environment
there are other times when you're
feeling like your internal metronome is
tick
and you've got a million things coming
at you through email or text you've got
a bunch of things and you're feeling
overwhelmed and tired well in either
case there's nothing right or wrong it's
just your body and your brain are trying
to say what's going on in the outside
world and how well matched am I to it
right so
if you think about some of the the sort
of core practices of mindfulness and
self-regulation of like focusing on
breathing or focusing on on you know
state of mind a lot of that is trying to
bring more awareness to your internal
state
but what our brain is normally doing
when our eyes are open and we're
interacting the world is we're
constantly trying to update our internal
state to match external demands of the
world and this Harkens back to it you
know like a really early design of all
nervous systems which is how do you take
an organism that needs certain things
food water mates reproduction shelter
how do you move that organism how do you
create a system that will do that in
best relation to the environment and so
what Mother Nature has done is designed
a CIS a series of systems
let's just take agitation and stress for
one if an animal or human is very
thirsty you feel kind of agitated you
might get up and get a drink of water if
you're very thirsty it can put you into
a state of panic if you're extremely
thirsty and water is a limited resource
you might even result to violence to get
it or negotiation of some sort that you
wouldn't if you were calmer so the
stress and agitation were designed to
actually mobilize the body to take us in
the direction of something that's
adaptive so you can start to see these
kind of core elements of
what the brain and nervous system do
sensation perception feeling thought and
action and this
constant challenge of trying to match
our internal state to the external real
estate the outside world and you start
to see that the sensations that we call
stress or impatience or calm are really
the result of that those attempts that
the nervous system is trying to perform
I'm a big fan of wellness and and I
think it's a great Community but it
tends to run in absolutes and there and
there aren't a lot of operational
definitions as we say in science and I
what I love about your questions you're
asking for really getting to the meat of
things asking for the operational
definitions one of the most dangerous
ideas in wellness and in popular
psychology is that your body hears every
thought you have what a terrible thing
to put on people you know what what a
challenging thing I don't think people
should try and suppress their negative
thoughts I think there is Great Value
however to introducing positive thought
schemes now the reason is not because I
think it's just because I think so but
because there's actually a neurochemical
basis for controlling stress and
actually making stress more taller
horrible and extending one's ability to
be in bouts of effort and that relates
to the dopamine pathway so the molecule
dopamine is a reward it's released in
the brain when you win a game you you
know close a deal
like your photo the great love of your
life you complete something but most of
our dopamine release is not from
achieving goals it's actually released
when we are in route to our goals where
we're in pursuit of our goals and we
think we're on the right path one
meditation very short five minutes where
for one breath one breath you close your
eyes and go internal and you get behind
and some people call it the third eye
right I'm going to get the the language
wrong but we all know what we're talking
about you get inside your breath and
then the second thing you do is you
focus on something at a short distance
there's a powerful system in your brain
when you focus both eyes on a single
point like a watchmaker making a watch
or you're reading that state is
accessing very specific channels in your
brain that are very different from the
one that when you close your eyes okay
and it's called a virgin's eye movement
when you put both your eyes on the same
thing and then the last one is the one
that we get a lot of here that feeling
awesome feeling when you go out to the
beach or you're on the top of a mountain
or you look at the horizon or you arrive
in New York City if you're me and you
just go oh my God and you're defocused
and that's when you're these ideas the
creativity it's kind of spontaneously
geysers Up From Below but then you have
to get back and you need to get to work
on something and so the what's been very
powerful and we're going to put we're
putting patients through this or
subjects in brain Imaging is this way of
accessing all these different brain
States is really about accessing
different Notions of space and time
trying to get access to your whole brain
and it's a short meditation I recommend
just one breath that each of these kind
of stations in your mind up close and
focusing on your hand and out and I'll
repeat that a few times during my
morning or maybe once or twice during
the day it's quick and we're getting
remarkable feedback
from the people who are doing this about
the kind of state that it puts them in
both engaged and present with the bigger
picture and in the end it's all about
the bigger picture right because it's
about not just what you do with your
life but how you're going to create good
in the world for any of us success in
any Endeavor is very closely related to
how much Focus we can bring to that
endeavor and the reward system you start
to realize is entirely internal no one's
coming along and cramming dopamine in
your ear or dripping it in your brain
it's all internal and this starts to
bring us into the kind of like
discussion around mindsets because so my
colleague Carol dweck who you know
popularized the same growth mindset it's
again a very misunderstood concept it's
the idea that we can change so that's
built into that but the discovery of
growth mindset was of these kids that
actually really enjoyed doing problem
sets that they knew they couldn't get
right but for them they would get this
like dopamine release from just focusing
on the problem they like doing puzzles
they couldn't get right it sounds crazy
but inevitably those kids are very good
at puzzles and very good at math and
these kinds of things so growth mindset
is I believe it was sort of a neuro
Neuroscience lens on growth mindset
would be that the agitation and stress
that you feel at the beginning of
something and when you're trying to lean
into it you can't focus is just a
recognized gate you have to pass that
through that gate to get to the folk
component and then if you can reward the
effort process you really start to feel
Joy when low levels of excitement in the
effort process that's that buffering of
adrenaline that's that feeling like yes
I've got a lot of adrenaline in my
system but I'm on the right path it
feels good to walk up this hill so to
speak and when you start to bring those
neural circuits together
you really start to create a whole set
of circuits that are designed to be
exported to any Behavior you want so if
it's writing a book great if it's
podcasting great if it's building a
business great if it's if it's you know
building a terrific relationship great
then the circuits that Mother Nature's
design are incredibly generic so that we
could adapt to whatever it is that we
need to do and I think the
misunderstanding around how these
circuits work has led to this idea that
there's some secret entry point maybe
marked flow on the door and there's a
trampoline up to that door and you just
open that door and you're going to be in
it right and nothing could be further
from the truth and anyone who's done
well in any career or athletic Pursuit
knows this but unfortunately there's a
kind of obsession with the idea that
it's all supposed to feel good and it
does feel good but there's a whole
staircase in which it feels kind of
lousy we can be driven from a place of
anger frustration and and you know
revenge or we can be driven from a place
of you know love gratitude and Etc I'm
not here to judge which one is better or
worse but the nervous system doesn't
distinguish between them so if you're
the kind of person that needs to you
know kind of budge yourself into
something great great if you're the kind
of person that wants to do things from
more of a warm fuzzy feeling that's fine
too what I will say is this the ability
to tap into this dopamine reward system
which is activated anytime you're in
pursuit of something that's outside the
boundaries of your skin and literally
the boundaries of your body as well as
the reward system the serotonin oxytocin
system which is really about the things
that are contained within your own body
and immediate experience things like
gratitude and you know touch and comfort
and things like that with loved ones the
ability to tap into both is crucial now
you said something really important
which was well negative thoughts
negative thoughts what to do I don't
believe that it's very easy to suppress
negative thoughts however when you
realize that thoughts can be
deliberately introduced you can start
replacing negative thoughts with new
types of thoughts so you can always add
something in but when people start to
realize that thoughts are very much like
physical actions of reaching and picking
up a glass of water or taking a jog
around the ball block or typing an email
perfectly this is something I sometimes
do because I'm I you know I struggle to
do the perfect email not all my emails
are perfect but when I do one I make
sure that I I complete and I think okay
it's possible it's not because the email
being perfect is so important it's
because I want to remind myself that my
thoughts and my actions are essentially
the same the nervous system can organize
thoughts so for somebody that's
struggling
you know we have these examples like oh
they were really back on their heels or
they were so depleted no money and all
this stuff what are they gonna we we
have so many examples like that but in
trying to make it actionable it's really
about saying yep that's all true
but I'm going to introduce a thought
which is I made it through today I'm I
made it through today and that's
actually worth celebrating at a micro
level so if you can give yourself
dopamine rewards in small increments
right you're not trying to celebrate
that you made it through one day
sometimes that's a huge feat but most of
the time you just want to dose yourself
with a little bit of that internal
release of dopamine you start rewarding
incremental steps and if there's
anything that your listeners could take
away from this whole thing about
dopamine and reward schedules and being
in movement it's reward incremental
steps in particular incremental steps
that are about forward action so maybe
that's writing an email maybe that's
um maybe that's that run around the
block maybe that's something much
grander for you as you get better at
things right the stairs get further and
further away from one another because
you've achieved more success and so they
tend to be you have to take the rungs on
the ladder further apart so to speak
that's a time when you really need to
implement not only the dopamine rewards
but also so those serotonin and oxytocin
rewards Etc so to make it actionable I
would say remember don't spend so much
time trying to suppress negative
thoughts if you need trauma therapy
pursue that with a professional but if
you have negative thoughts just remember
I can also introduce positive thoughts
the same way I can control running
around the block positive thoughts are
the equivalent of forward physical
action and if you reward them internally
you buffer yourself against the quitting
circuit this norepinephrine circuit we
were talking about before you are
building a stronger version of yourself
completely between your own ears and
some people say well that's silly it's
like you're saying oh I'm going to jump
up and down reward myself for doing
nothing no you're building the neural
circuits that reward that you can
control self-reward and in doing that
you can push through days and weeks of
effort consistently I don't mean
necessarily all-nighters but you can
push and push and push you know my
career is one that was made over two
decades it wasn't we had our big you
know Peaks and we added a lot of alleys
but learning to control these rewards is
absolutely key and I know you've done
this too Tom it's like you know it the
huge wins are great but it's really
about rewarding these increments so you
can keep going another 30 another 40
years I have a colleague his name is
David Spiegel and our department of
Psychiatry at Stanford and he and I have
a collaboration going now looking at how
respiration or breathing can be used to
shift the brain into different states
and I've talked to David about this and
so I'm sort of borrowing from his words
here so I want to be fair that these are
from those conversations so hypnosis
inevitably involves relaxing the nervous
system taking the nervous system into
states that are more like sleep now what
I mean by that is in high alert states
where you're talking and planning and in
action and stress in particular the
brain is very linear it's saying okay if
this then this if then then that this is
why we tend to be Forward Thinking when
we're when we're stressed we tend to be
not in our immediate experience but
really kind of forward thinking so
clinical hypnosis involves
going into a state of deeper relaxation
so that our analysis of space and time
meaning the way that the brain is
perceiving events is slightly
dismantled so that it's a little bit
dreamlike and then the hypnotist and
this could be by listening to a script
or listening to a hypnotherapist
starts to narrow our context take our
thoughts if you will it down a
particular path and that path could be
one of
um stress reduction or a smoking
cessation
um hypnosis is incidentally is very good
for treatment of smoking cessation or
for feelings of well-being or
confronting traumas so what it is is
it's really opening up the window for
neuroplasticity which is of course the
brain's ability to change in response to
experience to trigger neuroplasticity
you have to have Focus especially as an
adult you need acetylcholine released
but high levels of attention
acetylcholine and norepinephrine
together norepinephrine to create that
sense of urgency and acetylcholine to
bring that Spotlight of focus in really
really tight that triggers plasticity
but the actual it marks certain synapses
in the brain for change but the actual
changes in the synapses the rewiring
okay that happens during states of sleep
and deep rest so this is why when you're
trying to learn a motor skill you go and
you go in your tennis service it's not
happening it's not happening you take a
break you come back and you nail it
you're like wait what happened well you
needed time to set those circuits in
motion and allow them to do to rewiring
the sort of adaptation hypnosis seems to
capture both the high attentional State
and the deep relaxation at the same time
it's this very unusual State of Mind
where you're neither asleep nor awake
and in tight Focus or narrow focus and
it's very clear that it leads to these
rapid changes in Behavior because you're
rewiring the brain and the reason you're
able to rewire the brain so quickly is
because you're getting the trigger event
the focus and you're also getting the
relaxation event simultaneously and so
it's much faster than separating out the
learning trigger from the actual
rewiring of the brain my lab has a deep
interest and David Spiegel's lab has a
deep interest now and using respiration
or breathing to shift our state to
either heightened states of focus and
alertness to open up neuroplasticity I
want to just mention about the diaphragm
why it's so important for what were
these State changes is that a lot of
people talk about the vagus nerve and
all this stuff the Vegas and these
connections between the brain and this
vagus nerve or the gut
it's what gets activated when you're
really full and you eat a big meal and
you feel relaxed those are great but
it's very slow
the diaphragm is skeletal muscle just
like your bicep just like your tricep
just like your quadricep it is the only
internal organ except maybe a couple
muscles in your throat that are actually
skeletal muscle meaning it was designed
to be voluntarily moved and the
diaphragm isn't just designed to move
your lungs it also sends a signal
through the so-called phrenic nerve back
to the brain to inform your brain about
the status of your body so when you
breathe fast deliberately the reason you
feel kind of an elevated sense of
alertness is because yeah there are
chemicals secrete but mostly because the
phrenic nerve is firing off it's telling
you hey the body's moving we're really
running now even though you're
stationary in a chair if you're doing
breathing or if you're breathing very
slowly and rhythmically right box type
breathing or you know slow slow
breathing your diaphragm is telling your
brain hey we're calm we're good and you
calm down very quickly on the order of
seconds and so once you start tapping
into this you start realizing okay
movement of the body was designed to
inform the brain pain of where to be not
just the brain telling the body and how
does the body communicate with the brain
through the phrenic nerve from the
diaphragm so my lab is really pursuing
two questions and this is still being
worked out so I just want to highlight
that it's still in progress
but certain patterns of breathing will
calm you very much like entering a
hypnotic State and so you have a subset
of neurons in your brain stem that are
responsible for sighing is it you have a
subset of neurons in your brainstem
responsible for for coughing subset of
neurons responsible for laughter and a
subset of neurons in your brain stem for
sign this was a paper published in
nature this is a real thing these
neurons are every so often and your dog
does this too
you inhale twice
and then you exhale long
now that double inhaled best done
through the nose on the inhales and then
long exhale through the mouth activates
these PSI neurons that trigger the
so-called calming reflex the
parasympathetic arm of the nervous
system so we have a hardwired mechanism
a set of neurons connection to the
diaphragm and Back Again from the
diaphragm to the brain that was designed
to activate calm and when people ask me
how should I breathe to calm myself down
I would say double inhale through the
nose followed by exhales two or three of
those will reset your autonomic nervous
system faster than any other mechanism
we're aware of because it's really
capitalizing on a set of neural circuits
now once you're calm you say well how do
I get into plasticity states there you
want to go the other direction that's
going to be inhaling a lot more than you
exhale you're going to be driving in
more oxygen than you are breathing out
generally carbon dioxide and that will
lead to states that are kind of more
elevated this is typical of things like
tumor breathing Wim Hof breathing
Kundalini breathing and when people
enter those States
their whole world changes because it
shuts off the frontal cortex it really
this is why sometimes people pass out or
they feel like they want to get up and
move you know you get some odd behavior
when you're doing this kind of thing so
the key is if you want to access states
of heightened plasticity let's say you
want to learn faster where you want to
be more
um you want to bring more out of some
physical training that you're doing the
key is to apply those principles first
you need to focus you need to bring
yourself to that heightened state of
alertness you can breathe to do that so
this would be super oxygenated breathing
then you want to drop into a state of
calm and you do that by these a couple
maybe two or three rounds of inhale
inhale exhale inhale inhale exhale and
then now your brain is in a state we
believe this is still again being worked
out in Labs like mine and David's that
then you're in a state for heightened
learning
because you're in a state where
neurochemicals like acetylcholine are
going to be at levels that are higher
than they typically would be things like
noradrenaline slightly higher than they
typically would be but not in a
discombobulated way in a very regulated
way and the cool thing is you're
regulating them so you could argue you
know earlier we were talking about
subjective emotions and thoughts and all
these things but one thing that's
absolutely concrete is breathing I
always think of physical exercise
movement writing whatever singing
dancing talking those are physical
actions in the universe
then you have thought and somewhere in
between those is controlling your
respiration once you can control
everything that's within the confines of
your skull and skin once you can really
control that relationship that brain
body relationship you start to realize
that relationship is a lot like any
other relationship to forward action
it's just all happening within the
confines of my body so it's heightened
states of focus followed by states of
relaxation that are going to prime your
nervous system for learning in
plasticity just like hypnosis
sorry for the long-winded discussion do
don't you dare apologize that is some of
the most powerful and useful information
literally ever if I finish a chapter
I will stop for a moment and I'll just
kind of smile and laugh at myself I'm
big on like self-reflection with humor
and just think this is crazy you know my
brain is under my control there would be
people out there that say there's no
free will but I I do not believe that I
put my hands in a lot of brains you
stimulate certain brain areas people do
things you stimulate other brain areas
people think things
ultimately unless you have electrodes in
your head and someone's stimulating them
we are in control of our thoughts and
behaviors we can't control all of them
but my goal is to be as you know
deliberate and non-reflexive as possible
in life that's my goal from when I wake
up in the morning until I go to sleep
how do we get to that place
little by little and by rewarding each
thing if you get up and you used to make
the bed exam make the bed you're you're
not back on your heels you make cup of
coffee you sit down you script out
something in a journal you exercise
maybe you call a relative that you think
might need to hear from you or that
you'd like to talk to you do something
in a deliberate way just being
deliberate and learning to push away the
things that are trying to make you
reflexive is so important so I really
believe that we all have some superpower
that reflects maybe this is a bit of a
scientific explanation that reflects the
fact that our biology
is tilted in some Direction people often
thinks about their biology being tilted
in a direction that doesn't serve them
like oh you know my parents were this
and my you know or I'm not a good
athlete or I'm whatever but
it's also tilted in the direction of
something really special so like when I
was a kid
of that age I was fascinated by animals
I was just like my and so
had I learned to listen to that more I
used to hide my interest in animals
because I thought it was kind of not it
wasn't cool like I didn't play the
guitar in college I didn't surf I always
like like I can tell you all these facts
about mustelids and ferrets like what
good is that but like you know
but I think that kind of leaning that
kind of tilt towards like huh like
that's me like you resonate with
something and I'm not the first to say
this I think Robert Greene also said
this like there's a adults will often
remember back to a time where they
interacted with something sometimes it's
an object or sometimes it's an
experience and it just felt so good like
it kind of Drew you in I would tell your
young listeners to and viewers to really
pay attention to that it can seem almost
trivial like it's rarely about the thing
you're looking at or the thing you're
doing but sometimes it's the sensation
of running sometimes it's it's the
sensation of viewing seeing something or
hearing something because there's a hint
there and it's the it's not really about
what you're looking at or you're doing
it's that feeling like learn it that
feeling is your compass like that's your
true north because that's the feeling
you want to get to for to find you know
the mate for your life the you know the
partner for your life the the career
track and over time you're gonna pivot
right I mean you're not gonna get it on
the first try I eventually my story of
science started there it told me right
there I I felt it in that conversation
with my dad and then my compass was all
over the place and spinning and
eventually it's it's come back I found
it but getting in get in touch with that
feeling and if this seems at all
abstract I would do it as an experiment
I would sit in a chair and I would think
about something you don't like
really don't like and I would pay
attention to what that feels like in
your mind and in your body I'm not a
very somatic person I'm not somebody who
like feels stuff at the level of the
body I've always felt like my emotions
were in my head so when people talk like
their emotions in their other places I'm
just like I'm like I don't get it but I
would encourage them to think about that
and then I would encourage them to think
about something they really like
that could be roller coasters could be
music could be get specific and to get
in touch with that feeling and that
feeling is your guide that feeling is
your compass because the nervous system
it's not mystical the nervous system
will Orient toward the things that it's
best equipped to do
it really will
and I really animals do this naturally
my Bulldog Costello never tries to be a
different kind of dog he never fetched
once first time I threw the ball he
walked to the ball he sat down with the
ball he destroyed the ball because
that's what Bulldogs do
you know throw to a retriever they bring
it back because the brain of the
retriever is wired to feel good by
retrieving it and the brain of the
Bulldog is good to feel good by being
horizontal with and pulling on things
with their they like to tug
so I think humans we're so we're similar
enough but we're different in the sense
that you have something installed in you
that feels right and getting in touch
with that feeling is key and you're not
and I should tell that there's you're
not going to get it right away this is a
practice you learn like shooting
basketballs or or math you do it over
and over so that but if you get started
young at eight or nine oh my goodness
great and if you do it when you're 12 or
even if you're 60 and you do this you'll
find that pretty soon you start steering
in these directions and I I do believe
it's a nervous I think our it's a neural
there's a real physical substrate for
this I it's not mysticism
breathing and vision also run in Reverse
meaning if we change our pattern of
breathing we change our inner state
if our state changes our breathing
changes so it's reciprocal it's
bi-directional likewise with vision when
we are excited or stressed the aperture
of our visual window shrinks we get that
soda straw view of the world when we are
relaxed the aperture of our vision
expands but as well it runs in both
directions if we expand our view of the
world literally Force our our visual
field or just it's very easy actually
you can do it no matter where you are
right now if you just try and expand
your visual field not by looking around
or moving your header eyes but by trying
to see yourself in the environment that
you're in so you literally dilate your
views you could see the ceiling and the
floor and the walls if you're inside or
if you're Outdoors seeing as big an
aperture of your visual field or your
visual environment as possible so you're
directing your attention to even though
you might remain looking straight ahead
you're just directing your attention to
as wide a peripheral view horizontally
and vertically as possible is that what
you mean that's right exactly so
essentially if you keep your head and
eyes mostly stationary you don't have to
be you know rigid about rock steady but
if you look forward and you expand your
field of view so you kind of relax your
eyes so that you can see as much of your
environment around you as possible to
the point where you can see yourself in
that environment what you do is you are
turning off the attentional and believe
it or not the stress mechanisms that
drive your internal State towards stress
this is why when you go to a a Vista or
you view a horizon it's very relaxing
because you naturally go into panoramic
vision
when you are indoors you're looking at
your phone you're looking at computer or
a camera or something of that sort or
you're talking to somebody or an intense
conversation you may not notice it but
your entire visual field shrinks to a
much smaller aperture and that drives an
increase in alertness in internal State
and we sometimes call that stress if
it's a negative experience if it's a
positive experience we might call that
love or Obsession or Fascination but the
important thing to realize is that both
vision and breathing
have a profound and very rapid effect on
our internal State of Mind and Body and
it runs in both directions our internal
state that could be triggered by a text
message or hearing something that
somebody says tries changes in our
breathing and our vision but our
breathing and our vision can also Drive
changes in our internal State and so
that article in Scientific American was
a discussion about how we can leverage
the visual system and the respiration
the breathing system in order to take
control over our internal State because
it's not just that 2020 was stressful
it's that our internal State determines
everything it doesn't just determine if
we feel like we're having a hard time
falling asleep or having a hard time
focusing for instance it also determines
how we batch time how we analyze where
we are in the world in terms of our
lifespan a good example this would be
when we are very stressed we find sliced
time this is why when people are in a
car accident or something they might
report that things were in slow motion
they're actually your frame rate
increases whereas when you're very
relaxed your frame rate slows down and
when we are relaxed we get so-called
perspective
we are able to say well this too shall
pass or oh I can place this stressful
event in a context so one thing that's
just fundamental to how our nervous
system works is that we are constantly
placing our experience both our
immediate and past experience as well as
our anticipation of the future into some
sort of larger context and our visual
system literally how we are viewing the
world at that moment dictates how we
create perspective in terms of states of
Mind sounds a little bit abstract but
it's actually it boils right down to
Optics of the eye and very concrete
things like how you move your eyes and
how you view the world understanding
that pain and pleasure in this really
dynamic balance can also help us which
in the following way any pain that you
feel the longer day the less sleep the
the kind of Agony that things aren't
working that power outlet doesn't work
or the Internet is slow whatever it is
the amount of pleasure that you will
eventually experience
is directly relation related excuse me
to how much pain you experience so we
know this from actually what nowadays
would be considered quite barbaric and
unethical experiments where they would
give people electrical shocks and they
would measure their response and then
they say we're going to increase it
we're going to increase it eventually
they get to the point where a slight a
shock that was previously very painful
actually evokes a sense of pleasure now
you couldn't do these experiments
anymore these are not the experiments I
do in my lab and these are older
experiments but for instance I and this
has been discussed in scientific
research papers giving somebody uh like
a 10 minute ice bath for instance or
even a three-minute ice bath where a one
minute ice bath is quite painful but
there was a study from the University of
Prague a European Journal of physiology
showed that after a painful ice bath
stimulus
the amount of dopamine release goes up
for two and a half hours to 250 percent
above Baseline and that's not because
the ice bath itself evokes dopamine
release a lot of people think oh cold
water evokes dopamine release No Pain
evokes dopamine release after the pain
is over yesterday I tweaked my back
because I do this stupid thing every few
years the same stupid thing and it's
really painful and then you just
remember all the ways in which you can't
move around I was like standing up this
morning I'm like ah and just walking is
so painful as the pain has started to
dissipate you get a little bit of a high
right you get a little bit of a Euphoria
that's dopamine because of the the
degree of pain you experienced
previously predicts how much pleasure so
when you start a company down in the
dregs and you're shoveling again
that's beautiful because that means that
the win that you achieve is going to be
as good or greater than the one you had
previously in your case with Quest and
so we go back to this example the person
that's not motivated that can't get off
the couch that doesn't want to do
anything well this is the problem we
remember the rad experiment they are
effectively the rat with no dopamine but
they can still achieve some sense of
pleasure by consuming excess calories by
consuming social media and look I'm not
judging I do this stuff too right
scrolling social media if you've ever
scrolled social media and you're like I
don't even know why I'm doing this it
doesn't really feel that good
and I can remember a time where you'd
see something it was just so cool or you
see something online I remember this
when TED Talks first came out I was like
this is amazing these are some at least
some of them are really smart people
sharing really cool insights and then
now that they're like a gazillion TED
Talks I remember spending a winter in my
office at when I was a junior Professor
cleaning my office finally and binging
TED talks in the background thinking
this is a good use of my time pretty
soon they all sucked to me I was like
this isn't good so what you need to do
is stop watching Ted docs for a while
weight and then they become interesting
again and that's this pain pleasure
balance and so for people that aren't
feeling motivated the problem is they're
not motivated but they're getting just
enough or excess sustenance so they're
getting the little mild hits of opio it
becomes an opioid system and if you
think about the opioid drugs as opposed
to dopamine dopaminergic drugs
dopaminergic drugs make people rapid for
everything you know drugs of abuse like
cocaine and amphetamine make people
incredibly outward directed right they
hardly notice anything except what they
want more of more it's very it's bad
because those drugs trigger so much
dopamine release that they become the
reward it's very circular the only the
drug can give that much dopamine nothing
they could pursue would give them as
much dopamine as the drug itself
so there's that and then there's the
kind of opioid like effects of
constantly indulging oneself with social
media or with video games or with uh
with food or with anything to the point
where it no longer evokes the motivation
in craving and this is really the New
Evolution of the understanding of
dopamine and Neuroscience which is that
dopamine itself is not the reward it's
the build up to the reward and the
reward has more of a kind of opioid
Bliss like property which itself is not
bad if it's endogenous released from
within but when we can just sit there
like they're like the rat with no
dopamine gorging ourselves with
Pleasures so to speak what you end up
with is somebody that feels really
unmotivated and those Pleasures no
longer work to tickle those feel-good
circuits and so there's no reason for
them to go out and pursue anything and
that's a pretty dark picture so the the
keys are to pursue rewards but
understand that the pursuit is actually
the reward if you want to have repeated
wins okay you the celebration has to be
less than the pursuit and that's hard
for some people to do they you know they
it's got to be that your celebration is
slightly less dopaminergic it can be
very reflective you can be in gratitude
those are other neurotransmitter systems
but you don't want to be on that high as
you celebrate the win
you want to be
trickling out your dopamine regularly
until you pursue things there are other
goals that are very different last time
we talked you were learning Spanish yeah
still learning yes still learning and
there's a and there's a little bit more
friction there because it's very
challenging it takes more effort to lean
in because you when you don't already
know how to do something it's a very
different goal Pursuit right it's sort
of like uh so if I already have my
business and I've been running it for a
few years you know certain practices of
how to get to where you've been that's
right and you're thinking how do I
double my business that's right it's
different than I'm trying to learn a
whole new skill goal right you already
know how to forage for water yes as
opposed to your some young calf or some
animal that needs to learn how to walk
right so you so I think
you know one big goal of the sort that
um you know we don't actually have the
skill set yet we're not even aware that
of what we need in order to accomplish
it per year seems like a pretty good
goal to me so learning entirely new
language or an entirely new physical
skill but with any long-term goal the
problem is remember don't focus on your
destination that's right well so you
have to move the Horizon in but you have
to remember there's that one little
Pitfall that cul-de-sac that I described
where you'll tell people this year I'm
going to do blank and if they reward you
enough you might not do it remember if
you get enough dopamine it's amazing I'm
so happy you're doing that
congratulations and you say I know I can
do it and then you don't you sort of
lose the incentive to do it so some yeah
A lot's been made out of making goals
public is it is it better to make them
public or not well so this is this is a
question I don't know I think that in my
case it has
um for me telling people several people
that I'm going to do something because I
will work very hard to avoid
um
but I tend to do that with things I
really want to do anyway but there's a
strong fear element like I'm afraid to
do this or I'm I'm kind of anxious about
doing this so I'll tell people and then
I'm like okay now I'm committed yeah and
I tell people that I'm certain they're
going to give me a hard time yeah that's
just my nature right
um and I'm not trying to prove them
wrong I'm just trying to make sure that
they don't have any ground to stand on
yeah and that's how I do it I think for
some people
the continuation of what they're already
doing if it's feeling like a lot of work
it's feeling exceedingly challenging and
they're like oh my God another year of
this another five years of that I think
that's when you have to move the Horizon
in really close and I think a lot of
people right now are feeling back on
their heels because 2020 was such a
trying year for a lot of people so
everyone many people are recalibrating
what's possible although many people are
feeling expansion and they're really
going to go forward Full Steam so I
think continuing in Pursuits that will
already have some degree of Mastery over
and thinking about where could I Notch
that up another two or three percent I
think that's incredibly valuable I think
that provides a lot of value to the
individual to their families and to
society really because a two percent
Improvement of like what you're already
doing is going to have an outsized
effect on what other people receive
right even though for you you've been
down that road many times but taking on
a new pursuit in parallel to that means
really getting excited about the
possibility you give the Jim Carrey
example about the possibility and
starting to imagine what that would
actually be like to be well let's say
fluent in Spanish and you can just do
this reflexively without having to try
that's totally within your reach and I
think there it makes sense to really
think about the end point quite a lot as
a way to get over those barriers of sure
of fear because when you already know
how to do something there's no fear
barrier yeah it's just an energy barrier
right but when you don't know how to do
something there's all this sense of
clunkiness that is really uncomfortable
beginner's mind is a painful place
that's so hard man a lot of people think
about it like beginner's mind is such a
you know it's such a delightful place to
be so hard the friction the amount of
energy to build momentum is so
challenging in the beginning well this
is where play becomes very important
because like you know the great
physicists you know Richard Feynman was
also famous in addition to being a you
know a physics Phenom for having the
sense of play learn to Bongo drama late
in life he was became an artist late in
life and he had this lightness in this
and this kind of Joyful Way to approach
things humor at oneself is incredibly
powerful now we know the chemical basis
for that laughing at oneself is often
the best way to move forward really yeah
because you you I mean I do this well
maybe I don't know maybe I'm biased but
I do this all the time I'll just laugh
at myself for how worked up I can get
about the fact that a file won't load or
something like that I just laugh it's
crazy I mean and all of a sudden I have
the energy to do it so what does that do
for our brain when we laugh at ourself
but not but there's probably a
difference between laughing ourselves or
something like that versus
making fun of something that's a bad
habit like always shaming her not
shaming ourselves yeah because I'm 200
pounds overweight let me laugh at myself
the shame is kind of written into like
who we are it's not about what we're
doing it has this element of like who we
are you know guilt is sort of more about
I forget who said this but it wasn't me
first I just want to be clear I
recognize it wasn't me first guilt is
sort of more about
um what we did you know shame is is like
an identity thing um laughing on herself
yeah like laughing ourselves like how
ridiculous the human mind can be I mean
let's face it as brilliant as as the the
nervous system in our minds and our
bodies can be they make a lot of
mistakes yeah we are a fallible species
we're not a perfect
species and Perfection should never be
the goal sleep is the fundamental layer
of mental and physical health
if there's one thing that we should all
be doing is working toward
sleeping long enough and deeply enough
80 percent of the time okay I think that
80 is a good goal yeah because things
happen yeah right you're gonna travel
the weekend you're going out or whatever
yeah yeah until you are sleeping long
enough and deeply enough
eighty percent of the nights of your
life you are functioning sub-optimally
and what what's the biggest risk then if
we're not getting enough sleep okay so
there are a number of risks to not
getting enough sleep deficits and
learning deficits in the immune system
reduction in testosterone and estrogen
in both men and women so disruption of
hormones disruption of gut microbiome
increased cancer risk there are a bunch
of things
the severity of those things depends on
a lot of other things too prior Health
other health conditions uh context age
um occupation you know if you're not
getting enough sleep in your high-rise
construction worker different than if
you're an office worker okay so
um
we need to sleep enough now what's
enough sleep this is an interesting
question enough sleep
has been argued at six hours other
people it's seven hours other people
it's eight hours it's basically waking
up without an alarm clock and feeling
rested insomnia
is a actually a medical term
nowadays and insomnia is essentially
diagnosed as falling asleep during the
middle of the day due to lack of sleep
at night time but many people who are
having trouble sleeping at night are not
falling asleep during the middle of the
day they're dealing with grogginess or
crankiness or other effects of having
fragmented sleep what are the what are
the main causes of not being able to
fall asleep is it rumination is it
traumas that you're holding on to is its
arguments is it
self-doubt or insecurities is it you nap
too much is it the foods you ate too
late like what would you say are the
main causes
of not being able to fall asleep all of
the above
but the the primary one is a failure to
turn off your thoughts okay and I think
that might provide a good Anchor Point
for us to talk about some protocols
really a excellent night's sleep begins
in the morning I talked about this on
the previous episode so I won't go into
detail but everyone should get as much
bright light in their eyes ideally from
sunlight first thing in the morning 10
to 30 minutes outside depending on how
bright it is
eyeglasses or contact lenses are fine
don't wear sunglasses if you can do it
safely if you wake up before the sun
rises turn on bright lights then go
outside once the sun rises if you have
no access to sunlight use a daytime
simulator or similar like a ring light
and get that light in your eyes Okay so
that's all of that in a compact form
caffeine you can inhibit falling asleep
with caffeine you have to figure out
when your threshold is for me I can
drink caffeine up until about three even
four o'clock in the afternoon and sleep
like a baby and still sleep well yes
it's Matt Walker our good friend Matt
Walker would say that my sleep isn't as
good as as it would be had I cut
caffeine out earlier by like 11 or 12
yeah am right and and I I want to
acknowledge you know Matt is the Michael
Jordan of sleep science and so I'm not
gonna you're the LeBron James yeah well
no no and uh in Fair thank you for the
the compliment but uh but no I'm not
um I know a lot of the science and the
protocols but but that's Matt's
wheelhouse and so
um if he says something it's true and if
I say something and and our opinions
conflict it's likely to be something
that the data are still emerging or in
in that case default to Matt being
correct because I yeah just out of uh
due respect for his expertise so
caffeine you know for some people they
can have a two o'clock espresso 2PM
espresso some people it's 4 P.M some
people can drink caffeine at 8 pm and
fall asleep but there I would say um
it's problematic because you're
disrupting the architecture of sleep and
the brain waves associated with sleep
the chemicals and so forth so get that
morning light
cut your caffeine off at the time that
allows you to fall asleep
that Morning Light also sets a timer on
your melatonin Rhythm so you have this
gland in your brain called the pineal
gland that pineal is the source of
melatonin melatonin makes you sleepy but
it does not keep you asleep okay
melatonin starts to rise in the late
evening and
continues into the night and then
eventually tapers off this is naturally
occurring melatonin release not
supplemented in melatonin release
fastest way to slam melatonin into the
pavement and eliminate it in your system
is to look at bright light for I hate to
tell you this even a few seconds
so
you mean at night
any at night is typically when melatonin
Rises it's when it's released in the
bloodstream and when it has this effect
of making us sleepy it does a number of
other things you want more melatonin at
night is right right you do and if you
wake up in the middle of the night or
it's eight o'clock and you decide you
want to go to bed at nine or it's nine
o'clock you want to go to bed at 10 you
go into the bathroom and you flip on the
bright lights your melatonin levels just
got crushed down having lights on is a
the worst thing you can do yes and it
doesn't matter if it's blue light red
light purple light green light bright
lights inhibit melatonin very acutely
and therefore you want to avoid exposure
to bright lights at night if your goal
is to be asleep so that simple rule that
governs all this stuff is when you want
to be alert get bright light in your
eyes ideally from sunlight so that's
true in the morning and throughout the
day and when you want to be sleepy or
asleep avoid bright light in your eyes
now many home environments don't allow
you to have zero lights
and that's not actually necessary you
can just dim the lights in the evening
ideally you also avoid overhead lights
because the neurons in the eye that
trigger this melatonin suppression uh
and so forth they reside in an area of
the eye that views upper visual space so
you could have desk lamps or
um and just dim those down if you're
going to work on a screen dim it way
down will blue blockers help yes but if
the light is bright enough they it's
still going to go you're still going to
inhibit melatonin really there's an
interesting study that was published
recently
um just came out and uh that shows that
actually memory and uh recall for
material that's consumed on a phone is
much lower than right on the written
page and there's an interesting
um reason that they they give for this
you know there could be a lot of reasons
I just want to point that out but they
monitored breathing and they monitored
heart rate and they monitored some other
physiological signals while people were
either reading on a smartphone or
reading paper and what they found was
that but breathing was essentially
normal or equivalent in both conditions
meaning people breathe the same way
whether or not they're reading on their
smartphone or reading from a written
page but there was a particular category
of of breath that was abolished by
reading on the smartphone and this is
what is referred to as physiological
size
talk a lot about physiological size on
the podcast in my lab works on them this
is a spontaneous innate pattern of
breathing that's governed by a little
subset of neurons in in the brain stem
for those who want to know this is a
brain stem area called the parafatial
nucleus discovered by Jack Feldman at
UCLA who's the world expert in the
neural mechanisms of respiration and
this low collection of neurons probably
only 100 neurons or so make sure that
every three to five minutes you do
what's called a physiological side which
is a very deep breath sometimes followed
by another short inhale so
and then a long exhale and the double
deep breath with a very deep breath
reinflates the little sacs in the lungs
your lungs aren't just too big bags of
air they actually have hundreds of
millions of little sacks that we call
the avioli of the lungs and when you
don't do these physiological size
so in the second or third minute after
not having done a physiological PSI
these little sacs collapse and they're
kind of moist on the inside so you can
imagine trying to blow open a balloon
that's moist on the inside you need a
little bit of added air pressure and so
the size reinflate those and then on the
exhale allow you to offload carbon
dioxide now this happens even during
sleep every three to five minutes and
I've talked a lot about physiological
size as a what I think is really a
terrific real-time tool for reducing
anxiety and calming oneself down indeed
it works very well we have a study
that's out for review now it's a
collaborative work with David Spiegel
and Psychiatry but it but it points out
that these physiological size can be
used double inhale through the nose long
exhale through the mouth to calm down
and it works very well because you
offload carbon dioxide now in this study
about smartphone reading versus reading
on paper what they found is that people
stop engaging in physiological size
during any time they're reading on the
smartphone now it wasn't a perfect study
because they probably also should had a
tablet and a laptop condition so it's
not clear whether or not it's due only
to the reduced aperture of the visual
window that you're narrowing your
attention and there's this sort of app
almost like an apnea a kind of starving
of yourself or oxygen when you do this
but it's very clear I mean it's
abundantly clear that two things one is
nasal breathing and that the other is
getting sufficient oxygen to the brain
is important for comprehension so the
takeaway from this is if ever possible
try and read from a written page and if
you uh or from a book or a piece of
paper and if you can't do that then try
and access whatever you're learning from
as large a screen as you can manage in
that particular environment right and I
do realize when people are commuting you
know and sometimes I'm guilty of looking
at my phone and trying to read papers
and passages on my phone but it's
interesting because this study
highlights the the linkage between this
visual Attention our respiration and the
fact that you know our body and our
brain have these innate mechanisms for
making sure that we're getting
sufficient oxygen we're getting
sufficient blood flow to the brain areas
that are required for Learning and so
again I don't want to de-emphasize the
fact that there is a lot of legitimate
clinically diagnosed ADHD out there but
for a lot of people that are struggling
with attention or they feel like they
just can't focus I think we all owe it
to ourselves to ask well what kind of
environment am I creating for myself
that is depriving me of this focus and
what simple things can I do to try and
enhance my ability of focus because I'm
personally of the belief that if
possible and wherever it's not hazardous
to start with behavioral tools right
before ever moving to supplementation or
prescription drugs unless there's a real
dire need I would think that behavioral
tools should be the most valuable for
the simple reason that when you engage
in a behavior over and over again you
get neuroplasticity your brain circuits
change and get better simply taking a
drug or a supplement of any kind
although they can have their value isn't
going to rewire your brain in the ways
that you want you are essentially
dependent on that chemistry in order to
access the state that you want the whole
process of neuroplasticity and learning
is really a two-stage process first
there must be focus and alertness that
focus and alertness is associated with
the release of neurochemicals so-called
neuromodulators things like
acetylcholine in particular and which
sort of acts as a highlighter pen if you
will for certain Connections in the
brain to later be reinforced and the
neurochemical adrenaline which is also
called epinephrine also depending on if
you're in the UK or elsewhere a long
interesting story not for this time
about why it has multiple names
epinephrine also called adrenaline is
associated with an increase in kind of
agitation and alertness acetylcholine
think of it as kind of a spotlight or a
highlighter pen for certain Connections
in the brain so you need alertness and
focus and then the second stage is that
it is only during periods of depressed
in particular sleep and something that I
call non-sleep deep rest which I've
given an acronym because scientists like
acronyms nsdr non-sleep depressed things
like Yoga Nidra things like shallow naps
things like forms of meditation that
don't involve a lot of focused
concentration you're a far more the
experienced meditator than I so I'm
outside my wheelhouse when talking about
meditation but it is only periods of
intense focus and alertness followed by
periods of depressed that allow the
nervous system to change and there is an
abundance of evidence for that so that's
the first thing to understand the brain
actually rewires during deep sleep and
rest because during deep sleep and rest
naps Yoga Nidra deep sleep there's a
replay of the very same cells in the
brain that were active during learning
oftentimes in Reverse for reasons that
are still not understood but at a much
higher repetition rate so you're
actually getting repetitions while you
sleep this is why one will strain to
learn a language or a motor skill or
maths or something like that over and
over and over it doesn't happen you take
a couple nights sleep take a break from
and all of a sudden it's there it's
because it happens in rest now there's
some other things that one can do to
enhance this process further that are
arrive to us from good data first of all
there's a so-called ultradian Rhythm
which is the 90-minute Cycles during
which we can focus pretty well for a
duration of about 90 minutes of course
flickering in and out of focus nobody
really focuses for 90 minutes straight
unless they've built up that capacity or
they are very interested in what they're
learning right they're just wrapped with
attention usually people flicker in and
out and of course nowadays there's a lot
of literature and ideas about ways to
maintain Focus put the phone away limit
noise some people like background noise
some people like music some don't it's
very contextual highly individualized
yeah
but 90 minutes is sort of the the batch
of time that the brain can focus really
hard on one thing before it needs a true
rest of an hour or two before you can go
back to learning or working very hard
the other thing is that um there are
some very interesting data showing that
shallow naps or nsdr non-sleep deep rest
done within four hours of one of these
90-minute learning bouts can be very
beneficial for accelerating learning and
then there are these uh incredible data
on so-called Gap effects so there have
been studies now of of skills that are
physical skills mental skills where
people will for instance try to learn
scales on the piano or a math problem or
a spatial problem or a physical skill
and then at random every so often a
buzzer will go off and the person will
just be told to do nothing sit their
eyes closed or eyes open and do nothing
just stop the learning process for about
10 seconds and then return to doing what
they're doing these are these little
micro rests it turns out that during
those micro rests the hippocampus of
brain areas you know that's associated
with learning and memory and the
neocortex also associated with learning
and memory
undergoes replay of the thing that the
individual is trying to learn at 20
times the speed also in Reverse just as
in sleep and that has can lead and has
been shown to lead to accelerations in
learning so there are these ways I
wouldn't even think of them as hacks
because the word hack is a little tricky
because when I think of the word hack it
seems like doing something with an
object or a tool that wasn't designed
for that purpose right
um the nervous system already Harbors
these mechanisms and one can access them
through these little micro rests so
whether or not you're a child or an
adult every so often when trying to
learn something just pause for 10
seconds or so do your best to just clear
your mind of course it's very hard to
clear the mind but
um do your best to clear the mind and
then go back to the learning task as as
it were and that has been shown to very
to significantly accelerate the learning
process and the retention of newly
learned information and then the last
thing you touched on earlier which is
this notion of incremental learning you
said you like to throw yourself into
something as kind of a litmus test of
whether or not you enjoy it or not
turns out that from beautiful work done
by my colleague at Stanford School of
Medicine Eric Knudsen has shown that yes
it's true that early in development in
humans this would be up until the
mid-20s we can learn things in larger
batches and much more easily than we can
later in life however if one batches
that work into smaller increments
and for so for instance deciding maybe
set a timer turning the phone off
otherwise and saying I'm going to spend
three minutes just three minutes in
trying to intensely learn this thing
even if I feel like I'm failing if one
does that repeatedly those little
increments of learning can lead to an
outsized amount of learning overall and
so the nervous system loves incremental
learning it loves to batch things into
focused little bouts and you know if
that's already the the tools that you've
built up which it sounds like you have
wonderful but if somebody is out there
trying you know struggling to learn
really trying to break things down into
very brief periods of intense Focus that
is the cue by which during sleep the
nervous system will change itself and
this has been shown over and over and
over again even in very late life uh
individuals and people in there you know
we like to think life could go on
further than this but people in their
80s and 90s still have neuroplasticity
there's even evidence that new neurons
can be produced in the hippocampus of
people in their late 80s and 90s so the
capacity is there so non-sleep deep rest
nsdr is an acronym that I coined because
it encompasses a lot of practices that
are not meditation per se
but that bring the brain and body into a
state of relaxation and focus so
hypnosis is one variant of nsdr there
are other variants of nsdr you can just
look these up and you'll find them and I
think that they've caught on and that
the Google the CEO of Google uh is an
avid practitioner of nsdr
because it has this amazing ability to
reset your energy levels and focus
whereas with meditation many people find
meditation hard and part of the reason
they find it hard is that it requires
focus nsdr is a state which is very calm
and relaxing you don't have to work too
hard you're just listening to a script
whereas most forms of meditation not all
but most forms of meditation involve
cranking up the activity in your
prefrontal cortex and trying to see your
thoughts as opposed to thinking your
thoughts or
um focus on your breath but then third
personing yourself in some respect and
that's work and so many people who
meditate quite intensely feel more
exhausted now that doesn't mean that
meditation doesn't have any utility but
it's distinctly different than nsdr and
I think that people are working
certainly the CEO of Google after
imagine is working very hard and using
his forebrain if he's going to have 20
or 30 minutes to take a break
he should and I think this is what he's
doing he should go out for a jog and not
listen to anything and just kind of let
his mind wander or sit there in a chair
and just zone out or do nsdr the problem
is
people are not that good at shifting
States
we are all actually pretty good at even
people with severe ADHD read an episode
about this can become hyper focused on
things that they actually enjoy
because dope and most of the drugs
designed to treat ADHD are drugs that
increase the levels of dopamine so when
you like something there's dopamine
release and you can focus it's when you
don't like something that's hard to
focus shifting States is hard I'm sure
you've experienced this if you've ever
been in deep research or podcasting
podcasting and then all of a sudden you
go for a run you'll probably spend the
first third of that run thinking and
then in the middle third you're kind of
that thinking is is fractured a bit and
then in the final third is where you
finally get to relax because the brain
doesn't shift States very quickly we can
go from sleep to wakefulness quickly we
can go from wakefulness to sleep quickly
but we don't shift between different
states of Consciousness like a step
function
um except in rare cases right fear is
one all of a sudden we hear an explosion
right now it's a step function we're in
fear where we're in alertness right
um heightened state of alertness but
nsdr is terrific at allowing people to
learn to shift their state and I
actually would venture to argue that
part of the value of meditation and
exercise is the actual state that you
get into in deep meditation or exercise
but just as valuable is the transition
that you have to take yourself through
from one state of mind to the other and
then back again I when I look you know
David Goggins he always seems to come up
but he because he represents so many
important things Drive determination
override of emotional state going from
being a 300 pound plus person to a fit
person through he's never revealed
anything
substantial about what he ate or what he
didn't he's basically says like listen
run a lot eat less right
um
but what's remarkable is so much of what
he says is about those transitions about
taking oneself from a state of I don't
want to to scruffing oneself and like
you're going to do it anyway and then
being able to carry that into into
regular life so to speak so I think that
um nsdr is immensely powerful it's zero
cost and one of the reasons I'm such a
fan of people doing it is that most
people don't stick to a meditation
practice
there are also been a few cases you
might find this interesting there's a
book by Scott Carney I forget what it's
called I think it's called the
Transcendence trap or something I'm
gonna have that title wrong but
there have been a fair number of cases
of people that go and do very extensive
meditation silent meditation Retreats
who then return to normal life and end
up killing themselves
there are states of mind inside of
extended meditations or silent
meditations that are very beneficial and
I'm certainly not suggesting people
don't meditate but I know at least one
person who came back from one of these
long extended meditation Retreats and
wasn't able to shift their state back
into one that was functional in regular
life and that book includes a very
dramatic story I don't want to give it
away in case people
um check out the book but Scott told the
story to me directly once where
someone feels they've reached
enlightenment
and then commit suicide so these very
unusual brain states are are potentially
hazardous if people can't return from
them
we have to distinguish between
modulators and mediators and I'll do
this very briefly
there are a lot of things that will
modulate your state of focus but they
don't directly mediate your sense of
focus so for instance if right now a
fire alarm went off in this building it
would modulate our attention we would
get up and leave it would be very hard
to do what we're doing with that banging
in the background at least at first
so it's modulating Focus but it's not
really
involved in the mechanisms of Focus
right
in the same way being well rested when
you sleep your autonomic nervous system
that adjusts states of alertness and
focus and calm works better than when
you're sleep deprived so if you're
sleeping better you're going to focus
better so I always answer this way to a
question like this because the best
thing that anyone can do for their
mental health physical health and
performance in athletic or cognitive
Endeavors or creative Endeavors is to
make sure that you're getting enough
quality sleep
enough of the time for you and that's
going to differ we could talk about what
that means now in terms of things that
mediate Focus
without getting into the description of
mechanisms because we have podcasts
about that
it's very clear that mental focus
follows visual Focus provided that
you're a sighted person
much of the training that's being done
now in China to teach kids to focus
better literally has them stare at a
Target blinking every so often but
really training themselves to breathe
calmly and maintain a tight visual
aperture
when you read you have to maintain a
tight visual aperture you're literally
scrolling like a highlighter in your
mind's eye right it's kind of obvious
once you hear it so for people that have
problems focusing sleep well
learn to dilate and contract your visual
field consciously this can be done if
you practice it a little bit and then be
as I said before it is very hard to get
into a state of focus like a step
function immediately like snapping your
fingers what you can do is you can pick
any object but ideally an object at
roughly the same distance
placed at roughly the same distance to
which you're going to do that work and
stare at it you're allowed to Blink and
as your mind starts to drift every once
in a while to understand that's normal
but try and narrow your visual aperture
and bring that into your visual field so
that that's the most prominent thing
kind of like portrait mode in your phone
this would look very different in
portrait mode than it would in just a
standard photograph mode and then after
doing that for 30 to 60 seconds moving
into the work that you're about to do
and really Encourage Yourself to do that
if you're somebody who's low vision or
no vision you're going to use your ears
to do this Braille readers have trouble
focusing sometimes because they feel
other stuff and they hear other stuff so
you learn to adjust that aperture
consciously and then of course the
pharmacologic tools just enough caffeine
but not too much right we've talked
about white noise Brown Noise music or
no music really varies but it's very
clear that binaural beats of 40 hertz
can shift the brain into a heightened
state of focus and cognition so if
you're going to use binaural beats which
should definitely be used with
headphones
and there are a number of free apps out
there and sources uh 40 Hertz seems to
be the frequency that best supports the
brain shifting into a particular can you
give us the some some some binaural
beats yeah so you're going to look for
you'd want to find a uh an app that
offers 40 Hertz I think brainwave allows
you to
um slide bar up to the particular
frequency that you want and I should say
that um there are other frequencies that
are interesting but 40 Hertz binaural
beat seems to be the one that there's
the most quality research so it's a it's
like a b yeah oh yeah but you're saying
there's a lot of mixed science on the on
the yeah white noise you really should
be doing this with headphones because
binaural beats are best accomplished by
feeding two different frequencies to the
two ears and then you have What's called
the this brain stem area that reads out
what are called intraoral time
differences and then it extracts the the
the Delta essentially turn it up
and then in other things it can enhance
Focus so you know the pharmacology
around this is pretty interesting things
that tickle the dopamine pathway in the
acetylcholine pathway they work yeah
um there's your riddle in your Adderalls
your modafinils which are prescription
and there's a lot of non-prescription
use of those prescription drugs not so
much in my generation but in people 35
and younger you know I hear all the time
from day Traders and programmers and
stuff and kids that play video games a
lot of riddle and Adderall use
I think that unless it's prescribed by a
doctor for a specific purpose of ADHD I
don't think people should go that route
frankly hits the dopamine system way too
hard also has a number of negative
effects on sexual side effects all sorts
of things that you just wouldn't want
there are a few compounds like Alpha GPC
um 300 milligrams to 600 milligrams of
alpha GPC with a cup of espresso if
you're well rested you're like a laser
for 90 minutes maybe two hours but then
it's going to taper off and you have to
just recognize that and then there's
this whole world of nootropics now and
people trying to figure out the racetams
per acetams and phenol ethylamine
combined with this and you know it's not
quite in the place where you'd like it
to be there are a few companies that are
doing this better than others we talk
about some of these on the podcast but
um I would always start with behavioral
tools and then consider pharmacology and
and then I suppose the the other thing
for focus is um they're these this is a
little more esoteric but we cover this
in an episode on workplace optimization
um where you place your screen is
important staring down at a screen is
not going to be as effective as placing
it at eye level or above you when the
eyes are up literally your eyes are
directed forward or up the brainstem
centers for alertness are activated when
your eyes are down it's actually you're
you're sort of it's like being pulled
underwater a little bit in the autonomic
arousal sense it's you're closing your
eyes I mean um is one it reflects the
brainstem centers that are active
becoming less or for for alert and
excuse me becoming less active but
there's a really cool effect that's
active in this room right now which is
that there's been some really
interesting studies that when people
work in small compact spaces or wear a
hoodie or a hat that can also improve
focus like blinders on a horse for
obvious reasons now based on what I said
before but also
analytic work or the kind of work where
there's a correct answer that you're
seeking is best supported by these kind
of low ceiling environments whereas
there's something called the cathedral
effect which is when you work in an
outdoor environment or a high ceiling
environment it lends itself to kind of
pun intended kind of loftier ideas and
more creativity and that probably has to
do with the fact that there's a natural
tendency a reflex to expand your visual
field in these high ceiling environments
expansion of the visual field
changes the way the brain works in the
time domain your engineering and biology
oriented listeners will understand this
for the and music for those that don't
the best way to think about it is when
you have a narrow Focus portrait mode on
your phone or you're very alert you are
fine slicing life in time it's like a um
think of it as a high frame rate like
you're shooting in slow motion when you
have a uh when you dilate your your view
you're taking bigger time bins and the
one way to just let this hopefully land
home is that if you've ever had a really
exciting day or podcast interview or
experience of any kind your system is
flooded with dopamine and norepinephrine
alertness and motivation all this
excitement it seems like it goes by very
very fast and yet when you think back to
that it seems like a lot happened this
happened and that happened now think
about waiting in the doctor's office in
a blank waiting room with no interesting
art on the walls it feels like it goes
by very very slow dopamine and
norepinephrine are all time low and yet
when you think back on that experience
it's as if nothing happened because you
were you were parsing time differently
so those are the roughly the tools and
the and the neurochemicals around time
perception and the time domain uh
there's a wonderful book I'm forgetting
the title so wonderful I forget the
title by Dean um blodomano from UCLA but
I think it's called the brain is a time
machine that talks about this expansion
and contraction of the time domain and
what you can do is to leverage it for
work and creativity Focus this is what
people from elite special forces can do
they know how to make small
simple
physical steps in the real world that
allow them to build on these reward
circuitries but they don't get
delusional about how they're doing they
they know they keep the end in mind but
they get very micro they move the
Horizon in very close and so if you can
move the Horizon to something you know
you can complete and you reward that you
essentially are where you were before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go you're not depleting you're
not spending out anything and it feels a
little weird because none of us like to
reward things that aren't external but
the ability to control these internal
reward schedules is everything there are
other things that if it's a physical
skill that you're trying to learn
as opposed to just a mental skill then
there's a whole Kingdom of things that
are fun for instance if it's a physical
skill you want to generate as many
repetitions as you safely can per unit
time so if you say I'm going to learn
dance you want the ball machine if
you're playing tennis exactly you
literally want to generate repetitions
and in particular you want to generate
failures every time you you give up bad
serve playing tennis oh yeah that
activates the circuits for focus and
alertness for the next yeah it's true
that's right so when you're losing
that's right so so that and a lot of
people don't like failures and so they
back away from it so remember the
nervous system will only change if you
give it a reason to do that and the
other one that's kind of an interesting
Twist on this is the way the nervous
system is wired is it wants to pass off
all of its work to circuits that are
reflexive as much as it can you don't
think about walking anymore because you
learned how to walk but when you were
learning you were very focused on sure
one of the things that can set the stage
for more plasticity overall is when you
disrupt the vestibular or the balance
system it does appear that whenever we
are physically off balance the brain is
primed to pay attention and the mil the
chemical milieu is such that it can
actually rewire itself faster and
whereas I think the 90s and 2000s
brought out a lot of important work on
saying hey
exercise of aerobic type or maybe even
weight training can create
neuroplasticity
it was that was great but it wasn't
directed enough it didn't say well what
kind of exercise yeah and what will get
me even more plasticity and so there are
some basal things about heart rate and
blood flow Etc but anything that
involves balance or coordination it's
incredible how fast the brain can learn
so things like dance martial arts a real
sport not just exercising and I'm not no
disrespect to the the expert I'm more of
a just an exerciser than a sport guy
um but if you're 40 50 60 80 whatever
learning a new physical skill
we know is tremendously powerful for
opening up neuroplasticity broadly so
some people will even leverage this
where after they finish some physical
skill learning or something they might
take a 20-minute nap and then they might
read and they might try something so
when we see these people they're
learning surfing I'm like 60 years old
and I'm like yeah exactly exactly I
learned started learning tennis when I
was 45 and it's really a challenge
because it's not automatic and I have to
really focus and be present well these
and these individual cases are are not
necessarily the place to hang our hat
completely but for instance the great
physicist Richard Feynman he was well
known for learning bongo drums in the
sick when he was in it was in the 60s
but in his 60s then he became a quite
accomplished um painter later in life
and you know his whole thing was
approach all of these things from a
standpoint of play with intense Focus
yeah and I think the play element is key
because the play element keeps the
agitation in check so that when you're
stepping on your partner's feet trying
to learn how to dance answer you're
failing miserably it it can frustration
is a real thing and so I think that the
element of playfulness some people call
it beginner's mind but I think that
should be the Anchor Point to return to
and people that maintain curiosity or I
should say that cultivate curiosity and
that cultivate a sense of play and
willingness to take on new vestibular
experiences of all things they
show very they show remarkable
plasticity into their late life and I
think that it all comes back to this
thing that the brain won't change unless
something changes in the weather of the
brain the overall milieu has to say oh
wait everything that's about to happen
is different yeah otherwise why would it
change because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for the five key habits to
improve your health check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there they said the blueprints of
life you know all diseases are created
from genes turns out less than five
percent more like one percent of people
on the planet are born with a genetic
condition like type 1 diabetes or